AFTER WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING- BEFORE WE BEGIN I
DO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ON PROVIDING TESTIMONY
AT TODAY'S HEARING. WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION. ON THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER FOR US TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF THIS
HEARING WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS. THE STIRS
RATHER WISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. WHAT ACCEPT
BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATEN VIOLENCE. EVEN VEILED
THREATS. AS WE PROCEED WITH THE
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER. AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING. YOUR PRIDE APPLY
THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR C. OUR
PROCEEDINGS. ALL MAIN WITNESSES
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN PERSON
WITHOUT TWO MAIN WITNESSES- FOR
A MAXIMUM OF THREE. AND IT'S
EACH. EXCEPTION OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. TO ALLOW
THREE WITNESS MAIN WITNESSES FOR
A MAXIMUM OF FIFTEEN MINUTES
EACH SIDE. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM OF ONE
MINUTE. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY CAN
BE MADE IN PERSON OR OVER THE
PHONE AFTER THE MAIN WITNESSES
HAVE PROVIDED THEIR TESTIMONY.
THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WILL BE
COMBINED AND NOT GROUPED BY
POSITION. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
FOR AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WILL
BE LIMITED TO SIXTY MINUTES. ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
THE BILL AT HAND. COMMENTS ON
OTER ISSUES WILL BE RULED OUT
OF ORDER AND YOUR TIME WILL
EXPIRE IMMEDIATELY. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECTED TO REMOVAL
RATHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. YOUR
CARPET COOPERATION WE HOPE
AUTHORS AND STAKEHOLDERS- WERE
RESPECT FOR THIS PROCESS. DUE TO
THE KOBE PANDEMIC AND WE HAVE
LIMITED SPACE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE TO OR ASK THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
WHEN YOU COMPLETE YOUR TESTIMONY
MAY EXIT THE HEARING ROOM A
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT THE SPACE
PERMITS. WE WERE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
AFTER THE MAIN WITNESS
TESTIMONY. THE CALLING NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE.
IS. TRY THAT AGAIN. IT IS THE
ACCESS.
OKAY IT'S A HOT MIKE- ANYWAY-
LET'S GO BACK.
HELLO OKAY THIS WE OKAY NOW. WE
THINK.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE LONG ENOUGH TO
HAVE GOES AS FAR AS I'M AWARE
BUT BUT APPARENTLY SOMEBODY IS
SO MESS WITH THIS LITTLE BIT
TODAY. SO WE'LL GO BACK FOR A
SECOND THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
TODAY FOR THIS HEARING TODAY IS. EIGHT SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE
ONE ZERO ZERO YOU CAN FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE OR ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING IN AND
PLEASE PLAN DO SO WELL BEFORE
THE AUTHOR BEGINS PRESENTING
THAT BILL THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
LIMIT ALL BACKGROUND NOISE MUTE
YOUR LIVE STREAM AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION YOUR MAIN ON A
LIFELINE IT WILL NEED TO VIEW
YOURSELF UNTIL CALLED UPON BY
pTHE MODERATORS SPEAK REMEMBER
YOUR NUMBER. YOUR REMAIN- WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL WITH INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN FIND
THE EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE
THERE AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE-
STILL FACE. BILLS WILL BE HEARD
IN. IN THE ORDER PRESENTED IN
THE DAILY FILE. IN ON OUR AGENDA
. WE WITH THE EXPRESSION THERE
THERE ISN'T A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS AT FOUR PM TODAY WHERE
WE WILL HEAR ITEM TWENTY FOUR.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE ARE IN
THE AGENDA. THE FOLLOWING THOSE
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ANY MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A BILL
FROM CONSENT. IDMS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT ARE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWO FOUR TWO ZERO BY DR ARAMBULA
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN. ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIA BONTA. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT EXCUSE ME TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. MY DOCTOR CHOI
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
FIVE ELEVEN BY MISS IRWIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENT. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO. TODAY WE
HAVE A SUBSTITUTE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASH KALRA WILL REPLACE
THE DEMOCRATIC VACANCY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING- FROM THE
CALENDAR- HAS BEEN ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY NINETY TWO.
AS REMIT BEEN REMOVED FROM
TODAY'S CALENDAR. THE WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST OUR
FIRST BILL DR RAM YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. WHICH IS ACTUALLY
THIRD IN THE AGENDA BUT WE'RE
DOING IT FIRST SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ALL. ALL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
HELLO ALL. ALL.
WE HAVE AN ENGINEER ON THE WAY
TO TRY TO FIX THIS SO IF YOU
JUST WANNA HANG TIGHT HAVE A
SEAT RELAX SORRY I DON'T HAVE
ANY REFRESHMENTS TO OFFER A VERY
GOOD HOST APPARENTLY BUT WE GET
THE MICROSD TO WORK EVERYONE
WILL BE MUCH HAPPIER.
TELL.
YOU QUEUE UP A MIKE AND ONE OF
YOU GUYS CUBA MIKE.
MY APOLOGIES WE ARE GONNA TAKE A
RECESS FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY MINUTES WHILE THE THEY
WORK ON THE MICROPHONES I DO
APOLOGIZE IT'S BEYOND OUR
CONTROL AT THIS POINT SO- SO
WILL BE RECESSING FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MINUTES.
OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND JUST
SPEAK LOUDLY OKAY I'VE MEDICAID
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY.
FOR THE RECORD WE ARE NOT GOING
TO RECESS IMMEDIATELY FORGET
TAKE ROLE AND THEN WE WILL
RECESS. THERE IS MUCH. WHAT YEAR
WALDRON AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BIGELOW RIO LARA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAYES. MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO KALRA. WE
HAVE A QUORUM NOW WE WERE GOING
TO RECESS.
WHEN TO.
OKAY OKAY.
YEAH. OKAY THEN I THINK I'M GOOD
. AT THE END OF THE OF THAT OKAY
BYE. CHECK CHECK CHECK CHECK
CHECK.
TEST TEST TEST TEST TEST.
TESTING RIGHT BACK AT YOUR HOUSE
A- SOUNDS GREAT SO WHAT OUR
PROBLEM IS WHEN WE HAVE TOO MANY
BIKES OPEN THERE'S A CROSS POINT
SOMEWHERE IN THE SOFTWARE BUT
IT'S NOT EXPECTING THAT'S
CAUSING THIS SORT OF WEIRD
FEEDBACK. SO IF WE MINIMIZE THE
AMOUNT THAT WE HAVE OPEN IT
WON'T OVER BURDEN THE- OKAY.
VACATIONS THANKS VERY MUCH. OKAY
WILL COME BACK INTO SESSION
AGAIN SO WHAT WILL HAVE A- AFTER
REGULAR AND HIS WITNESSES FOR AB.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AS CALIFORNIA MAKES
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE TO THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM THERE IS A NEED
FOR SIGNIFICANT REFORM AS WE
SEEK TO ADDRESS THE
FRAGMENTATION THE INEFFICIENCIES
AND INEQUITIES THAT A PLAGUE THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM FOR FAR TOO LONG
. IN THE FACE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THESE CHANGES WILL RAISE IT
IS CLEAR THAT THE STATUS QUO IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WILL ADVANCE
POPULATION HEALTH BY PROMOTING A
CERTAIN TYPE OF HEALTH PLAN THAT
USES INTEGRATED MODEL OF CARE.
THIS NEW PLAN IS CALLED AN
ALTERNATIVE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
PLAN OR E. H. C. S. P. AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WILL HAVE
THESE H. C. S. P.'S WHICH MUST
OPERATE AS A HEALTH PLAN A
PROVIDER NETWORK AND MUST OWN OR
OPERATE THEIR OWN PHARMACIES. TO
COMPARE H. C. S. P.'S TO OTHER
HEALTH CARE PLANS IS LIKE
COMPARING APPLES TO ORANGES AS
OTHER HEALTHCARE PLANS DO NOT
HAVE THEIR OWN PROVIDER NETWORKS
OR PHARMACIES. AT THIS TIME
HEISER PERMANENT TODAY IS THE
ONLY SUCH PLAN THAT MEETS ALL OF
THESE REQUIREMENTS. HOWEVER THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT CURRENT
PLANS FOR MOVING TOWARDS A MODEL
. TOWARDS THAT MODEL WHICH CAN
BE MOST BENEFICIAL TO ITS
MEMBERS. THE STATE WOULD ENTER A
DIRECT CONTRACT WITH AN H. C. S.
P. JUST LIKE IT CURRENTLY DOES
WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER MEDIC CAL
HEALTH PLANS H. THE CSP'S MUST
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS AS OTHER
HEALTH PLANS INCLUDING WITH
RESPECT TO TIME WITH ACCESS.
GRAFT ACCESS QUALITY METRICS
COORDINATION OF CARE SAFETY NET
COVERAGE NON DISCRIMINATION AND
THE EXACT THE EXECUTION OF A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
COUNTIES AND OTHER REQUIREMENTS
. BY CREATING A DIRECT CONTRACT
WITH H. C. S. P.'S THE STATE
WILL HAVE DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF
THESE PLANS AS THEY STEP UP TO
PROVIDE MORE CARE FOR MEDICAID
ALL IN WILL EASE. JUST AS
IMPORTANT CONSUMERS WILL HAVE A
DIRECT LINK TO H. C. S. P.
SERVICES WITHOUT THE NEED TO
DIVERT FUNDS INTENDED FOR HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TOWARDS
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES. WHICH
HAPPENS QUITE A BIT UNDER
CURRENT SUBCONTRACTING PRACTICES
. RIGHT NOW LOCAL HEALTH PLANS
CAN SUBCONTRACT WITH KP AND ARE
TAKING BETWEEN TWO AND 20% OF
THE MEDICARE FEE FOR THEMSELVES
AS ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. THE
OPPOSITION HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF WHAT DOES
THE STATE OR CONSUMER GET OUT OF
THEM KEEPING THE ADMIN FEE. THE
DIRECT CONTACT WILL IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ENSURING THAT FUNDS THAT ARE
MEANT TO COVER MEDICAL SERVICES
DO JUST THAT. YOU'LL HEAR THE
OPPOSITION SAY THAT THIS IS A
SWEETHEART NO BID CONTRACT BILL
. WHAT THEY DON'T SAY IS THAT
KOS AND L. I. PLANS ARE ALSO NO
BID CONTRACTS. YOU'LL HEAR THE
OPPOSITION SAY THAT THIS BILL
INTERFERES WITH LOCAL CONTROL
YET KNOW WHERE IN THIS BILL WILL
YOU FIND LANGUAGE THAT
INTERFERES WITH THE ABILITY OF
THE CODE OR L. I. PLANS TO SUB
CONTRACT FOR SERVICES UNDER
CURRENT LAW. OR TO INTERFERE IN
THEIR EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH
THE STATE. THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO MANDATE HOW CODES OR
LRE PLAN PROVIDE THEIR SERVICE.
YOU'LL HEAR THE OPPOSITION SAY
THAT THIS BILL WILL JEOPARDIZE
HEALTH CARE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND YET THEY DON'T
EXPLAIN THAT THE H. C. S. P.
WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
SAFETY NET STANDARDS. THAT THE
CODES AND ALLIED PLANS CURRENTLY
MUST ENSURE. WHAT THE OPPOSITION
WON'T SAY IS THAT AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES H. C.
S. P.'S TO GO THROUGH A MUCH
MORE RIGOROUS CONTRACTING
PROCESS. THEN DH CS CURRENTLY
DOES IN ENTERING CONTRACTS WITH
OUR LOCAL PLANTS. THE OPPOSITION
WON'T SAY THAT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WILL ALSO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF LOCAL HEALTH PLANS. AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR ADVANCES
EQUITY INCREASES ACCESS IMPROVES
AFFORDABILITY IMPROVES THE
QUALITY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
DEMANDS ACCOUNTABILITY FROM OUR
H. C. S. B. TESTIFYING HERE
TODAY ARE JOSE TAURUS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR BOSS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND A ROOF SHAKE WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE. THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD WILL HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES TOTAL FOR YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY RIGHT THANK
IS A MEMBER ARAMBULA GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THOUGH
THEYTOWARDS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION. HEALTH ACCESS HAS A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INTENSIVE ENTER INTO A
DIRECT CONTRACT WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE AS A MEDIC CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS IN CERTAIN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF THE STATE.
HEALTH ACCESS IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THE VARIOUS GOALS IN THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE PATIENTS
AROUND THE STATE. WITH
CONTINUITY OF CARE IF THEY HAD
PRIOR COVERAGE WITH KAISER AND
NOW BECOME ELIGIBLE FROM. IF
THIS WORKS AS INTENDED MORE
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS AND MORE
COUNTIES WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO KEEP THEIR KAISER DOCTOR AND
NOT HAVE TO HAVE THEIR CARE
INTERRUPTED. WE ALSO SUPPORT
EXPANDING THE OPTION OF KAISER
COVERAGE TO THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. OF FOSTER CHILDREN
AND TWO OTHERS WERE SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
GETTING KAISER TO DO MORE OF ITS
FAIR SHARE IN MEDIC COW HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE CAPACITY.
QUALITY AND A CABIN
ACCOUNTABILITY ACCOUNTABILITY
I'M SORRY IN THIS KEEP PROGRAM
THAT SERVES OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. HEISER
DOES RELATIVELY WELL ON MANY
QUALITY METRICS BUT THERE IS
STILL MUCH ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
ON THEIR RECORD FOR QUALITY IN
EQUITY ESPECIALLY WITHIN
BEHAVIOR HEALTH. A DIRECT
CONTRACT WITHIN A DIRECT
CONTRIBUTING DH CS AND KAISER
WOULD BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR THE STATE TO HAVE.
GREATER AND MORE DIRECT
OVERSIGHT OVER KAISER. WHILE WE
SUPPORT THE BROAD INTENT OF THE
PROPOSAL WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE INTENDED GOALS AND
COMMITMENTS ARE CODIFIED. THE-BEST BENEFIT MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH IN THIS
CONTRACT WITH KAISER AT THE
MEDIC HOW MANAGED CARE PLANS.
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED AND WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR. IN WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS THEM. THESE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDED THAT THERE
BE NO DENY ALL OVER ROAMING. FOR
THOSE PROTECTED BY THE CONTINUAL
CARE THAT KAISER. AND THAT
KAISER IS HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AS OTHER HEALTH PLANS.
THAT THEY'RE BEING A DEFINITION
OF CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
CLARIFICATION OF FAMILY LINKAGE.
AND THAT THE LANGUAGE OF JUST.
UNDERSTAND ROAMING MATCH WHAT IS
CURRENTLY IN PLACE. HOWEVER WE
STILL DO HAVE VARIOUS.
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS MOVING
FORWARD. WE WANT TO CODIFY THE
PROPOSAL TO HAVE KAISER. THE
POOR FQHCS IN THEIR SERVICE AREA
TO IMPLEMENT A PORTFOLIO
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT.
AND CLINICAL TRANSFORMATION. WE
ALSO SEEK TO CODIFY THE PROPOSAL
TO HAVE EITHER PROVIDE SPECIALTY
SERVICES FOR THE HIGHEST NEED
SPECIALTIES AND GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
ARE USING KAISER PHYSICIANS. A
LIMITED NUMBER OF OUTPATIENT
SERVICES AND RELATED NEEDS SUCH
AS DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AND
OUTPATIENT PROCEDURES. BURKE NON
KAISER MEMBERS. BOTH OF THESE
SHOULD BE IN ADDITION TO WHAT
ALREADY EXISTS NOT IN PLACE OF
WHAT SAFETY NET PROVIDERS ARE
DOING TODAY THOSE BEING THE
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND COUNTY
HOSPITAL. WE ALSO SEEK BACK
HIGHS ARE CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH COUNTIES ON SERVING THE
MEDICARE POPULATION. WHILE WE
CONCEPTUALLY SUPPORT THE DIRECT
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE STATE WE
DON'T WANT TO LOSE THE LOCAL
VOICE OVER MAD COW. WE
ESPECIALLY RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
GOALS OF CAL AIMS FOR WHOLE
PERSON CARE WOULD BE BEST MET IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
VARIOUS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. AS SUCH WE SEEK TO
CODIFY LANGUAGE HAVE KAISER
ENTER INTO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE COUNTY IS
THAT THEY ARE LOCATED IN TO BEST
COURTNEY. THE NECESSARY CARE FOR
BENEFICIARIES. AND IT IS NOT
JUST CALLING HIM. HI THERE NEED
TO CONNECT WITH COUNTIES TO HELP
ADDRESS NEEDS LIKE HOUSING
INSTABILITY. FOOD AND FOOD AND
SECURITY AND ON BEING A
PRODUCTIVE PARTNER IN THE LOCAL
SAID HEALTH SYSTEM. AGAIN OUT
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IS TAKING A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS BILL. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
THOUGHTS ON HOW THIS DIRECT
CONTRACTING PROPOSAL WAS
ORIGINALLY RELEASED AND THE LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY IN THAT PROCESS.
WE DO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US. WELL
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED. WE CONTINUE TO HAVE.
OTHER OUTSTANDING CONCERNS AS
MENTIONED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. TO
ADDRESS THEM BECAUSE THE END OF
THE DAY. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PROPOSED THE BEST
BENEFITS MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THIS
BOX. AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR IN HIS
OFFICE AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR EFFECTUATE OUR BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSAL
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH KAISER AS
A MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLAN IN
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES HEISER IS
DIFFERENT FROM OUR OTHER
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLANS IS
THE AUTHOR NOTED IS AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM IS BOTH THE
PLANT AND ANIMAL WRITER REALLY
RELIED ON ITS BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE CARE. HI
THERE DOES NOT EXPAND ITS ACCESS
FIGHT CONTRACTING WITH PROVIDER
GROUPS ARE PHYSICIAN GROUPS FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE OTHER MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS. THEY'RE
INTEGRATED AND SELF CONTAINED
SYSTEM IS UNIQUE AND THEY'VE
BEEN TREATED UNIQUELY- BY THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. BECAUSE OF THIS
HI THERE IS NOT BEEN- SUBJECT TO
THE TRADITIONAL MEDIKAL PLAN
CHOICE METHODS WITH ANYONE WHO
CHOOSES KAISER COULD ENROLL IN
KAISER. ENROLLMENT GROWTH RATE
WOULD FAR OUT PASSED THE
PHYSICAL CAPACITY. HI THERE IS
ALSO UNIQUE BECAUSE IT'S SYSTEM
INCLUDES ACCESS TO THE SAME
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR COMMERCIAL
MEDICARE EXCHANGE AND MEDICAL
POPULATIONS. AND KAISER IS A
HIGH QUALITY PROVIDER IT
CONSISTENTLY SCORED HIGHER. THAN
OUR OTHER MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ON AGGREGATE LEVEL AND IN
FACTORS RELATED TO CHILDREN.
PREVENTIVE CARE AND MATERNAL
CARE. WE WANT TO GROW THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE MEDIC
HEALTH SPACE. UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL THEY WILL GROW THEIR
MEDICAL ENROLLMENT BY 25% OVER
THE COURSE OF THE FIVE YEAR
CONTRACT. THIS MEANS THEIR
MEDICAL GROWTH WILL BE AT A
FASTER RATE THAN THEIR
COMMERCIAL. AND MEDICARE LINES
OF BUSINESS. THIS IS. MORE. AS
POP. THIS HIGH CALL PLAN. UNDER
THE PROPOSAL MANY THE PRO IS
GETTING MORE FROM KAISER THAN
TODAY THAN THE CURRENT STATUS
QUO TODAY KAISER'S ALLOWED
CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS FROM OUR
MANAGED CARE REQUIREMENTS SUCH
AS EXEMPTIONS FROM FACILITY SITE
REVIEWS AND MEDICAL RECORD
REVIEWS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
THESE EXCEPTIONS WOULD BE
ELIMINATED AND KAISER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PARK A BY BY ALL BY
MANAGED CARE. REQUIREMENTS HE
DAY KAISER'S ENROLLMENT IS ONLY
REALLY THROUGH CONTINUITY AND
FAMILY LINKAGE THAT IS A PERSON
IS ABLE TO SELECT HEISER AS A
THEIR MEDICARE. PLAN IF THEY
HAVE HAD HIGHS IN THE LAST SIX
TO TWELVE MONTHS THROUGH ANOTHER
LINE OF BUSINESS SO FOR EXAMPLE
PERCENT HAS UP AND PLAYER
SPONSOR KAISER COVERAGE THEY
LOSE THEIR JOB THEY CAN SELECT
MEDIC CAL. KAISER AS IT AS AN
OPTION. BUT IN IN OUR PROPOSAL
YOU'RE A IN ADDITION TO
CONTINUITY AND FAMILY LINKAGE-
WE ARE. OFFERING THE OPTION FOR
DUAL ELIGIBLES GENERAL AND
KAISER SO THINK SHE'S MEDICARE
AS THEIR- KAISER. A LINE OF ARE
THERE HI THERE IS THERE MEDICARE
LINE OF BUSINESS. THE ALIGNMENT
OF MEDIC HELL WOULD BE THAT
WOULD FOLLOW AS WELL THIS WOULD
OPERATE UNDER THE START CURRENT
STATE- RULES. AND AS AN OPTION
FOR FOSTER YOUTH WE KNOW OUR
FOSTER YOUTH OFTEN TRANSITION
BETWEEN COUNTY LINE DISPLACEMENT
CHANGES. THIS WOULD PROVIDE A
FOSTER YOUTH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A HEALTH PLAN THAT FOLLOWS
THEM AS THEY CROSS THE COUNTY
LINE SO THAT WE KNOW THAT THEIR
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
IMMUNIZATION RECORDS- REACTIONS
TO MEDICATIONS ALLERGIC
REACTIONS TO MEDICATIONS FOLLOWS
THE YOUTH AS THEY AS THEY
TRANSITION I COUNTY LINES. OF
THESE ENROLLMENT OPTIONS WOULD
ALL BE BASED ON THE MEMBERS
CHOICE. IN ADDITION GIVEN THE
FEEDBACK WE'VE HEARD SINCE THE
FOR THE INITIAL RELEASE OF THIS
PROPOSAL. WE ARE ALSO- ADDING
THE ABILITY TO ASSIGN KAISER
LIFE THROUGH THE DEFAULT
PROCESS. SO IF IN A DID IT TO
AVOID KIND OF THIS CHERRY
PICKING NOTION THAT- VOCAL
HEALTH PLANS HAVE RAISED. SO IF
AN INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT CHOOSE
MET A MEDICAL MANAGED CARE PLAN
AS THEY BECOME ELIGIBLE HAVING A
KAISER BE PART OF A DEFAULT
ENROLLMENT PROCESS- AT IN
THROUGH THE COUNTIES. I AM I
ALSO. THAT THIS. DOESN'T EXCLUDE
VOLATILE POPULATIONS FROM KAISER
ENROLLMENT AND I WOULD ALSO NTE
THAT KAISER'S CASE MAKES IS
PRETTY GENERALLY RELATIVELY FOR
A SIMILAR TO OUR STATEWIDE CASE
MIX. FOR EXAMPLE KAISER'S AND
WOMAN INCLUDES ABOUT THREE POINT
76% AS SENIORS AND PERSONS
DISABILITIES. AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL THOSE NUMBERS ARE ABOUT
THREE POINT 45% TODAY KAISER
PARTICIPATES IN TWENTY TWO
COUNTIES FIVE WE DIRECTLY
CONTRACT WITH THEM AND IN US I
SEVENTEEN COUNTIES THROUGH AN
INDIRECT CONTRACT WITH WITH THE
PRIME PLAN. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
KAISER PARTICIPATE IN THIRTY TWO
COUNTIES WORK HAS ANY LINE OF
BUSINESS AND IN THOSE THIRTY TWO
COUNTY THROUGH WOULD HAVE A
DIRECT CONTRACT WITH KAISER AND
DIRECT OVERSIGHT. OF THEIR
OPERATIONS AND PLAN THIS REALLY
HURT TODAY MOST OF OUR THE
RELATIONSHIP IS THROUGH A SUB
DELEGATE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRIME PLAN I'M AND WE HAVE WE DO
NOT HAVE DIRECT INSIGHT INTO
INTO KUIPERS. OPERATIONS TODAY
KAISER IS NOT REQUIRED TO
PARTNER WITH OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS FOR EFFORTS
RELATED TO POP POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT. ECON SOLD OR IN
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY ACCESS.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL KAISER'S
AGREED TO TERMS ON THESE
PARTNERSHIPS. TOGETHER WE ARE
GETTING THE- ARE MEDIA HIRES FOR
NOT HIS REMEMBER TO PROVIDE AND
PER SPECIALLY ACT- IN THE
CENTERS THIS IS REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INNOVATE AND
BRICK PARTNER TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE MORE FOR OUR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. GETTING THEM TO
DO MORE IN THE MEDICAL SPACE
EVEN FOR THEIR NON MEMBER. I. AS
THE- THAT WOULD. COME ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPACT IT TOLD HEALTH.
CONTRACT WITH HIGHS. RATES WILL
BE ADJUSTED TO REFLECT MEMBER A
CUTIE SO I HEALTH PLAN WILL
RECOGNIZE AND REALIZE THAT RATE
ADJUSTMENT AS UP AS THIS GOES
LIVE NOT IN ARREARS AND NOT A
TWO YEARS LATER. THE RECOGNIZING
THAT MEDICAL RATES ARE BASED ON
PATIENT ACUITY PATIENT MIX AGEX
ADDRESS. IN CLOSING WE WANT TO.
OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO CRAFT
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO WORK
WITH KAISER DIFFERENT
PARTNERSHIPS TO EXPAND THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. THIS PROPOSAL AGAIN
GETS US MORE FOR OUR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. OUR GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE CHOICE CONTINUITY FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES ACROSS
PAYER SOURCE ACROSS COUNTY LINES
DECREASED INCREASE ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND INCREASED QUALITY
CARE. AND FINALLY WANT TO KNOW
WE ARE STILL BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF ON ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
SUCH AS THE DEFAULT ENROLLMENT
PROCESS. THAT WE ARE INTENDING
TO DO AS FLOOR AMENDMENTS I
SHOULD THE MOVE BILL MOVE OUT OF
CAN. YOU THANK YOU. THANKS TO
THE NEXT WITNESS FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ARGHA SHAKE I AM A DIRECTOR
AT KAISER PERMANENTE A FOR A
MEDIC CAL AND STATE SPONSORED
PROGRAMS MY AREAS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY INCLUDE
MEDICARE'S PLAN PARTNER
CONTRACTING REGULATORY REPORTING
AND AUDITING AND ALSO TITLED
LOCAL- CAL. COLLABORATIVES
ACROSS THE STATE ON BEHALF OF
KAISER PERMANENTE A I'M HERE TO
SHARE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD ALLOW DCS TO ENTER INTO A
SINGLE DIRECT MEDICAL CONTRACT
WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A
STARTING JUNE FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. ARE YOU PERMANENTLY
HAS PROUDLY PARTICIPATED
MEDICARE FOR MANY YEARS AS A NON
PROFIT HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATION
WITH THE MISSION TO PROVIDE
QUALITY- COVERAGE IN TEMPERATE
TO HELP THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE. STRUCTURE BUT- BECAUSE
YOUR HUSBAND AND TAKE. PER HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO OVERNIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES IN TWENTY TWO
COUNTIES. ARE TO FOURTEEN
DIFFERENT CONTRACTS I WOULD
LOCAL PLANS AS WELL AS- GMC
COUNTIES. A SINGLE DIRECT
CONTRACT ALLOWS KAISER
PERMANENTE EIGHT INCREASES
PARTICIPATION IN MEDICARE WITH
MANAGEABLE GROWTH. THAT WOULD
IMPROVE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
ACCESS TO CRITICAL PROVIDERS AND
QUALITY HEALTHCARE SERVICES
WITHOUT NEGATIVELY IMPACTING THE
ESSENTIAL ROLES. AT THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS AND SAFETY NET
BITERS PLAY. TRANSITIONING THREE
SINGLE DIRECT MEDICARE CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE HAS THE FOLLOWING
BENEFITS IT ADVANCES HEALTH
EQUITY KAISER PERMANENTE A WILL
SERVE MORE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITH COMPLEX NEEDS
SUCH AS FOSTER CHILDREN. SENIORS
ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL AND
MEDICARE ALSO KNOWN AS DUAL
ELIGIBLES AS WELL AS OTHER LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. IT
INCREASES ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
CARE HAS BEEN NOTED KAISER
PERMANENTE IS THE HIGHEST
QUALITY MEDICARE PLAN IN THE
STATE. ROGER COMMITTEE WILL ALSO
EXPAND AS DIRECTOR BOSS NOTED-
TO MEDIC CALLIN ROMAN INTEND
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES FOR A TOTAL
OF THIRTY TWO COUNTIES. THIS
REALLY ALLOWS KAISER PERMANENT
TEAM MEMBERS TO KEEP THEIR SAME
DOCTORS THERAPISTS HOSPITALS
ELECTRONIC. CETERA NO MATTER
WHAT COUNTY THEY RESIDED. RATHER
THAN HAVING TO NAVIGATE A WHOLE
NEW SYSTEM OF CARE. IT REDUCES
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY IT
INCREASES STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT A DIRECT CONTRACT
WILL REMOVE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAYERS MAKING THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM EASIER TO ACCESS FOR
MEMBERS. AND ALL STREAMLINED
STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE CONTRACT.
AND FINALLY IT RESPECTS LOCAL
CONTROL ARE YOU PERMANENTLY WILL
HAVE MO USE WITH COUNTIES AND
WILL COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS COUNTIES AND THE
SAFETY NET. I DETERMINING
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IMPLEMENTATION
OF CALLING POLICIES AND DELIVERY
OF COMMUNITY SUPPORT. AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR IS A FULLY
BALANCED APPROACH THAT WILL
ALLOW KAISER PERMANENTE A TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
CARE. FOR ORDER NUMBER MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN A WAY THAT IS
INTENDED TO SUPPORT AND
COMPLEMENT THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS AND THE SAFETY NET
DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE LIKE TO
THINK WE ARE. AND THE STAFF
MISTER CHAIRMAN HOW YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOUR WORK TO
HELP SHAPE AND STRENGTHEN THIS
THIS LEGISLATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP WE'VE ALSO
APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS AND
LONGTIME PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS. WE'RE
NOT THERE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INTEREST IN THIS PROPOSAL AND WE
VALUE YOUR INPUT. WE WELCOME
FURTHER CONVERSATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS
PROPOSAL MOVE MOVES FORWARD. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
LAST FOR OUR OF OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO COME TO THE TABLE.
AND AS WITH OUR- PROPONENTS OF
THE OF THE BILL YOU HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES- TO SPLIT AMONG YOU.
THANK YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
STEPHANIE SONNENSCHEIN CEO OF
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
HEALTH I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
ALLIANCE'S OPPOSITION TO BE TWO
SEVEN TWO FOUR IN WHICH WE ARE
JOINED BY OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OUR SAFETY NET
CLINIC PARTNERS THE SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA LOCAL PUBLIC PLANS
AND MANY OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE ALLIANCE
IS A COUNTY ORGANIZED SYSTEM
LOCALLY GOVERNED PUBLIC HEALTH
PLAN SERVING THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SANTA
CRUZ MONTEREY AND MERCED
COUNTIES. OUR MISSION IS
ACCESSIBLE QUALITY HEALTH CARE
GUIDED BY LOCAL INNOVATION. WE
HAVE TWENTY SIX YEARS OF SERVING
PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
BE CLEAR FROM THE OUTSET ABOUT
WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE THE
PROPOSED DEAL IS NOT A SMALL
CHANGE IT IS A RADICAL DEPARTURE
FROM ESTABLISHED PUBLIC POLICY.
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS THE END
OF THE COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH
SYSTEM. DESTROYING APPROVING
PUBLIC POLICY THAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY EXECUTED FOR FORTY
YEARS. THE COAST MODEL WAS
CREATED SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS IN THE MEDICAL DELIVERY
SYSTEM THROUGH AN EXCLUSIVE
CONTRACT BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR IMPROVEMENTS
IN ACCESS QUALITY AND COST. THE
DRIVING FORCE BEHIND BRINGING A
LOCAL PLAN INTO A COMMUNITY. IS
THE CONVICTION ACROSS THE LOCAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM PARTNERS THAT WE
CAN DO BETTERFOR PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WITH MEDICAL. IT'S K.
SIR CAN GUYS HEALTH SYSTEM.
KNOWS THAT SHARED ACCOUNTABILITY
LOCAL CONTROL AND SELF
DETERMINATION ARE A SIGNIFICANT
ADVANTAGE TO SOLVING THE COMPLEX
PROBLEMS AND PUBLICLY ASSISTED
MEDICAL CARE. BOTH HAVE
HISTORICALLY SERVED THE BROADEST
RANGE OF MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
AND OFFER THE BROADEST RANGE OF
BENEFITS OUR PLANS ARE PUBLIC
ENTITIES AND THUS ANY NET INCOME
EARNED IS USED TO OFFER MEMBERS
ENHANCED BENEFITS TO ENHANCE
PROVIDER PAYMENTS AND TO INVEST
IN THE CAPACITY OF THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. WE ARE HERE TO SERVE OUR
FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS NO
MATTER WHAT. AT WE ARE GUIDED BY
PUBLIC AND NOT PRIVATE INTERESTS
WE'RE COMMITTED TO OUR MEMBERS
AND OUR PARTNERS REGARD
REGARDLESS OF PROFIT MARGIN OR
POLITICS. AN EXCLUSIVE CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE IS THE DEFINING
FEATURE OF THE COAST MODEL. IT
REQUIRES THAT A COUNTY GO
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS TO
CREATE THE SINGLE LOCALLY
GOVERNED MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLAN. EXCLUSIVITY IN THE COAST
MODEL IS WELL ESTABLISHED
DEMONSTRATED BY REGULATION
LEGISLATIVE INTENT PRIOR CMS
WAIVERS IN FACT THE STATE'S OWN
DOCUMENTATION AROUND MANAGED
CARE MODELS. THE END OF A
MEDICAID CARE MODEL DEVELOPED
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS IN THE DELIVERY SYSTEM
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO DEEP
SCRUTINY. SUCH A PROPOSAL SHOULD
BE DIRECTLY RELATED TO A WELL
ARTICULATED PROBLEM IN THE
SYSTEM AND SHOULD BE THE BEST
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM. SUCH A PROPOSAL SHOULD
NOT UNDERMINE A WELL ESTABLISHED
SUCCESSFUL PUBLIC POLICY WITHOUT
SOME SUBSTANTIAL JUSTIFICATION.
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A
MASSIVE OVER REACH RATHER THAN A
WELL DEVELOPED NARROWLY TAILORED
SOLUTION. THE DEAL ENABLED BY AB
TWO SEVEN TWO FOUR IS THE RESULT
OF PRIVATE NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
THE STATE AND A COMMERCIAL
ENTITY WHICH PRIORITIZE THE
COMMERCIAL ENTITIES INTERESTS
OVER THE PUBLIC INTEREST. HIGHS
ARE THEY CLOSED VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED MODEL THESE SELF
IMPOSED CONSTRAINTS LIMITED. TO
ENGAGE AND LIKE MAD CAL
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR
COMMERCIAL PLANS THIS IS THE
REAL ISSUE UNDERLYING THIS
PROPOSAL. A DIRECT CONTRACT WITH
KAISER DOES NOT GIVE PEOPLE WITH
MEDICAL ANYTHING NEW. KAISER
SERVICE PEOPLE TODAY WITH MEDI
CAL THROUGH SUBCONTRACTS WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OR DIRECT
CONTRACTS WITH THE STATE. HEISER
SHOULD MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT
CONTRACTS WITH THE LOW HEALTH
PLAN AND WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
CONTRACT DIRECTLY WITH THE
HEALTH PLANS IN THOSE COUNTIES
WHERE THEY HAVE PRIORITIZE
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE. PROVIDING
KAISER WITH A SPECIAL DEAL IS
NOT OF THE BEST SOLUTION TO
PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL
ACCESS TO KAISER PROVIDERS NOR
IS IT THE ONLY SOLUTION. FURTHER
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS IS ALL
I PROVIDER MARKET COMPETITION
DYNAMICS RURAL AREAS OF THIS
MUST BE CONSIDERED. THE PROVIDER
EACH SYSTEMS IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
ARE DELICATE. THE ORGANIZE
HEALTH SYSTEM MODEL SUCCEEDS AT
GETTING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS TO WORK TOGETHER AS
PARTNERS TO STRENGTHEN ADULT
SYSTEM. THIS POLICY WILL DISRUPT
THE DELICATE BALANCE TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE. A STATE POLICY THAT
ADVANTAGES ONE SO ENTITIES OVER
. CAN BE AT DETERRED THOUGHT
MARSHALL PROVIDERS GETTING
DEEPLY ENTRENCHED IN THEIR OWN
COME IF POSITIONS AND
PRIORITIZING THEIR PRIVATE
INTERESTS. THERE'S LESS SENSE.
TO COLLABORATE ON PUBLIC
SOLUTIONS. WHEN THE ALLIANCE BIG
OP. TO SIX AGO COMPETITION
ACROSS PROVIDERS WITH A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THEIR
RESISTANCE TO CONTRIBUTE TO A
SUSTAINABLE DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
PEOPLE WITH MEDICARE ALL. THIS
PROPOSAL RISKS A RETURN TO THAT
MEDICAL MEMBER EXPERIENCE OF THE
NINETEEN NINETIES A TWO TIER
SYSTEM OR COMMERCIAL PROVIDERS
ARE PROTECTED IN SERVING ONLY AS
MANY PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL AS THEY
PERCEIVE OF AS BEING THEIR FAIR
SHARE. AND WHO DO NOT PARTNER
WITH THE TRADITIONAL SAFETY NET
WHO DO IN FACT ENSURE ACCESS FOR
ALL. EQUITY IS NOT ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE PRIORITIZATION OF
COMMERCIAL VOICE. OVER THAT OF
THE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WITH
THE TRADITIONAL SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE SERVED THEM.
THIS POLICY INFRINGES ON THE
LOCAL GOVERNANCE AND CONTROL
SUPPORTED BY STATE STATUTE. AND
ACTED ON BY FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
IN THE STATE. SUBSTITUTING
WISDOM
COUNTIES THE BENEFICIARIES THE
PROVIDERS WHO GOVERNOR LOCAL
PLANTS TODAY. SO IN CLOSING OVER
THE PAST TWO MONTHS WE WHO
OPPOSE HAVE BEEN RAISING OUR
VOICES THROUGH EVERY MEANS
POSSIBLE. TO TRY TO ENGAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT IN REAL DISCUSSION ON
THIS ISSUE. OUR QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS HAVE GONE UNANSWERED
OUR EXPERTISE HAS BEEN
DISREGARDED THE PROPOSAL WHICH
ADVANTAGES THE INTERESTS OF A
POWERFUL. IS THE PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF A SYSTEM PRODUCING THE RESULT
IS INTENDED TO PRODUCE I THINK
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER. I URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
CLOSE COAST MODEL BY REJECTING
THIS POLICY. TECT THE DECISIONS
OF THE COUNTIES WHO HAVE ADOPTED
A COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEM
OR A LOCAL INITIATIVE TO BEST
MEET THEIR COMMUNITY NEEDS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE COMMENTS ON AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR ENSURE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A NOT FOR PROFIT
LOCAL HEALTH PLAN THAT'S BEEN
SERVING THE NEEDS OF MEDICARE
ENROLLEES IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR
DECADES WERE VERY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HOLDING. THIS POLICY
HEARING TO BRING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND DIALOGUE IN
THIS MATTER MY NAME IS CHAIRED
MCNAUGHTON AND I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS CEO OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN.
AND THAT WE COVER ALL OF THE
HELP COMMITTEE SUPPORT SERVICE
FOR MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION MEDIC HELP MEMBERS OF
THE COUNTIES OF RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THESE COUNTIES REPRESENT
THE FOURTH AND FIRST LARGEST
COUNTIES RESPECTIVELY BY
GEOGRAPHIC TERRITORY IN THE
CONTIGUOUS UNITED STATES AND THE
UNIQUENESS OF OUR HEALTH PLAN
BECAUSE IT. HELPS US TO SEE PER
BILLS LIKE THIS WITH AN EYE FOR
EQUITY AND ALSO LIKE TO SHARE
THAT WE'VE ENJOYED A VERY LONG
STANDING RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
LOCAL KAISER PERMANENTE A TEAM
AND CURRENTLY DELEGATE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF OUR MEDICARE
MEMBERS HAVE HAD A PRIOR DOCTOR
OR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP WITHIN
THEIR CLOTHES NETWORK. BUT THIS
L. BILL ELIGIBILITY RESTRICTION
ON CHOICE PREVENTS THE MOST
VULNERABLE FROM AND ROLLING WITH
KAISER IT IS AS IT IS SENSUALLY
RESTRICTS COVERAGE TO MEMBERS
WITH PRIOR INSURANCE COVERAGE OR
A CONNECTION TO KAISER THROUGH A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT RESTRICTION
IS ACTUALLY CAUSED A
DISPROPORTIONATE PERCENTAGE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS AND
TOSE WHO ARE SENIORS ARE
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. TO
UNROLL ACTUALLY IN OUR PLAN I H.
P. SHAPE SENIORS ARE PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES IS ACTUALLY
49% HIGHER THAN KAISER IN
RIVERSIDE AND 71% HIGHER THAN
KAISER IN SAN BENITO COUNTY
WE'VE ALSO HAD THE EXPERIENCE
WITH KAISER WHERE THEY ASK US TO
D. DELEGATE A MEDIC CAL OR
MEDICARE ENROLLEES BACK TO I. H.
P. BECAUSE THE CARE AND
SERVICES. REQUIRED FOR THAT
MEMBER OR DO NOT FIT WITH THEIR
CLOTHES NETWORK OR EXPERTISE.
THE WITH THOSE ENROLLEES
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES NOW
IMAGINE WITH ME FOR JUST A
MOMENT THAT THERE'S A NETWORK OF
GAS STATIONS ACROSS THE STATE IN
LARGE METROPOLITAN AREAS LIKE
LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO AND FOR
THOSE WHO LIVE. IN THOSE LARGER
METROPOLITAN AREAS THEY ACTUALLY
GET TO USE THE GAS STATIONS AND
THEIR CITY BUT ONLY IF THEY GET
A SPECIAL INVITATION TO DO SO
AND WORSE FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT
LIVE IN BAKERSFIELD- ON TERROR
REEKER MONTEREY WELL THEY'RE
TOTALLY OUT OF LUCK BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T USE THE METROPOLITAN GAS
STATION NETWORK. IF YOU HAPPEN
TO BE DROPPING THROUGH WHAT THE
LARGER CITIES THEIR STOCK
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIVE IN THE
RIGHT ZIP CODE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT GAS STATION
NETWORK AND THEY WERE NEVER
GIVEN SPECIAL INVITATION THROUGH
THAT B. E. NETWORK TO JOIN WELL
THAT'S EXACTLY THE SCENARIO THAT
STATE. STATUS UP THROUGH THIS
DIRECT NO BED BACKDOOR DEAL.
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE STATE AND
KAISER PERMANENT DAY WHILE EVERY
OTHER HEALTH PLAN. IN THE STATE
BOTH NOT FOR PROFIT OR FOR
PROFIT COMMERCIAL HAS TO ABIDE
BY THE RULES OF THE STATE
MEDICARE CONTRACT. THAT IS NOT
THE CASE FOR KAISER THROUGH THIS
DEAL YOU SEE THEY GET A SPECIAL
DISPENSATION. THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO ONLY SEE PARTICULAR MEMBERS
WHERE THEY ALREADY HAVE A
COMMERCIAL FOOTPRINT WHICH MEANS
IN OUR CASE. THAT WHILE THEY
MIGHT SEE PATIENTS A LARGER
METROPOLITAN AREAS SUCH AS
ONTARIO RANCHO CUCAMONGA
RIVERSIDE. THOSE WHO LIVE IN THE
HIGH DESERT LIKE BAR STORE
NEEDLES FOR THOSE WHO LIVE WITH
A LOAD AFTER LIKE BLIGHT. WELL
THEY'RE OUT OF LUCK. AS YOUR
WILL ONLY COVER THOSE MEMBERS
WHO LIVE IN GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS
WITHIN THE COUNTY WHERE THEY
ALREADY HAVE A COMMERCIAL
FOOTPRINT. CREDIT HERE'S THE
KAISER IS A TWO TO CON WITH HAVE
ARE FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS THAT WERE DESIGNED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT YEARS AGO
TO SEE THE MOST VULNERABLE WHO
HAD LITTLE TO NO ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CARE BUT THE PROBLEM IS
THAT ONCE AGAIN THE STATE AND
KAISER ARE TRYING TO GET AROUND
THE VERY STATE STAFF WHICH IS
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN.
THAT WAS CREATED YEARS AGO
ALLOWING THIS WHOLE DEAL TO MOVE
FORWARD IF THE STATE STATUTE
SAYS THAT CERTAIN CRITERIA MUST
BE MET IN ORDER TO HAVE THIS
KIND OF DIRECT CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE'S BUDGET AB IN INTEGRATED
NETWORK THAT IS AREAS THAT THEIR
STRATEGY TO CONTRACT PURCHASE TO
UTILIZE JEFF COMMITTEES THAT
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY HAVE NO
PRESENCE ACTUALLY CREATES A MASS
STRIPPING ON ALREADY WORLD
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF IT BECAUSE IF KAISER
IS GOING TO BE PULLING UP SLOTS
WITHIN THE AFTER SHE STERN WORK
PROVISIONAL MANDATE MEDICAL
MEMBERS ARE ALREADY SEEN. HIS DO
NOT GETTING IT THAT WORK
ADVOCACY AT ALL THE SUPER
MEMBERS BUT ACTUALLY TAKING AWAY
SLOTS FROM THOSE IN HELL AND
THROWN IN THIS THE G. THANK YOU
TO STAY STATUE THE ALLOW THIS
ANTI DEAL TO FORWARD AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR ALLOWS THE
STATE TO EXEMPT KISER PROFANITY
A COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLAN FROM
RULES THAT APPLY TO EVERY OTHER
MANAGEMENT OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL WOULD
DO NOTHING TO INCREASE ACCESS
FOR VULNERABLE MEDICAL MEMBERS
INSTEAD IT WOULD D THE OPPOSITE
SHRINKING ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
CONTACTS AND OTHER SAFETY HAS
SERVICES FOR ROLE IS AN EXISTING
PLANTS. THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS WE BELIEVE THAT MUST
BE ANSWERED THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IS AT THE STATE'S INTENTION TO
KNOWINGLY CREATE A CONSCIOUS
BIAS TWO TIERED MEDICAL A MEDIC
CAL SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA THAT
COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT ACCESS
TO CARE FOR. MEDICAL IS THAT THE
STATE'S INTENTION TO ALLOW
COMMERCIAL PLAN TO SIDE STEP THE
STATE'S NORMAL CONTRACT PROCESS
IN TERMS NETWORK REQUIREMENTS A
LIMITED ROLE MEANT TO THE
HIGHEST MEMBERS AND CREATE A
TRULY. DISCRIMINATORY
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT A SINGLE
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLAN WHOSE
TRUE FOCUS ON ON THOSE MODE
VULNERABLE. BUT ON INCREASING
COME PUT BILL. AS SOME WILL USE
THE QUALITY ARGUMENT FOR THIS
CHANGE AND AS A PASSED CEO OF A%
LARGE ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER I
CAN TELL YOU I'LL BE THE FIRST
TO SHARE. IT'S EASY TO HAVE HIGH
QUALITY IN A CLOSED SYSTEM WHERE
YOU GET TO CHOOSE WHO YOU WILL
COVER COMPARED TO OUR MISSION TO
COVER FOR ALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GERMAN WORD AND REALLY
APPRECIATE. A MEMBER ARAMBULA AS
WELL AS TO HAVE THIS INVITATION
TO SHARE HOW THESE EXPECTATIONS.
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPACT THE LOCAL
SAFETY NET AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND OUR LAST
WITNESS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
NOW YOUR- FEET YOUR PREDECESSORS
TO COUPLE MORE TIME. IT'S GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- THE
AUTHOR. MY NAME IS DR MAX
GRIFFITH I AM THE CEO OF
CLINICAL THE SALUTE VIA SALINAS
IN MONTEREY COUNTY. MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE PRESENTED TO
YOU- THOUGHTS AND IDEAS COMING
FROM THE COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH
SYSTEMS. AND A LOCAL COUNTY
HEALTH PLANS. AND WHAT THEY
PRESENTED OUR SCENARIOS THAT ARE
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC. 'M HERE
REPRESENTING OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS ARE MADE UP.
OF THE PATIENTS. WHO MOST OF
THEM ARE FARMWORKERS. AND
THEY'VE GROWN A HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN MONTEREY COUNTY THAT.
HAS THIRTEEN SITES AND COVERS
ALL OF THE MAJOR TOWNS UP AND
DOWN THE SALINAS VALLEY. AND
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED WITH.
WHAT THIS POTENTIALLY COULD
CREATE. WE'RE LOOKING AT.
DISMANTLING I HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM I HEALTH PLAN. THE
NEWSPAPERS ARE CALLING THIS THE
LINES ARE BEING DRAWN THERE
THERE ARE NO LINES THE ARTICLES
THE TITLE OF ALMOST DISCUSSING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE NO
LINES BETWEEN WHO IS BETTER AND
WHO ISN'T WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTH PLANS. ONE HAS A HISTORY
OF TAKING CARE OF MEDICARE LIVES. AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT
BEFORE ANYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT
MEDICAL AND THEY'VE CREATED
SYSTEMS THAT ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR PREGNANT
WOMEN CHILDREN THE ADULTS
LOOKING AT THE FULL LIGHT
SPECTRUM. WHAT'S THE PALM OF
HAND HERE. IS ASKING US TO LOOK
AT. CRITICAL ISSUES THAT ARE
DUE- NEEDED TO PUT TOGETHER A
HEALTH PLAN YOU GOTTA TALK ABOUT
ENROLLMENT. YOU'VE GOT TO TALK
ABOUT RISK YOU'VE GOTTA TALK
ABOUT PAYMENT AND THE OUTCOME
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVE GOOD HEALTHCARE AND GOOD
OUTCOMES THAT WE NEED TO MEASURE
AND REPORT BACK TO YOU ALL. SO
THAT YOU ALL POLL THAT ONE
DIDN'T TAKE CARE. NOW WE'RE
VOICING. OPPOSITION THROUGH THIS
BILL WE DON'T SEE THE- IT IS
WORTHY OF RECEIVE SUPPORT BY THE
COMMITTEE. SO WE MUST STRENGTHEN
THE SAFETY NET THAT WE CREATED I
WAS THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IS A PROBLEM
ONLY FOR. HISER NOT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE MUST
STRENGTHEN THE SAFETY NETS AND
AS WE PUT THIS TOGETHER ARE YOU
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER. HAVE
INFORMATION ON THIS PLAN WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE OLD ADAGE YOU CAN
PUT LIPSTICK ON THE PIG. BUT IT
AIN'T GONNA LOOK BETTER. WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE USING OUR RESOURCES
TO PUT TOGETHER I HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT'S INTACT.
REASONABLE AND IT MAKES SENSE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES BACK HOME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO SEE ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM- LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THIS ON THIS BILL
WILL JUST BE ASKING FOR YOUR
NAME. AND THE POSITION AND
ACTUALLY WHEN MEANT YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE ACTUALLY. ANYONE ELSE
ANYONE UP THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI MICHAEL LOSE
ACT I'M AN EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN
AND I PUT AT THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND ROSEVILLE WHERE I PRACTICE
ABOUT A THIRD OF MY PATIENTS ARE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. EITHER
KAISER PERMANENTE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS AND THOSE PATIENTS
ARE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES GET
THE SAME CARE QUALITY AND ACCESS
THAT I DO IN MY FAMILY DOES
THAT'S WHY I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. Q. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
PLEASE DON'T TOUCH THE MIKE
SORRY. HI I'M DOCTOR ASON CORD
AND I MADE A RADIOLOGIST- IN
IRVINE AND ANAHEIM- AND I'M NOT
A CEO AND I AM NOT HERE TO US
SUPPORT THE BILL AND- AND
CONFIRM THAT- THAT OUR PATIENTS
ALL GET THE SAME CARE AS ANYBODY
IN ANY OTHER MEDICAL SYSTEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HONORABLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR DIANA
SHEBA I MEAN ACTIVELY PRACTICING
OPHTHALMOLOGIST AND EYE SURGEON
L. A. COUNTY. AND I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR BECAUSE IS GOING TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE TO THE MEDICAL
PATIENTS IN MY COUNTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SIX WITNESS. HI MY
NAME IS DR KING NOW I'M AN
INTERNAL MEDICINE PHYSICIAN-
FRONTLINE. AND CENTRAL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS EXACTLY
THE TYPE OF BILL WE NEED TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE AREAS LIKE CENTRAL
VALLEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR
CHRISTINA CHONG HANN I'M AT
SERVE I'M A RADIOLOGIST SERVING
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. HELLO I'M DR ESCRIBANO I'M
A FAMILY PHYSICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT WILL ALLOW
ME TO SERVE MY COMMUNITY AND
FOLKS WHO LOOK LIKE ME. BETTER
AND PROVIDE THE HIGH QUALITY
CARE THAT I THAT I NEED AND THAT
THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU. HI I AM
DOCTOR OSCARS AND GUESS I'M I'M
AN EMERGENCY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
IN SAN DIEGO AND I ALSO SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
TEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHEN A
COMMAND ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
REPRESENTS THE SIXTEEN NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS. CONSISTENT WITH THE
TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY TWO ALLEY
TO PC MEMBERS CENTER CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR HEALTH AND INLAND
EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN. C. AS
OPPOSED AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. THE PROPOSAL UNDERCUTS THE
PUBLIC PLAN MODEL AND AGENCY AN
EXPERIENCE OF COUNTIES AND LOCAL
CYCLE. IT ALSO ENABLES KAISER TO
CONTINUE TO ENROLL HEALTHCARE
MEDICAL POPULATIONS CREATING AN
EQUITABLE ACCESS AND RESULTING
IN LOCAL SAFETY NET PROVIDERS
SERVING THE MOST VULNERABLE SICK
AND COSTLY MEDICAL RELEASE.
FINALLY IT IS TROUBLING THAT
THERE ARE MANY DETAILS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THAT ARE STILL UNKNOWN
INCONSISTENT WITH THE BILL
LANGUAGE OR ABSENT FROM THE BILL
ALTOGETHER. WELL ELOISE PC IS
FIRMLY OPPOSED AT TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR AND URGES THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON THE
BILL. SHOULD PROCEED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THE REQUEST
FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
CONSIDERATION OF THE AMENDMENTS
L. A. B. C. SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE AHEAD OF TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEVON ANDERSON ON
BEHALF. ASSEMBLY TEAR COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA SANTA CRUZ VENTURA COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON RACHEL BLEACHER ON
BEHALF OF THE LA CARE HEALTH
PLAN IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYBE WE COULD HAVE
THE MICROPHONE TIPPED UP A
LITTLE BIT SO. I HAD THE TWELFTH
. I'D DOCTOR WILSON FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT DOES GIVE ME THE
ABILITY TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF MY PATIENTS THEY DON'T COME
IN PERFECT IT TAKES ABOUT TWO
YEARS TO GET THEM UP TO THAT
LEVEL SO WE WILL WORK REALLY
HARD TO GETTING THEM THERE AND
THIS REALLY ALLOWS OUR PATIENTS
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS POLYCHROMY HAVE THE
COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT CINEMA.
MERCED SAN LUIS OBISPO STRAIGHT
OPPOSE. AND THE COUNTY OF SOLANO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRENT SMITH
REPRESENTING FIVE COUNTY
ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS
CLEANING CAL OPTIMA GOLD COAST
HEALTH PLAN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR HEALTH PARTNERSHIP
HEALTH PLAN AND HEALTH PLAN OF
SAN MATTEO OPPOSE UNLESS COUNTY
ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE
REMOVED FROM THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ARNOLD TORAH'S
REPRESENTED CENTER COAST HEALTH
NETWORK CLINICS IN SEMINOLE
COUNTY MONTEREY COUNTY SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY- OXNARD INTO
LARRY- JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY-
WERE UNAWARE EXACTLY HOW MANY
MUCH MORE ACCESS IS GOING TO BE
CUT. BY THIS BILL WERE SPECIALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HISPANICS
BECAUSE 50% OF THE POPULATION OF
MEDICAL PATIENTS ARE HISPANIC WE
DON'T SEE A MEDIC CAL SEEN A LOT
OF THOSE PATIENTS- AND THAT IS A
VERY FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM BECAUSE
OUR NO MECHANICS IN ANY OF
THESE- LEGISLATION OR ANY OF
THE- BEEN HANDED OUT BY THE
ADMIN- TO BE DOING THE- BILL-
ALONG THE WAY WITH AMENDMENTS.
IS THE WORST WAY TO DO PUBLIC
POLICY ON AN ISSUE THAT HAS
PHENOMENAL STATEWIDE
IMPLICATIONS. FOR POPULATION OF
LATINOS WHICH IS THE LARGEST
POPULATION IN THE STATE AND 50%
OR MEDICAL PATIENTS VERY
PROBLEMATIC IT'S A VERY BAD BILL
. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
STEPHEN BREEDLOVE'S- PLASTER
COUNTY RESIDENT AND I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE GETTING
ACCESS TO KAISER IS NOT ALWAYS
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE AND
ALTHOUGH THIS MAY BE A NOBLE
EFFORT I THINK THAT IT INDEED
DOES- DESERVES SOME ADDITIONAL
SCRUTINY IT IT DOES SEEM TO BE
DISCRIMINATORY IN NATURE IF YOU
LOOK ACROSS THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S VERY
LARGE STATE VERY DIVERSE HAS
VERY MANY NEEDS AND I THINK THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE GONNA BE LOCKED OUT OF THIS-
ADMIRABLE STEP FORWARD IN SOME
AREAS BUT I THINK IT'S A
REGRESSIVE MOVE. AND JOB. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
LISA DESPEREAUX WITH INFORMED
PARENTS OF CONTRA COSTA A
BILINGUAL TEACHER- VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SERVICE THAT
OUR MINORITY POPULATIONS WOULD
RECEIVE FROM THIS. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE YOU'RE SAYING NO ONE WILL
GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES AND
HAVE THE OPERATOR OPEN FOR
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THAT'S BLENDED IT'S
PRETTY HARD TO KEEP KEEP IT THE
ANY OTHER WAY SO WHENEVER. THE
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
A. B. TWO SEVEN TO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT TELL MINE EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN FIVE. LINE EIGHT EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHT EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR ONE ONE
SEVEN FOUR. ANDREA RIVERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HELP NETWORK STATING OUR
SUPPORT INCOMES THAT POSITION ON
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS MEDICAL NON
BURKE AND CURRENT THANK THE
MEMBERS OUTSIDE OF THE MEDICAL
SET. STANTON GAME FROM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THEIR
CARE WITHIN THE SAME HELP SYSTEM
HOWEVER PERFORMED BETTER THAN
MOST MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
ON MAJORITY OF OUTCOMES BUT NOT
QUALITY METRICS AND IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RETAIN THE CORE.
CONTRACT THE DEBATE OF HEALTH
SERVICE WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
ACTUALLY GREAT OVER OVER THE
HEALTH AND YOU REASON. AND YOU
KNOW AS THE- THAT POSITION FOR
THIS BILL HOWEVER WE WENT ALSO
TO SEE GREATER. IN THE BILL
SPECIFIC AREAS REGARDING A CLEAR
. ON ELLA. FOR TWO. FOR THE
DEFAULT ENROLLMENT FROM VISION-
A REQUIRING TO MEET ALL
CONTRACTOR- TEMPERAMENT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IMPOSE THIS COUNTRY
. WHERE THERE ARE AREAS THAT.
WE'RE JUST NOT CURRENTLY HIGHLY
AND I'M ESPECIALLY REGARD TO BE
HEALTH I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
AN ANNUAL EVENT. OF THE CONTRACT
ANY IMPASSE TO THE NOT I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SEE CONSIDER.
RELATED TO ADDITIONAL BETH HI
THERE WITH YOU CAN HOW WE
APPRECIATE THE PROJECT CONGRESS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH OUR AND
WHICH TO READ IT OUR. THIS BILL
. FOR CALLING PLEASE LIMIT. THE
CALLER PLEASE YOUR NEXT OVERCOME
LINE NOW SIX NINE SIX NINE THREE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M THURMOND. ON THE OF
THE- STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU RIGHT- THIRTEEN
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LINE THIRTEEN NINETEEN YOU KNOW
MY AND HEALTH COMMITTEE AND DO
LIKE A MINUTE I SHARES THE
MINUTE IT FOR THIS BILL TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ANYTHING WILL BE
YOUR CALL AND- WHAT. THANK YOU.
DURING THE BUT WE KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK YOU DOING WHAT YOU VERY
MUCH WILL AND CALL THINK U. NEXT
CO PLEASE. YOUR MIND THIRD
NINETY. I'M. THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE THREE TO. THANK. WE GOTTA GET YEAH NINE TEN
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE CALL. LINE ONE
FOR FIVE. HI MY NAME IS JANICE
ELKS SECOND COUNTY I THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWELVE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWO FOUR ZERO. BLIND TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
SIMPSONS EMMY. YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH SO JUST AS A GENERAL
COMMENT- SO BASICALLY A TIMER-
SHARES OF CARE IT'S YOU KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
CENTERS A CARE IS NOT THE END GO
. THANK THE STANDARD CARE THEY
ISN'T IN EQUITY YOU CAN WE CAN
ALL BE EQUALLY MISERABLE
TOGETHER SO IT'S REALLY THE
WISDOM THAT GOES INTO THE EQUITY
AND ALSO I'M NEUTRAL ALL LEAVE
MY COMMENT THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SANDRA HANN I'M CALLING FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR- I WORK WITH AND NOT
. CAN CALL FRESNO BUILDING
HEALTHY BE THE ONLY A WRECK WE
WERE UNINSURED AND I'M- CAN WE
MEMBERS THE CENTER VALLEY. AND
THE SHE DO THAT WOULD- THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC ANY PRIOR TO THE
PAN HAS BEEN THE LACK OF ASK. TO
THE- CARE SO THE EIGHT EIGHT IS
J. SURE BUT IT'S ACTUALLY ARE
NONE OF THE LEADING PER. AND
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE THAT PER
HOLD STATE. CARE AND WHAT. HI
THERE. FOLKS AND BRING ON BOARD
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE THAT
TO HELP SUCH A MY MOTHER WHO IS
A FORMER HI MEMBER AND MANY AGO
AND FOR LAW HER WHEN OTHER PAST
EIGHT AND BECAME A MAN
BENEFICIARY. GETTING RIGHT CARE
AND THEN EGG. YOUR BUT WITH A NO
OF HEALTHY IT WE THAT'S SPENT ON
YEAR TRAV TO BE ONE NINE EVERY.
SO THAT SHE GET THE CARE THAT
SHE NEEDS BECAUSE THERE CAN
AREN'T ENOUGH MAY HELP. FRENCH
COUNTY. AT TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR WITH THAT WELL I MY MOTHER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
SIXTY SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
THREE SIX SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS WELL BUT ALMOST FROM FRESNO
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
ABOUT. I JUST TO BE THE SAME AS
QUOTE FROM THE DISH OBVIOUSLY
AND THAT FOR ME HOUSE PLAN PER
X. AND SHOULD BE SO IS THAT WE
SHOULD KNOW WE. OUR STAFF. IS
WHAT I AB TWENTY. FOUR THANK YOU
. THANK YOU RIGHT NOW SIX SIX
GOT. HI MY IS IN CLIENT FRESNO
AND I CALLING IN. OF THE- THREE
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
AMY I'M A FRESNO COUNTY ATTORNEY
WHO WAS WORKING WITH LEGAL
SERVICES DURING THAT TIME COUNTY
BACKING HIS. YOUR TIME FOR WE
GOT IF NOT OF. FROM DISTRAUGHT
MEDIC CAL MAY. WHO WERE INFORMED
KAISER HAD TO DROP THEM
EDUCATION AND TOLD TO TRANSITION
HELLO VIDAK. MANY HAD SERIOUS
ILLNESSES AND THE DEMOCRATIC FOR
YEARS IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO
FIND PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER. YOUR
AVAILABLE. I OPTIMIZATION TO SEE
IF NEXT STEP MASSIVE CARE
SERIOUSLY. AS MANY MEDICAL
HEALTH PLAN BECAUSE PROVIDE
NETWORK THAT ARE BROKEN HAVE ANY
OF THESE MOMENT MEDICAL PIECE
AND GIVEN THE ALL THEY WERE HAVE
REMAINED WITH CUT. THE BILL COME.
NEW HER TWO COUSINS REFERRAL IN
PRE AUTHORIZATION SYSTEM THEM
WITH THE LOCAL PLAN TO SOME
CONTRACT- LEAD TO OTHER HEALTH
PLANS PATIENTS HELPED WITH
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THAT IS WHY
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH PROVIDE
VULNERABLE. HELP EACH AND THEN
OPTION MAY DESPERATE. THE
PATIENT CHANGED ONLY HARD BUT
STAFF QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
PLEASE VOTE TO PASS AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. AND
THANK THANK YOU AND A WITNESS
ESTONIAN PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF IF YOU
DON'T SO I APOLOGIZE BEEN TRYING
TO GET IT HERE BUT- NEED TO MOVE
ON. YOU I'M TEN FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAVE A LOOK AT
PHONE NUMBER I AM CALLING
REPORTS OF EIGHTEEN BEACHES FOR
AND FIFTY ONE FOUR FOR BRINGING
ACCESS TO CALL CARE AND- THE
MUCH NEEDED- OKAY. MARC MILLER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ME FOR EARLY
THE PEOPLE I ON A TWO FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I NINE
SIXTY THREE GO AHEAD. YES NAME
IS MICHELLE COLE IN A CALLING
RUBBER THE OF. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
REMIND ALL OF YOU THERE TO THAT
THIS IS WHAT KIND ONE NATION GOD
REMEMBER THAT GOD I'M THE YOU
REMAIN. AT FEDERAL. THANK THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU BIANCA
FROM SARASOTA COUNTY AND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN
WILL ACTUALLY REGARDING-
ADDITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOUR MIND ALIVE IN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACK BE RECKONED FROM PRESENT
COMPANY AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. YOU'RE
RIGHT EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR CRITICAL
HAVE. HI THIS IS GOING TO PASS
IT ON THE STATE YOU COUNTY
DELEGATE TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
. I WAS A SUPPORTER AT THE FIVE
SIX TWO. AND CAL CARE AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED. AND AT THE
BORDER FOR BERNIE SANDERS FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL. SO MANY OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS STATE AND
THIS COUNTRY WANT HEALTHCARE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL. APPLE AND A
GOOD CALL. AND GOOD COFFEE- IT
IS IN FACT A- PARTY PLATFORM BUT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT HELP
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL IT. AND I DO
NOT SHARE ANY OF ON COMMITTEE IN
FACT. MY DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
STAND. FOR EIGHTY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. AND I DON'T THINK YOU
MIND. EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE CALL.
HELLO MY NAME HELP THEM FROM
FRESNO COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE OF AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PARK THANK YOU THANK YOU. YOU'RE
RIGHT ALIVE IN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JANICE
SHERA I'M FROM FRESNO COUNTY AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT AB EVENT
FOR- I WANT TO BE TREATED WITH
THE SAME RESPECT CULTURE AND-
GET. TO SEE THE STATE IS
PERFORMING HEALTH- PLAN BYE- I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOURTEEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WERE
NEUTRAL ON THE PROPOSAL AND
WANTED TO APPRECIATE THE
DOCTOR'S OFICE AND INCLUDING
SOME OF OUR LANGUAGE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING TO
HIM. ALSO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
NEARLY. YES MA'AM YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GREAT SORRY ABOUT THAT MY
NAME IS SHEILA JIM CALLING FROM
BOTH THE COUNTY AND I'M GOING TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK VERY
MUCH MADAM OPERATOR BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND A MR MAYS
HAS QUESTIONS SO PLEASE GO AHEAD
MR. I THANK YOU HIS CHAIR AND I
JUST WANTED TO START OFF BY-
THINKING THE AUTHOR THANK YOU
IT'S- AND I SUSPECT A THINKING
OF THE ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP. FOR
A BRING A BILL OF BEFORE US.
FRANKLY IT'S- IN. AND WHEN IT
WAS FIRST REPRESENTED A IN THE
PRESS IT WAS AS IF IT WAS A FATE
ACCOMPLI. AND IT WAS GONNA END
UP IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND
THERE'S GONNA BE NO DISCUSSION
ABOUT IT- AND IT WAS GONNA BE
FRANKLY FORCED ON ALL OF OUR
THROATS WITHOUT ANY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT. BY THE WAY
THAT IT WAS INITIALLY PRESENTED
WAS AWFUL- IT WAS NOT
TRANSPARENT- AT THE END OF THE
FACT THAT WERE HAVE CONVERSATION
A. I. IS INCREDIBLY. IMPORTANT I
DO AGREE WITH THE CALLER ON A
MAJOR TO SAY THIS THAT AS WELL-
THAT OFTENTIMES WHEN YOU TRY TO.
QUOTE COMFORT- IT I'M- AT THE
STATUS QUO. PERRANCE SB. THERE
HAS TO BE DIALOGUE AND DEBATE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THIS A CORRECTLY SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THINK OF THE AUTHOR AND THINK
THE CHAIR HAVING THIS TODAY
BLOWING AND THE SUN TO DISCUSS.
THIS THAT BEING HAD A DAY. OF
COME FROM THE- FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME- AND THE ONE
THING THAT THE- THE GENTLE LADY
HAD A HEADS HAD SAID I'D MADE I
CREDIT TO TALK ABOUT BECAUSE YOU
SAID- THAT THIS IS THE END OF
COUNTY OR- COUNTY OR- WHAT DO
YOU MEAN BY THAT THIS IS THE END
OF THE COUNTY ORGANISES. WELL AS
I EMPHASIZED IN. SIX THE COUNTY
ORGANIZED SYSTEM IS UNIQUE IN
THAT AT THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PARTNER WITH LOCAL
PROVIDERS TO FORM A SINGLE ALL
MANAGED CARE PLAN TO SERVE
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES. AT THAT
BY. PROCESS BECAUSE THERE ARE
CONSIDERATIONS TO HAVE PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS ONLY THROUGH ONE
HEALTH PLAN. PROPOSE IN.
COMMERCIAL INTO THE ORGANIZED
HEALTH SYSTEM COMMUNITIES
THEREBY RENDERING US I GUESS
WOULD BE LOCAL INITIATIVES ARE
PERHAPS WERE GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED
CARE COUNTIES. HAS THE POLICY
WASN'T DESIGNED TO A CHANGE IN
THE COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH
MODEL. RATHER THE TO THE CRAP
COUNTY HEALTH SYSTEM MODEL SEEMS
TO BE AN AFTERTHOUGHT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO DESCRIBE
THAT BUT IT ENDS US BECAUSE WE
WILL NOT BE A SINGLE PLAN THAT
IS. WE GOT BURNED INCLUDING
HAVING BENEFITS TREES ON OUR
BOARD PROVIDERS LOCAL COUNTIES
ABOARD THE RISERS PRESENTED OF
SO IT IS THE END OF THE COSTA.
ACTORS THAT HAVE OPENED UP ON
OUR COMMUNITIES AN ABS WELL I
THINK THE IMPACT IS THAT IT.
REALLY WEAKENS THE DECISION
MAKING THAT HAPPENS LOCALLY IN
THE COUNTIES THAT ARE SERVED BY
COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY THIS FOR THAT WE WORK
THAT ALL STAKEHOLDERS BE FOCUSED
ON THE SAME GOALS THAT WE BE
PART PULLING IT. RUSSIAN THE PUB
. BETTER OR WHEN THEY'RE
COMPETENT. A PRICE PROVIDERS IN
PARTICULAR OUR SERVICE AREA IS
UNIQUE AND I THINK YOU CAN HEAR
THAT IN THE COMMENTS- FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE BOTH SUPPORT SUPPORTING
AND OPPOSING. IT CAN BEFORE
HELLO HAS FIFTY EIGHT. TWENTIETH
AND THERE'S FIFTY EIGHT VERY.
DIFFERENT- SETS OF COMMUNITIES
AND DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN THE
REGION THAT I SERVE. THERE'S AND
YOU KNOW. DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
DIFFERENT DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND
THE NORTH OF THE COUNTY OR THE
SOUTH THE OTHER IF YOU'RE ON THE
EAST OR WEST SIDE OF A COUNTY-
RESIST. ALL OF THE COMMUNIST
SYSTEMS FOR ALL OF THE STATE TO
GO. TO CALL MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW. SICKENING IN THE THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE MATTER PRO. ARE
YOU SURE THAT THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS- DON'T OPPOSE THIS-
BECAUSE THE KAISER DOES IT
BETTER AND THAT SALUTE WE NOT
AND THAT KAISER THE I THINK IT
WAS A BIRD 2% PERCENT THAT LOCAL
. FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND
FROM MY BOARD'S PERSPECTIVE THIS
IS NOT AN ISSUE ABOUT KAISER.
THIS IS AN IT ABOUT MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE FROM
ESTABLISHED CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POLICY THE COUNTY ORGANIZED
HEALTH SYSTEM MODEL WAS BROUGHT
IN IN THE EIGHTIES BECAUSE THE
SUCH AS THE GOAL YEP IN THE DOOR
. DONE OF THE MID WITH MY- ASK
PRIVATE WRITERS TO BE ON YOUR-
AND HELP DICTATE THE POLICY THAT
WILL GUIDE HOW THE HEALTH PLAN
OFF IT'S THE I. AND WHAT WE- BY
OUR COMMUNITY AS WE TALKED THIS
THIS WITH THAT.
STATION THESE ARE PEOPLE WITH
MEDIC CAL THEIR OTHER. THE
COUNTY ORGANIZED SYSTEM HEALTH
SYSTEM REALLY BREAKS THAT DOWN
BECAUSE WE COLLECTIVELY HAVE TO
PULL TOGETHER. MAKE DECISIONS
SHARED USE OF RESOURCES TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
CAPACITY. TO HAVE PROVIDER
IMPAIR THEIR THE RESULT. OTHER
HIS. EXCELLENCY PROVIDER
SERVICES. IN OUR COMMUNITY IN
SANTA CRUZ THIS IS A NOT TO
SERVE THE MEDICAL RELATION. TO
THE BOTH IN THE- POPULOUS. THE
WAY THE COULD. CAN YOUR- SYSTEM
. THERE CONTRACT WITH HELP AS
PART OF THEIR NETWORK. HAVE TO
BE TO SUPPLY HEALTH THEY COULD
DIRECTLY CONTRACTED THE PROVIDER
I UNDER DIFFERENT BUSINESS
MODELS AND I HEAR SO MUCH TODAY
AND THE DISCUSSION ABOUT CHANGES
HARD AND CHANGE SALUTE. BUT THIS
PURPOSE. WAS SENT TO DIVERT. A
SASS ABOUT CHANGING THE CO MODEL
. BUT HY WOULD WHY WOULD THE
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS GET A 20% CUT
FROM FROM KAISER WILL UPDATE WHY
WOULD THEY GET THAT. AWFULLY I
AND I DON'T. OF A LOT OF AWFUL
LOT BASED I'M NOT SURE WHAT
YOU'RE TO A TERMS OF THE TWENTY
PER CUT MY UNDER. IS THE- MISTER
HE BURKE MY AND ENDING IS THAT
THE OF HELP ON THAT SUB. WITH
KAISER WHICH WE DO NOT BECAUSE
THE NOT TO. OUR SIR. THIS
BECAUSE CUT. ALL OF THOSE THAT
ARE MEDICAL FOR EGGS BUT TERM
CARE SERVICE THEY DON'T BY ME
MAJOR OR TRANSPLANT AND SO THE
HEALTH PLAN THE VAST BEEN OF SIR
TO PAY BUT THE HAVE TO RETAIN
COORDINATION OVER SERVICE THAT
HIGH DOESN'T.
WHAT IMPACT IT'S GONNA HAVE THE
RAW ARIZONA COMPACTS I DON'T
QUITE GET THE GAS STATION AN
ANALOGY YOU HAVE. THAT I CAN
COME BACK TO BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
WANTED TO ASK SOMEBODY IS
SOMEBODY FROM KAISER- OKAY. SO
SOME GENTLEMAN SAID THAT THAT
KAISER. ALREADY SEES ONE THIRD
OF THEIR MEDIC CAL THAT PATIENTS
I'M I'M ONE THING I'M STRUGGLING
WITH- IN THIS- AND BY THE WAY
THIS DOCUMENT THAT STUFF. TO GO
GREAT I'M GLAD THAT HAD A-
LITTLE PUT IT. OTHER SOME
CONVERSE IS I KNOW BUT- BECAUSE
p- IF YOU IF YOU READ IT BUT THIS
IS THE BEST THAT I'VE SEEN OF
ACTUALLY PUTTING IT ALL IN ONE.
TAKE THE DOCUMENT YES. THE THING
THAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH IS
WHAT'S THE CRUX OF ALL THIS
WHAT'S- WHAT'S THE STATE'S
INTEREST. IN IN IN IN DOING THIS
IF- IF KAISER ALREADY THESE
MEDIC CAL PATIENCE. WHY DOES
THERE HAVE TO BE A STATEWIDE
STATE WHAT CON. WITH PROP. MY
ORGANIZATION- THAT DIDN'T GO
THROUGH AN RFP PROCESS HOW YA-
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S
ANYTHING NEW- HERE IF THERE'S NO
BENEFIT TO THE STATE AND SO I'M
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT WITH
THAT WHAT I DID AND BY MIB ITS
PARENT IN MY- BOOK BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T STILL HAS A IN MEDIGAP.
THAT'S I'M GONNA STOP SEEING. IT
IS THE MIKE IS HELLO- THAT THE
ORGANISE HAD TO FORCE THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH SOME SORT OF A DEAL SO
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- THIS.
IN IN DOING THIS- BECAUSE REALLY
THE STATE ALL OF US TOGETHER-
SHOULD BE THAT SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
DIRECTOR BOSS ANSWERED THAT
ORIGINAL QUESTION AS IT TIES
INTO CAL AIMAR ADVANCING AND
INNOVATING MEDICO AND THEN WILL
HAVE- A ROOF SHAPE CANCER
SUBSEQUENCE. SO WE WILL WATCH
GROW THE PIE OUR MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WE WANT THAT KAISER'S
PRESENCE THERE ARE HIGH QUALITY
PLAN WE WANT THEM TO DO MORE IN
THE MEDICAL SPEAKS AND THROUGH
THE PROPOSAL GETTING THEM TO BE
MORE THAN THE STATUS QUO- IN IN
REGARD TO THE- IN ABOUT CAN'T
WE- KEEP THIS. QUOTE SAMPLE AND
NO. CENTRAL VALLEY COUNT. HI
SCHOOL WAS A MEDIC A
SUBCONTRACTOR IN THOSE COUNTIES
BUT THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
THE PRIME PLAN. AND KAISER THEY
CAN COME TO AGREEMENT AND SO
THEY WERE NOT ABLE THEY DO NOT
MAINTAIN A PRESENCE. IN SOMERSET
L. A. COUNTY AS A MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN AND SO THROUGH
THIS DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WILL
ENSURE. THAT HIGH THERE WILL BE
TWO FIFTY AND GROW THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE MEDICAL
SPACE. NO WE- WRITER WE NEED
MORE SPECIAL. SAYS AT BROUGH
THIS ARRANGEMENT WE ARE ALSO
GETTING THEM TO PROVIDE-
SPECIALLY CARE ACT THIS IN OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER SO FOR
NOT HIGHS ARE MADE. OR TO PUT
PAID IN MEDI CAL BE WHAT THE
TODAY. HOW DO WE GET THEM TO
PARTNER WITH OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS HOW DO WE GET
THEM TO INNOVATE AND DELIVER
BETTER CARE FOR OUR
BENEFICIARIES. IS THERE ANY
OTHER ORGANIZATION I KNOW THAT
THIS DOESN'T ISN'T SPECIFICALLY
A CONTRACT WITH KAISER. BUT IT'S
KAISER RIGHT IT'S KAISER IS
THERE ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION
THAT COULD MEET- THAT THAT THAT
THAT COULD MEET HE REQUIREMENTS
OF BEING A BECOMING AN H. A H.
C. S. P. THE CONCERTS ARE NOT
HAPPY TO HAVE DIRECTOR BOSS
ANSWER THE QUESTION DURING OUR
OPENING COMMENTS THOUGH I WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO HIGHLIGHT AGAIN
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROP YET.
INTO BEING TOLD. WELL WITH
INTEGRATED CARE AS THAT CAN BE
MOST BENEFICIAL TO ITS MEMBERS
NO I YEAH I AND I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I MEAN THAT THE CHECK I
MEAN. REALLY THAT THAT THIS IS.
THIS IS KAISER AND THERE'S BEEN
VERY VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO BE
ABLE TO GET A FOR ANYBODY ELSE
TO COME UP WITH THAT SAME MODEL
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF BECOMING AN H.
C. S. B. RIGHT. RIGHT I MEAN HI
THERE IS UNIQUE THAT THEY ARE
ONLY ONE THAT IT STUFF. HAVE
THIS. HERE AT MEDICARE LINES
BUSINESS SO HI THROUGHOUT PIERCE
WE'RE WE'RE TO ELIMINATE THAT
KIND OF TWO TIER SYSTEM BETWEEN
COMMERCIAL CARE AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE REALLY HOW WHO ARE
PARTNERS THAT CAN HELP US GET TO
IT TO THAT QUALITY CARE AND
REALLY MAKING THE OUR- OKAY. AND
THEN ONE QUICK. IF I CAN ASK
JERRY WITH IN MY DISTRICT HAVE
GOT SOME VERY VERY RURAL AREAS-
YOU KNOW I GREW UP IN A SMALL
SMALL TOWN IN MY- IN MY DISTRICT
AND I THINK OF THOSE- HOBBY. A
COMMUNITIES. AND THE IMPACT THAT
THEY WOULD WOULD HAVE OF A TELL
ME AGAIN WHAT. OF WHAT THE ARE
YOU SUGGESTING AGAIN THE YOU CAN
MAYBE DUMP ON THE GAS SURE NOW
THINK TRIED. DUMP ALLEGE CA TO
MAKE THE DOT. DUMB FOR US SO
WHAT IT PACKED. AN ON A-
COMMUNITIES APOLOGIES FOR BEING
ON THAT IS MEMBER BECAUSE IT IS
A CONFUSING SAID OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND AGAIN WE WERE
NOT PART OF CRAFTING ALL OF THIS
BEEN HELPFUL AT THE TABLE TO HOW
CRAFT THIS WE COULD'VE WERE
THROUGH SOME THINGS TOGETHER IF
AT THE TIME IT WAS CREATED THERE
WE COULD HAVE HAD A BOY THE BEEN
STATE IN. AND THEN PUT THE
GRATED APPLE IS THAT KAISER WILL
HAVE BASICALLY THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE THOSE KAISER MEDICARE
MEMBERS IN LARGER METROPOLITAN
AREAS WITHIN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WHERE THEY HAVE ALREADY. A
COMMERCIAL FOOTPRINT 3% THE
CLINIC INFRASTRUCTURE OR
HOSPITAL WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
REPLIED TODAY. FOR THOSE AS ZIP
CODES THOUGH THEY'RE OUTSIDE OF
THAT AREA WE'RE FOR YOUR
DISTRICT. SEARCH OR THEY MAY
HAVE CONFESSED. THOSE BOXES
COULD NOT CHOOSE KAISER BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE A CLINIC
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THAT
SO IN OUR SITUATION WE ACTUALLY
COVER THE ENTIRETY OF THE EMPIRE
ALL TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES NOW. THAT WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED BY KAISER TO FILL THAT
SO THERE IS. THE SIX CONST
THROUGH THIS TO IT WILL BE
UNDERSTAND THROUGH THIS DIRECT
CONTRACT IS IT ZIP CODE SPECIFIC
INSTEAD OF COUNTY SPECIFIC WHERE
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY BE REQUIRED
TO SEE ALL OF THOSE FOLKS EVEN
IN AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE NO
GEOGRAPHIC. ACTUAL LOCATION WELL
SPOKE I DON'T KNOW IF THAT HELPS
OR NOT IT DOES BECAUSE I WAS
JUST YOU KNOW THIS IS. THAT THE
FIRST HEARING WE GET A LITTLE
BIT TIME TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH- SO IT LOOKS AS THOUGH-
YOU ARE OFFERING UP A PROBLEM
WITH THE BILL OF THAT. THAT
MISTER SO. UP B. I'M INTERESTED
IN HAVING- SOME CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND TRY TO
MAKE THE BILL A LITTLE BIT
BETTER I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
THE CAN YOU THE CONSULTATIONS
AND TO LOOK AT AND CONSIDER THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE COMING FROM
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLAN THERE ARE
MET WITH THEM. MY IS. PLANNING A
MEETING WITH LATER THIS WEEK AS
WELL I WILL SAY THAT MANY OF
THEIR AMENDMENTS ARE OVERLY
LIMITING OR REMOVES NECESSARY
LANGUAGE. SOME HAPPY TO WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH PLANS TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH AMENDMENTS WE
CAN- WHEN IT. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION THOUGH COMING BACK
TO WHERE YOU STARTED IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEE DEPRECIATE THE
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING US TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION. THANK YOU
TEACHER. THE CHRISTMAS VIZAG V.
AND THEN STIR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE THAN NOT FEELING
LIKE YOU'RE NOT INCLUDED IN
THESE REALLY TOUGH POLICY
COMMITTEE CONVERSATIONS SO FROM
SIDE PERSON HERE- I FEEL YOUR
PAIN- I'M I ALSO WANT TO SAY IS
THAT I. YOU FRUSTRATE THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY WORK- ARM HAD
OPPORTUNITY THE TABLE SO THIS
THE MAN WAYS DOING THIS- YOU
HAVE ASSURED ME THAT YOU CAN TO
WORK BOTH SIDES. LET'S FACE IT.
THE BEST INTO FROM AN CAL
BENEFICIARY. AND THAT'S WHAT I
HAVE TO KEEP GOING BACK TO AS WE
GO FORWARD- I GREW I TOTALLY
AGREE CHANGE IS DIFFICULT- AND I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS I'D LIKE
TO ASK. A BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT A LOT OF CALLS ON A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ON. FIRST OF I
WANT TO MAKE SURE MY A FEDERALLY
FUNDED- H. R. QS AND SEES WHAT I
JUST GOVERNMENT OF ECONOMICS- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE INCLUDED THAT WERE THERE
AT THE TABLE- I REALLY DEPEND.
UPON THEM IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE LAST THING I
WANT TO SEE SOMEBODY GO UPSIDE
DOWN OVER THOUGH SO I HOPE THE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE-
THEN THE OTHER ONE IS THAT IT.
MAY BE POSSIBLE YOU KNOW. THIS
IS GONNA BE ABLE TO CHERRY PICK.
NEVER COME INTO THE- I'M HAPPY
TO ADDRESS A- BOTH THE CHERRY
PICKING AS WELL AS- WHAT YOU
INITIALLY BROUGHT UP. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AND WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO BRING AND DIRECTOR BOSS
AND- A REEF SHAKE AS WELL- IN
TERMS OF CHERRY PICKING I
THOUGHT WE HEARD EARLIER THERE.
IS NO LOOKING AT MEDICAL
INFORMATION BEFORE YOUR DEFAULT
ASSIGNING A PATIENT. SO THAT 25%
TO KAISER IS OING TO BE
ACCEPTING. WILL BE DEFAULT
WITHOUT ANY LOOK OR EVALUATION
BASED ON THEIR MEDICAL HISTORY.
SO IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO CHERRY
PICK WHEN THE BLOCK. TO WHAT
THEIR MEDICAL HISTORY IS.
INDECISIVE ROGEL WITH WHERE.
WHAT I. IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TAKING THE FOSTER CHILDREN AS
WELL AS THE DUAL ELIGIBLES BOTH
MEDIC CAL AND MEDICARE
OFTENTIMES THERE ARE ELDERS OR
COMPLEX DISEASES AS WELL AS OUR
USED TO HAVE COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. I WOULD CHALLENGE AND
SAY THAT MANY OF THESE PATIENTS
ARE THE COMPLEX PATIENTS THAT
INTEGRATED HEALTH SYSTEM CAN
BEST HELP AND SERVE WITH. WITH
TO BE ABLE TO NOW ASK DR FOST.
AT JUST TO ALSO ADD- THROUGH
THIS A CRISIS IS AS I THINK WAS
ALLUDED TO WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
D. DELEGATE OR RETURNING PATIENT
BE STOPPED IT TOOK COMPLICATED
TO IT THEY WILL THEY MUST ACCEPT
ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO MEET THE
CRITERIA THAT WE WALK THROUGH
AND SO. REALLY THE NOTION. BEING
K. I. APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE- THERE'S A
FALSE I THINK STATEMENTS ARE
BEING MADE AND I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT AND AGAIN ON MY F. IS THE-
REALLY ALL IT TOOK. THEM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S WHERE I'M
NERVOUS ABOUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE BY REPRESENTATION FOR MY-
REAL COMMUNITIES LOT OF
AMERICA'S AREAS AND SO. ANYWAY
YOU CAN HELPING HIM COMPLETELY
KEEP THEM AT THE TABLE AND TRULY
APPRECIATE IT. WILL WILL STATE
AS WE- TALKED IN PRIVATE THAT-
WE ARE CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR FQHCS THE
LANGUAGE WASN'T READY TO INSERT
. IN THE COMMITTEE BUT BELIEVE
IT WILL BE READY FOR FLOOR
AMENDMENTS IF THIS BILL IS ABLE
TO GET OUT OF. TODAY AND- WILL
ALLOW. BOTH KAISER AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO TALK ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING DEMO YOU. THANK IN
THANK YOU MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD HI I THINK PUBLIC
OUTREACH MAKING SURE THE VOICES
ARE HEARD AGIS PARAMOUNT. AND-
YOU'RE DOING THIS IS IT.
EVERYONE AT THE TABLE THANK YOU
. HE WAS FIGURE CURRY MCCARTY.
YEAH I THINK YOU JUST THREE
THREE ISSUES BUT- BUT BRIEFLY I
KNOW. THIS IS NOT A PERFECT
PROCESS BUT YOU KNOW MR ARAMBULA
YOU AND I CHAIR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE IN THE LAST HOUR
NINETY MINUTES HERE IS WAY MORE
THAN WE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IN THE
BACK AND FORTH WITH THE BUDGET
FOR THIS.
PERFECT BUT AGAIN IT'S WAY
BETTER THAN HAVING A JAM DOWN
OUR THROATS. BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. WHEN THERE'S NOT MUCH BACK
AND FORTH AND BACK AND FORTH
TODAY. AS TODAY. THE
PREPARATIONS OF FLOOR ABOVE
APPLIED AND AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
SO. I AND- M. SUPPORT OF WHAT
THE SPEAKER SAID IS HEY THIS IS
A BIG DEAL LET'S SLOW DOWN THIS
THIS. UP C. SAYS N. TOOK.
GRENADE MUCH YOU HUNCHED I
BELIEVE IN IMPACT THIS BUT YOU
THOUGHT THIS IS A ISSUE WERE PER
SE I'M NOT CERTAIN ON AND I KNOW
SOME OF MY COUNTIES HAVE CALLED
ME AS WELL SO WHEN I GET TO THAT
BUT THE FIRST QUESTION IS- I
KNOW YOU AND I SPOKE ABOUT THAT
THERE WAS A CONCERN ABOUT KAISER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT'S BROUGHT
TO US BY. AND ADDRESS. AND WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HEALTH ELEMENTS ARE
ADEQUATE FOR CALIFORNIANS I
THINK IT'S A- COMPLETELY
APPROPRIATE TO CRITIQUE TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE LOOKING AT DATA AND
ANALYZING IF THAT IS WHAT WE CAN
MAKE IMPROVE. I THINK WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT CUTS- THERE ARE
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT AND NEED
WITHIN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND-
I'M EXCITED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH N. U. H. W.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GET TO
A RESOLUTION. UNDERSTANDING
THERE. AUDIT TO BE COMPLETED AND
THEY WOULD LIKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO COME FROM THAT AUDIT BUT
BELIEVE WE NEED TO HAVE GUESTS
ON GETTING CAL LAME STARTED BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. AND
SO ON IT IS TO WORK WITH LABOR
TO HEAR THOSE CONCERNS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
AND MAKE SURE THAT KAISER IS
MEETING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF- IT'S MATTER ALLEN
ROWLEY'S. WILL NOW AT HIGHS ARE
TO STEP IN AND ALSO SPEAK ABOUT
HOW THEY ARE GOING TO BE MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IS. HI THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA- I THINK- ONE THING TO
POINT OUT IS THAT- THAT SHORTAGE
OF MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS IS
REALLY IN A NATIONWIDE ISSUE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS
CERTAINLY BEEN BROUGHT TO LIGHT
MORE RECENTLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC US WITH SOMETHING THAT
I THINK EVERYBODY IN THE HEALTH
CARE SPACE IS WORKING THROUGH-
THAT BEING SAID HOWEVER- IN THE
PAST- FIVE YEARS AS AN EXAMPLE
KAISER PERMANENT DATES ADDED
HUNDREDS. OF NEW PATIENTS TO OUR
STAFF AND WE CONTINUE TO ADD
THEM ON A DAILY BASIS. AND I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAVE TO KEEP ON DOING-
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST. I THINK I
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN IN THE HOUSE
TO HAVE TO FILL. I'M OTHER I
AREAS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IS
RETENTION STRATEGY THIS IS
ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT ASPECT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
IN OUR SYSTEM AND RETENTION IS A
REALLY BIG PART OF IT- AND
ANOTHER THING I WOULD POINT OUT-
IS THAT ONE THING THAT HAS COME
OUT CERTAINLY. MORE DURING THE
PAST WEEK- IS VIRTUAL CARE AND
WE'VE EXPANDED OUR VIRTUAL CARE
OPTIONS AGAIN FOR. THOSE MEMBERS
WHO WANTED- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR
MEMBERS ONE VIRTUAL. OKAY FROM.
HAD CUSTOMS AVAILABLE HI TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A SEAMLESS WAY
THAT WE CAN SEE OUR PATIENTS IN
A WAY THAT THAN MEETS THAT MEETS
THEIR NEEDS- I THINK I DOCTOR
AMULET TO THIS- I THINK- I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
ANYONE SYSTEM IS PERFECT BUT I
THINK WORKING TOWARDS PERFECTION
BUT THAT'S THAT'S A FAIR WAY TO
PUT IT OUT RECENT- RECENT-
RESULTS FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT ADVOCATE HAVE HAVE HAVE
SHOWN HI LADIES CORES
SPECIFICALLY FOR KAISER
PERMANENTE'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND AGAIN WE HOPE THAT THIS IS
CONTINUE. OUT WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO BETTER AND BETTER TO
SERVE OUR OUR MEMBERS SPECIFIC
TO SPECIFIC TO BE ABLE. OKAY AND
THEN WHAT ONE OTHER QUESTION. SO
THIS YOU KNOW COMMITTEE IS ABOUT
EXPANDING HEALTHCARE ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT YOU KNOW
MONTROSE HEALTH PROVIDERS LIKE
YOU AND DOCTOR WOULD IS IN A NO
HARM. SO THERE'S A BUNCH OF OUR
CLINICS IN OUR COUNTIES THEY'RE
SAYING HEY THIS IS GOING TO HARM
US AND IN US PROVIDING CARE TO
PEOPLE- I DON'T HAVE A LETTER
HERE FROM MY COUNTY BUT I HEARD
FROM A LOT OF OTHERS WELL I HAVE
A LETTER FROM YOLO COUNTY NOT
FROM SACRAMENTO. BUT FROM UP
THERE COUNTY SO WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY YOU KIND OF ANSWERED THIS
WITH- MISTER MAYES QUESTIONING
WHAT YOU SAY TO THE- FEEDBACK
YOU GOT FROM SOME KIND OF THIS
IS GOING TO HARM. THEIR ABILITY
. TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE. I
WOULD IF I CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE MEDIC CAL IN
RALEIGH. A DOCTOR WOULD AND I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT ON A
SELECT COMMITTEE WHERE WE HEARD
FROM CALIFORNIANS. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS WE HEARD WAS
ABOUT AFFORDABILITY. WHEN YOU
HAVE UNNEEDED LAYERS OF
BUREAUCRACY AND ADMINISTRATION
YOU CREATE. THE AND
AFFORDABILITY THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE WITHIN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. BY FIGURING OUT HOW WE
CAN REDUCE THESE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES AND MAKE SURE THAT MEDICARE
ALL. FEES ARE GOING TOWARDS A
MEDIC CAL POSS IS HOW WE WILL BE
ABLE TO CREATE THAT
AFFORDABILITY AND DELIVER A
BETTER PRODUCT FOR THE MEDIC
CALENDAR. A MISS WALDRON AND
THEN MR BIGELOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A QUICK ONE
QUESTION AND I THINK IT WAS KIND
OF ALLUDED TO SO I JUST WANTED A
LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC- WHAT IS
THE SPECIFIC PLAN. TO INCREASE
STAFFING- TO ENSURE YOU CAN
PROVIDE CARE TO YOUR CURRENT
MEMBERS WHAT IS BEEN DOTSON WHAT
DO YOU PLAN TO DO- YOU KNOW THE
LAW REQUIRES WITH S. B. TWO TWO
ONE WHICH I CO AUTHORED AND WAS
A BIG PROPONENT OF. THAT WHICH
WAS TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
STANDARDS- BOTH FOR PLANS AND TO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE AND HEALTH
FOR TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE SO.
YOU KNOW NUMBERS OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU NEED TO BRING ON TO
REACH THE GOAL OF THIS WHAT'S
THE COST HOUSE THAT'S GOING TO
BE COVERED. I WILL ALLOW KAISER
TO ADDRESS THAT QUESTION BUT
SINCE YOU BROUGHT UP TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS. I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
NEED THAT TRANSPARENCY TO HAVE
THE ACCOUNTABILITY. CURRENTLY
WHEN YOU HAVE THE PRIME CONTRACT
AND SUBCONTRACT THERE'S
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW US TO HAVE THAT
NECESSARY TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IF WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT QUALITY SCORES AND LOOK
TOWARDS TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
SIMPLIFICATION OF THE SYSTEM.
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL AGAIN
WOULD BE SOME NECESSARY BUT
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK
KAISER TO. ANSWER WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN PREPARATION. THANK YOU
SO MEMBER- WITH REGARDS TO S. B.
TWO TWENTY ONE I'M HAPPY TO- TO
MAYBE SHARE WITH YOUR STAFF SOME
SPECIFICS ON NUMBERS BUT WHAT I
CAN SHARE- IS THAT OUR TEAM HAS
BEEN WORKING REALLY REALLY HARD-
ON ENSURING FULL COMPLIANCE AND
WE EXPECT TO BE IN FULL
COMPLIANCE OF S. S. B. TWO. TO
TWENTY ONE BY THE JULY FIRST A
TIME FRAME- AND I THINK RATHER
QUESTIONED- WAS JUST AROUND- YOU
KNOW I GUESS JUST. J. AND I.
SITE DR PUT IT TO- IS THAT IN
KERN ST DH YES HAS A VERY-
EXTENSIVE A DASHBOARD THAT THE
THAT THE PRODUCER ON QUALITY-
IT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE I THINK
ANYONE CAN ACCESS IT CAN
ACTUALLY EVEN DEEPER UNDERSTAND
LIKE WHAT THE METRICS ARE WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT- IN KERN ST-
THAT DATA IS ONLY AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY FOR OUR DIRECT
CONTRACTS I'M IN SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO AND- AND THREE REAL COUNT.
I WITH A DIRECT CONTRACT AGAIN
TO GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL POINT
ABOUT OVERSIGHT AND OUT OF THE
CONTRACT- THAT KAISER PERMANENTE
IS THE MEASURES WE WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. BACK TO
YOU I'D LIKE NOT THE DIRECT
CONTRACT ASPECT. I THINK YOU
KNOW PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE FACT THAT KAISER PERMANENTE
WILL BE HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AS EVERY OTHER MANAGED
CARE PLAN IN THE STATE. THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW. THANK YOU
ARE MISTER CHAIR- YOU GAVE A
REALLY GOOD RESPONSE TO OUR
COULD REFRAIN FROM SACRAMENTO
AND IT TALKED ABOUT LAYERING.
THE REAL CRUX OF THIS ISSUE IN
THIS ENTIRE DEBATE IS ABOUT THE
HIGHER COSTS THE PEOPLE ARE
FEELING THE DISPROPORTIONATE.
AND THE UNFAIRNESS OF THOSE
COSTS IN YOUR BILL YOU'RE TRYING
TO ATTEMPT TO CORRECT THAT LIKE
READING A WHOLE NEW LAYER BY
CREATING A NEW BENEFIT LATER. AT
PICKING UP. FIELD AND FIND THE
BABY. IS NOT GOING TO BE QUITE
AS LEVEL AS WE'D LIKE IT TO BE
BUT IT'S STILL. A LITTLE TILTED
. HELP US UNDERSTAND HAT
INSTEAD OF DOING WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY ARE WE GOING
BACK AND REVIEWING ALL THIS
LAYERING THAT'S CAUSING THE
TRAUMA AND THE DIFFICULTIES IN
THE ADDED COSTS. WHERE WE-
UNRAVEL THE SYSTEM SOMEWHAT IF
YOU WITH. AND FIXING. THE BROKEN
PIECES. TO MAKE IT SO THE SYSTEM
ACTUALLY BECOMES AFFORDABLE.
HAPPY TO BRING IN DIRECTOR BOSS
I WILL ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY THOUGH BY HAVING A
DIRECT CONTRACT WE ARE
SIMPLIFYING THE ADMINISTRATION
AND BUREAUCRACY HEY WE NO LONGER
WILL HAVE A NEED TO HAVE A PRIME
CONTRACT AND TO PAY THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. WE WILL BE
ABLE NOW HAVE DIRECT OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY WITH THE PLAN
AND WILL SIMPLIFY THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL IN ESSENCE DOES I
WOULD LIKE TO BRING IN DIRECTOR
BOSSES WILL. END I WOULD I JUST
IN ADDITION BROAD SPEAKING ON.
YOU ARE. IMAGE CARE ON TRACK
THAT WILL GO LIVE J. ONE TWENTY
FOUR THAT WILL BE TO ALL A MAN
CARE. LOCAL INITIATIVE
COMMERCIAL KAISER. REALLY GETS
AT YOUR POINT ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THOSE LAYERS
OF DELEGATION. THROUGH THIS
CONTRACT PLANS WILL HAVE TO
JUSTIFY PROVIDER THAT RATIONALE.
DELEGATING THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES SO THE
CONSUMERS THE DEPARTMENT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING FOR THESE LAYERS
WHILE THEY REQUIRE THEIR THEIR
THEIR THE VALUES WERE GETTING
FROM A BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT.
THOSE EXTRA LAYERS ARE.
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
CONFUSING TO CONSUMERS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AT THAT ISSUE
DURING THE CONTRACT. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT IT'S STILL
IT DELIGHTS THE FACT OF THE
COMPLICATED ISSUES THAT WE'RE
ALL FACED WITH HERE. TODAY AND
NONE THE LESS. CREATING A WHOLE
NEW SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP
BENEFITS. WHILE YOU WILL BECOME
A MORE LEAD PROMINENT IN THIS
BENEFIT WE'RE HEARING TWO SIDES
OF A STORY ON HOW TO REMEDY.
THIS PROBLEM AND IN THE FACT
THERE BECOMES A WINNER AND A
LOSER. AND THAT'S THE CONCERN IS
BEING PRESENTED TODAY A WINNER
AND A LOSER. WHEN IN FACT WE
COULD ALL WINNERS IF WE JUST
TAKE THE SYSTEM AND REALLY GO
BACK TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. SELECT COMMITTEES
FOCUSING AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
TALENTED AND KNOWLEDGEABLE IN
THIS WORLD. BREAKING DOWN THE
SYSTEM AND UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THESE FAULTS ARE. AND BY USING
SOME OF THE SYSTEMATIC PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE AROUND
HERE TO ADVISE US IT WOULD SEEM
LIKE COMMON SENSE WOULD PREVAIL
AND WE WOULD COME UP WITH A MUCH
MORE. EFFECTIVE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THEY'LL HELP EVERYBODY.
DOESN'T MATTER WHO THEY ARE. AS
LORD KNOWS RIGHT NOW OUR SYSTEM
IS. PROBABLY SECOND TO NONE IN
THE WORLD FOR CARE BUT IS
COMPLICATED AND IS BEING
TROUBLED. BY THE INABILITY.
PATIENTS TO GET WITH THEIR
DOCTORS WITH THEIR CARE GIVERS
WITH THEIR HOSPITALS EVERYBODY.
BECAUSE THERE'S SOMEBODY OUT
HERE NOW SAYING WELL WHAT YOU
CAN'T DO THIS YOU CAN'T DO THAT
. I JUST THINK THAT THERE'S A
BETTER WAY FOR US TO HANDLE IS.
THIS MAY NOT BE THE BEST WAY
TODAY. BUT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BECAUSE IF
WE DON'T TAKE AND HOW THESE
DISCUSSION WE'RE ALL GONNA SAY
THE SAME THING. IF WE DON'T HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS NOTHING WILL
EVER GET DONE. I THANK YOUNG
NEED MAYBE TAKE A STEP BACK
THAT'S JUST ME TODAY. HE WAS A
REGULAR- MISTER FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A DOCTOR EMILY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND ANY WORK TO
GET IT OUT OF BUDGET WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A POLICY
DISCUSSION I THINK THAT THAT
CANNOT BE. OVERSTATED HOW
IMPORTANT THAT ACTUALLY WAS TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP I DO FIND IT- JUST
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN THE DIRECTOR
BROUGHT IT UP. WHERE THIS BILL.
WAS ENCOURAGING KAISER TO GET
MORE INVOLVED. HEY THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ENCOURAGING
KAISER TO GET MORE INVOLVED AND
REALLY. EASE OF LEGISLATION TO
MAKE SOME THE ONLY ONE THAT CAN
ACTUALLY DO IT RIGHT NOW. WHERE
THE BASICALLY KIND OF TO HANDLE
IT. AND THE N. MY MIND A FREE
MARKET REACH BETTER RESULTS FOR
EVERYBODY IN WHEN WE REDUCE OUR
COMMUNITIES. ACCESS TO
PROVIDERS. I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT CREATES MORE CARE- SITE
WITH YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT FOR
ME JUST BRIEFLY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
BOARD THE CAN CAN DO THIS. WE'RE
NOW KIND OF GIVE TO ONE. AND IF
WE REDUCED PEOPLE'S POTENTIAL.
HOW'S THAT CREATE MORE ACCESS.
BUT I'LL START UP AGAIN AND THEN
TOSSED IT TO DIRECTOR BOSS I
THINK EARLIER WE HEARD ABOUT
APPLES AND ORANGES AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO FOCUS ON THE
INTEGRATED NATURE OF KAISER AS A
PLAN. BY HAVING A PROVIDER
NETWORK WHICH IS INCLUDED IN
THAT THEY GROW UP TO THAT LIMIT
WHEN YOU HAVE OTHER PLANS THEY
MAY TAKE CONSUMERS AND THEN
ATTEMPT TO BUILD THE NETWORK
AFTER. WE HAVE HAD BETTER
RESULTS WHEN WE HAVE SEEN THESE
INTEGRATED SYSTEMS AND RESPECT
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE UNWILLING
TO GROW BEYOND THE CAPACITY THAT
THEY FEEL IS. SAFE FOR THE
ENROLLEES BUT WILL ALLOW
DIRECTOR ASKED TO STEP IN. GREAT
AND THIS IS REALLY INCREASING
CAPACITY TO SERVE OUR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WITH THE
EXPANSIONS THAT WE PROPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE A MEDIC CAL ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED TWENTY SIX
TO FORTY NINE. YEARS OF AGE WE
HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
NEW MEDICAL MEMBERS THAT THAT
WILL BE JOINING ATJANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE NEED TO
INCREASE CAPACITY IN THE SYSTEM
TO SERVE OUR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN THIS IS ONE OF
THE OPTIONS TO DO THAT IS
REALLY. HOW DO WE THINK THROUGH
HOW TO BRING IN MORE QUALITY
PROVIDERS TO THE MEDICAL SPACE.
SO IT CAN I AM IN THIS IN THIS
IS NOT AN ISSUE WITH KAISER FOR
ME PERSONALLY I'M A- THERE'S IT.
IS NOT I MEAN I. AND I DON'T
HAVE USED YOUR IS IN A MEETING
WE MIGHT JUST HAVE TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IT DOES JUST SEEM A LITTLE
BIT INTERESTING TO ME- THAT IF
ONLY ONE PERSON OF THE BILLS
RIGHT NOT ONLY ONE PERSON IS
ACTUALLY IS THE CRITERIA TO.
THIS CON. HOW THE EVEN IF WE'RE
BRINGING ON ALL THESE NEW
PEOPLE. POTENTIALLY REDUCING
THEIR ABILITY TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND BRING IT INTO ONE
FACILITY HOW DOES THAT ACTUALLY
CREATE. ACCESS AND FOR ME AS A
CENTRAL VALLEY ELECTED LIKE.
THAT WE CARE ABOUT. ANYTHING
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY REDUCE MY
NO DOCTOR EMILY SHE HAD LIKE YOU
KNOW THIS- ANYTHING AND THAT'S
WHY. I'M I'M NOT GONNA VOTE NO
ON THIS I'M JUST GONNA LAY OFF
OF IT TODAY BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IT GET FIXED- BUT I DO
THINK THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
AND I KNOW YOU'LL ADDRESS THOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- I HAVE A-
COUPLE QUESTIONS- THE FIRST ONE
DIRECTED AT DIRECTOR BOSS. SO
THE 25% ROUTE. THE INCREASE OF
KAISER- PROVIDING SERVICES FOR
MEDICAL PATIENTS WAS THAT
ROUGHLY GO OUT TO IN A NUMBER
NUMBER OF PATIENTS. SURE SO
TODAY AT KAISER HAS ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND COMMENTED FOR
MEMBERS A WE THINK WITH THE RE
DETERMINATIONS THAT WILL BEGIN
HAPPENING ONCE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- ENDS WE WILL COMMENCE
REDETERMINATION FOR MEDICAL
POPULATION AND SO WE SUSPECT
THAT THAT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WILL BE REDUCED PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 800-800-5900
NO. SENATE SO FROM THE START
TRACK JACKET ONE TWENTY FOUR. AT
FROM THERE 220% TO LET'S YOU
KNOW SOMEWHERE BETWEEN EIGHT
HUNDRED TO EIGHT FIFTY PROBABLY
AS A STARTING POINT AND THEN
GROWING 25% ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND. MORE MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE MEMBERS FOR CHRYSLER AND
THAT'S WHAT I UNDERSTOOD AND I
THANK YOU FOR TAKING LEADING
THAT. THAT IS. ONE POINT FOUR
PERCENT. OF THE ENTIRE MEDICARE
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO PART OF WHAT I'M
GRAPPLING WITH IS. HOW DOES
THIS. IN THE C  SYSTEM. IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE POINT
FOUR PERCENT. I'M SORRY THAT
JUST DOESN'T COMPUTE WITH ME- IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. AS FAR AS
RURAL DISRUPTION. SPEND A LITTLE
TIME TO MY DISTRICT. IN YOUR
IDEA THAT SOMEHOW WE SHOULD BE
EXPANDING THE KAISER SERVICE
AREA TO STEEP SERVICE PEOPLE IN
YUCCA VALLEY OR FURTHER OUT
THAT'S REALLY MAKE ANY SENSE
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I DO. I
DON'T HAVE A BECAUSE PRESENCE
BEYOND THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA-
REALLY ESSENTIALLY IN CINEMA
COUNTY I'VE GOT THREE HUNDRED
MILES OF MY DISTRICT. EXPANDING
THE SERVICE AREA FOR KAISER TO
MY ENTIRE DISTRICT BECAUSE THIS
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH. DOESN'T HELP
WITH ACCESS. I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
AND MAYBE AT SOME POINT AS OF
THESE DISCUSSIONS WHEN I COULD
GET INTO IT TODAY BUT- I WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE FROM AN OPERATIONAL
STANDPOINT. THIS BERMAN ACCESS
POINTS AND POINT I DON'T GET
SOMEBODY IN TRINITY COUNTY
SUDDENLY HAVE BE A MEDIC CAL
PROVIDER TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE HELL TO GO. THAT WILL
HELP ANYBODY- AND SO THAT IS
THAT IS THOSE WHO SO YOU NEED
TO. IF THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO YOU NEED TO FIND A
BETTER WAY TO MAKE THAT WORKS I
DON'T SEE HOW IT WORKS QUITE
FRANKLY- SOME SO. WE MENTION A
BIT AT WAS MADE. OF THREE FROM
KAISER TALK ABOUT AUDIT THAT J.
LACK AUDIT WAS AT ONE OF OUR
AUDITS. THIS WEEK REGARDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO WE'RE WHAT
IS THAT AUDIT WHO DID IT. AND
WHERE WHERE WHEN WE GET TO SEE
THE RESULTS- I THINK MAYBE THIS
IS RELATED IDEA ME SEE AUDIT
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH. I THINK
THIS IS- AN AUDIT THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE PLACE- OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD- WITH TWENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT HEALTH PLANS. THAT'S
NOT JUST A KAISER PERMANENTE
IDITAROD ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM. SO THIS HASN'T HAPPENED
YET CORRECT. SO WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW IF YOU'RE IMPROVING YOUR-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AT
WHAT I A WAY WHAT I DID ALLUDED
TO EARLIER WAS- RECENT QUALITY
AND MEMBER SATISFACTION SCORES
THAT CAME OUT OF THE OFFICE OF
THE PATIENT ADVOCATE SO WE
DEFINITELY HAVE THAT- AND I
THINK ALSO. NOTABLY ININ KERN
ST KAISER PERMANENTE IS SUBJECT
TO- THE SAME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ACCESS YOU KNOW STANDARDS AS
OTHER MANAGED CARE PLANS- SO.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT MAYBE TO.
SPEAK TO BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S
THAT'S DEFINITELY PART OF THAT
THE MANAGED CARE. FOR SITE
PROCESS THAT THAT CREDIT TAKES
PLACE BOTH ON THE PHYSICAL AND-
WELL THEN OFF BEGINNING. THEN
BECAUSE THAT'S HAVE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY ALL ANY OF US HAVE
AT THIS POINT I'D LOVE TO SEE
THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT DATA
WITH THAT I'M NOT SUBJECT TO
THAT. YET SO IF YOU HAVE THAT.
DOCTOR BOSS OR SOMEONE CAN PASS
THAT. THAT INFORMATION TO US AS
A COMMITTEE WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CONCERNS WE HAVE.
LOOK AT THANK MUCH PREPARE
KAISER KAISER IS A FABULOUS
SYSTEM PATIENTS LOVE KAISER I
MEAN THE IDEA HERE IS TO TRY TO
GET MORE PATIENTS INTO THE
CUTTERS BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM MORE
MEDICARE PATIENTS OF ECO SYSTEM
SO PLEASES NOT A RUB ON ON YOUR
QUALITY MEASURES BUT ONE OF THE
BILL THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE
HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS
AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND
OUR FRIENDS IF YOU ANY AND YOU
H. W. SAY THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO BE READY TO IMPLEMENT
SB TWENTY ONE. THEIR LIVES IN
PROVIDE. AT A PRETTY RAPID RATE-
AND SO. IN AN AREA WHERE WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING STRUGGLE WITH
PEOPLE GETTING AXED TIME ACCESS
TO CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THAT AND NOW WE
HAVE FOSTER YOUTH. AND A GREAT
NUMBER OF THOSE- I DON'T KNOW
THE PERCENTAGE BUT A GREAT
NUMBER OF THOSE CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO NEED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. I DON'T EXPLAIN TO ME
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO. KEEP YOU
KNOW GET AND BUILD THE WORKFORCE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE NOT JUST TO
YOUR TO THE NEW. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUT TO THE POPULATION
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS THAT IN
MANY CASES FEEL THEY'RE NOT
GETTING ADEQUATE SERVICE. SURE I
THINK AGAIN GOING BACK TO S. B.
TWO TWENTY ONE- I THINK- AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT- I THINK- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE TO THIS PUBLIC
PROCESS YOU KNOW THAT. WAS THAT
LEGISLATIVE YOU KNOW. IS IT IS
IMPOSED REALLY IMPORTANT
REQUIREMENTS I'M ON ON ALL
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND KAISER
PERMANENTE FULLY EXPECTS TO BE
COMPLIANT BY BY JULY FIRST. IN
TERMS OF THE- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
POPULATIONS HE MENTIONS IT AS
YOU KNOW FOSTER USE OR- OR TO
THE ELIGIBLES- I MEAN I CAN I
CAN CERTAINLY SHARE YOU KNOW
THAT- YOU KNOW IS GOING BACK TO
DOCTOR AMBULANCE. IT WAS AT THE
KAISER MODEL WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
YOU KNOW. FILLING UP. PORTNER
NUMBER TWO. OUR MANAGED CARE
PLANS I THINK IT'S REALLY
HALLMARK THAT IS THE FACT THAT
WE'RE IN A GREAT SYSTEM IT'S I
THINK A FOR A FOR A VULNERABLE
MEMBER WITH COMPLEX CARE NEEDS
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO GO NAVIGATE
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS OF CARE
PROVIDER GROUPS THEY GET ALL OF
THEIR CARE WITHIN ONE SYSTEM AND
THIS ALLOWS OUR CHRIST A-
PHYSICIANS HAVE REAL TIME DATA
TO IT TO VERY YOU KNOW TUESDAY
TO SEAMLESSLY CREATE YOU KNOW
CARE PLANS- WHICH DRIVES QUALITY
QUALITIES IS DRIVEN WITH THAT.
THAT INTEGRATE. AT LEAST IN PART
. YOU KNOW THAT SAME INTEGRATED
SYSTEM HELPS YOU KNOW PER.
IMPROVED HEALTH AS WE- I THINK
REALLY THAT THE HALLMARK IS
REALLY WITH KAISER THE SECRET
SAUCE IS REALLY THAT THAT THAT
THEY INTEGRATED MODEL. I GUESS I
WOULD JUST GO BACK TO THE- THE
ANECDOTAL PART THAT HERE THE A
GRADE MODELS WORKING REALLY
REALLY WELL WITH THE EXCEPTION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND SO MY
QUESTION IS HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
GEAR UP AND HOW YOU CAN MAKE
THAT WORK IN MAYBE DOCTOR
DIRECTOR PROCESSING CONTACT I
WOULD JUST ADD FOR OUR FOSTER
YOUTH JUST KIND OF FIND OUT ONE
OF OUR CALVET. I'M POLICY. IT IS
THE- CARE ACT ARE ACCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ITEM FIVE YOUTH WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA THEY
HAVE AUTOMATIC M. THAT MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SO WE ANTICIPATE MOST OF
IF NOT ALL OF THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH PEER ALL SERVICES WOULD
BE PROVIDED BY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH I GIVEN THE KELLY POLICY
. THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE I LOST
IT. AND ALLOW US WITH WITHIN SET
UP HERE FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
MAYBE TO COME BACK TO ME AND
MAYBE NOT SO. I'D LIKE I DO ONE
OF THEM- SOME COMMENTS- BUT I'M
I'M I'D LIKE YOU TO- ACTUALLY
LIKE IT GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY DR
EVERY OF CLOTHES FIRST THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY. AB TWO. T. FOR
WOULDN'T- THAT H. C. S. P.'S ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
OVERARCHING GOALS FOR MEDICAL.
TO PRESERVE CONTINUITY OF CARE
TO PROMOTE. THE HIGH QUALITY
OUTCOMES TO REDUCE DISPARITIES
TO REMOVE LAYERS OF COMPLEXITY
BUREAUCRACY. AND THE COST. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR REGULAR AND I
DID THAT OUT OF ORDER SO- BUT
I'M GOING TO STILL MAKE MY
COMMENTS ANYWAY I COULD DO THAT
AS THE CHAIR- SO JUST JUST MY
COMMENTS YOU KNOW MY FOCUS ON
THIS BILL HAS BEEN- WHAT'S IN
THE BEST INTEREST AMERICA
BENEFICIARIES. HAVING A GREAT
KAISER PRESENCE IN THE PROGRAM
IS A GOOD THING- BECAUSE NOT A
PERFECT PLAN ARE WE THERE IS A
PERFECT PLAN- I'M SERIOUSLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ITS NEED TO
IMPROVE PERFORMANCE AS I'VE
TALKED ABOUT IN MENTAL HEALTH. I
DON'T WANT TO LOSE SIGHT OF THAT
IN THIS PROPOSAL IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF THE
BENEFICIARIES AND THE POTENTIAL
BENEFICIARIES. I MEAN SET BACK
QUITE BECAUSE OF QUALITY SCORES
AND POSITION TO BENEFIT. BILLS
ARE. POP UP. APPLE KAISER
CONSISTENTLY SCORES ABOVE 90% IN
THE AGGREGATED QUALITY FACTOR
SCORE BY COMPARISON THE AT THE
WEIGHTED AVERAGE OF OTHER
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS A
65% I'M SURE WE'D HEAR ARGUMENTS
AS TO WHY THAT IS- BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT IS THOSE ARE THE
NUMBERS REGARDLESS OF HOW HOW
THEY ARE I'VE DOT. ADDITIONALLY
A KAISER HAS THIS WORK FOR ONE
RELEASED IT DOES FOR MEDICAL SO
IF YOU'RE A MEDIC CAL KAISER
PLAN THAT MEMBER YOU'RE GONNA
GET THE SAME CHARACTER THAT THE
RIGHT MEMBERS GOING TO GET. IS
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT. BONTA IF.
IT SERVICE SURVEY. MEDICARE
BENEFITS. HAVE DIFFICULTY
FINDING CARE PARTICULARLY
SPECIALIST YET WITHIN THE KAISER
SYSTEM THEY'RE GOING TO BE RIGHT
THERE- IN RESPONSE CANCERS- BY
THE OPPOSITION AND WESTERN
MISSING A TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR
THAT LOCAL HEALTH PLANS. THERE
KEEP HUGELY IMPORTANT- AND IN
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH. WHICH SERVES
FIVE THE FIVE COUNTIES IN MY
DISTRICT- MANY OF THEM WELL BUT
THEY'RE ALL. WE'RE ALL FACING IN
GENERAL- CHALLENGES WITH ACCESS
BECAUSE THE ROLE NATURE THE
COUNTIES SO. A SIMPLE TO THE-
THESE PLANS SIR IS IT EXPRESS.
ALSO THINK THE CONCERN COME IN
PART FROM A FEAR OF CHANGE-
WHILE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL RESULT IN SOME CHANGE.
TO THEIR MODEL I DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IS A RADICAL IS A PLANE
REMEMBER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE
POINT 4% TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND.
AS EVEN A TOUCH FOR THE COUNTIES
I REPRESENT BECAUSE THAT. ISN'T
THERE IT NOW- SO CURRENTLY WE
GOT SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND BENEFICIARIES. RECEIVE
CARE THROUGH SUBCONTRACTED
ARRANGEMENTS WITH KAISER.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND ARE DIRECT
HAS A MAJOR MET MEMBERS. THE
NUMBER OF BENEFICIARIES
CURRENTLY PROPOSED OUT TO
INCREASE WE TALKED ABOUT THAT AS
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. TO GET
KAISER TO JUST OPEN MILLION ONCE
ONCE THE ONCE THE DUST SETTLES
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND A
YEAR. AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EIGHT THREE OUR POINT TWO POINT
3% A YEAR CHANGE I KNOW CHANGE
IS HARD THAT'S PRETTY DARN SLOW
AND CRIMINAL. THE REAL CHANGE IS
REALLY NOT SO MUCH THE NUMBER OF
BENEFICIARIES BUT THE SHIFT FROM
PLANTS SUBCONTRACTING WITH
KAISER THE STATE CONTRACTING
DIRECTLY WITH KAISER. THE SINGLE
STATEWIDE CONTRACT REDUCES
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WHICH IS
HUGELY IMPORTANT TO DR RANDALL
AND I AND MANY PEOPLE ON THIS
COMMITTEE. BY ELIMINATING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE CHARGED BY
PUBLIC PLANS AND ELIMINATES THE
NEED FOR A DOZEN SUBCONTRACTS
SUBCONTRACTOR CONCEPT. SPENCE
WAS THAT WORDS ARE TODAY- BUT
THE CHANGES IN THOSE
ARRANGEMENTS THAT THERE IS
THERE'S A COST TO THOSE
ARRANGEMENTS AND PUT TOGETHER.
BILL INCLUDES MISTER CAPTAIN
ROMAN BY COUNTY AS A MEANS TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS. THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. NOT NOT AND IT WASN'T
EVEN ADDRESSED BY THE OPPOSITION
. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL SUBJECTS
KAISER TO ALL MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE TERMS OF CONTRACT EXCEPT
FOR ACCEPTING ALL POTENTIAL
ROWLEY'SAND PROHIBITS KAISER
FROM DENYING COVERAGE TO PEOPLE.
AFTER COSMETIC OUT FOR PRO.
SOURCE WHICH REP WITHOUT OF
WHICH REPRESENT THE PROTECTIONS
I THINK ARE CRITICAL. I CONTINUE
TO ENCOURAGE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS
TO PROPOSE AMENDMENTS BUT ONES
THAT FOCUS ON PROTECTING
BENEFICIARIES WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE SAME AS
PROTECTING A BUSINESS MODEL. I
DID WANT TO POINT OUT ONE THINGTHAT JUST SO THAT EVERYBODY IS
AWARE BECAUSE I'VE IT MATES THE
WAY IT SIMPLE THE IMPLICATION TO
ME IN THE WAY IT WAS PRESENTED
MADE IT SOUND THAT THAT THAT. IT
WOULD. PLAN NOT FOR PROFIT.
KAISER IS NOT FOR PROFIT THE
IDEA THAT THAT IT THAT IS THAT
THAT IS THE WAY IT THAT'S THE
WAY IT IS YOU MAKE YOU MAKE YOU
MAKE I SEE SHED SHAKING BUT THIS
THIS CURRENT STATUS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THEY ARE ALL NOT
FOR PROFIT YOU MAY OFFER. THEY
OPERATE. BY LAW THEY'RE ALL NOT
FOR PROFIT THEY ARE DIFFERENT
BUT THEY'RE NOT FOR PROFIT SO
ANYWAY I'D APPRECIATE A FACT
THAT YOU GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY
WHILE I GAVE MYSELF THE
OPPORTUNITY I CAN DO THAT BUT-
BUT I APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING OUT
OF ORDER I SHOULD HAVE BUT I
SHOULD SAID THAT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE UP ARM BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND WE'RE
LOOKING A MORE.
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE AND WALDRON.
WALDRON AGUIAR-CURRY. AGAR CURRY
II ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. HELLO NO CARILLO REAL
AYE FLORA OR NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES MAYES NOT
VOTING MCCARTY I MCCARTY I IN
THIS AREA. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
WE HAVE FIVE VOTES BELIEVE THE
BLUE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR AMBULANCE SOUTH
. SO- REMOVING A REALLY RAPID
PACE HERE FOLKS WILL BE MOVING
HOME TO OUR SPECIAL- OF BUSINESS
FOUR O'CLOCK- WHICH IS- I DON'T
WELL DONE- AB. TWENTY TO TWENTY
I REMEMBER WICKS. I BUT I DON'T
SEE-
THIS WEEK'S ARE YOU READY. OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE'RE BACK TO OUR NORMAL
PROCESS WITH TWO WITNESSES AT
THREE MINUTES EACH- WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY WITH WICKS. ARE YOU
THERE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK- AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL.
PREGNANCY COMMITTEE
CRIMINALIZATION IS A WIDESPREAD
NATIONAL PROBLEM THAT CALIFORNIA
IS PROTECT AGAINST THE PAST
DECADES LEAST THIRTY PREGNANT
HAVE BEEN. MISCARRIAGE
STILLBIRTH. OR CALIFORNIA'S ARE
EXEMPT FROM THIS DESPITE CLEAR
LAW THAT ENDING OR LOSING A
PREGNANCY IS NOT A CRIME
PROSECUTORS IN THE STATE HAVE
CHARGE PEOPLE WITH OFTEN. FOR
VERY READ FOR THE CASE OF CHILL
IN A DOOR PRESS TWO CALIFORNIA
WOMEN WHO WERE RECENTLY
PROSECUTED AND IMPRISONED FOR
THEIR STILLBIRTHS THE CHARGES
WRONG RECENTLY JUST. OR VACATED
AND ONLY AFTER THESE WOMEN WERE
BEHIND BARS SOME IN THE CASE OF
MONTHS FOR CHELSEA BECKER. AND A
DOOR PRIZE TO. FOR YEAR. THE LOS
TO ILLUSTRATE THE URGENT NEED TO
PROTECT AGAINST CRIMINALISATION
OF PREGNANCY OUTCOMES ANOTHER
EXAMPLE COMES TO MIND THIS IS
THE ONE THAT JUST HAPPENED LAST
WEEK. WAS UP. I'M ENDED UP
HAVING A PREGNANCY I LOST YOU TO
SELF MANAGED ABORTION AND SHE
WAS JAILED FOR DAYS HER PHOTO IN
OUR NAME AND OUR PRIVATE HEALTH
CARE AND HEALTH. INTERNET THE
CHARGES THEREFORE TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IN
DECISION MAKING AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT NO ONE FACES THE SAME TROUT
TELSEY. ENFORCE STATE PRACTICES
PROTECTIONS THIS BILL DOES THIS
BILL DOES SO BY SEPARATING
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES FROM THE
STATE SYSTEM THAT POLICE. AT
THAT END. THIS BILL DOES SO BY.
PAYMENTS YET I'M SORRY. THE
PLACE TO CRIMINALIZE HOWEVER
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS BILL THAT
HAS BEEN SPREAD BY THE
OPPOSITION. THE SAME GROUPS THAT
ARE AN ABORTION ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND IMPRISON PEOPLE FOR
STILLBIRTHS HAVE MANUFACTURED A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN USING
DISTURBING AND VIOLENT IMAGERY
THAT IS NOT GROUND CALL SCIENCE
. SIX OF THE- OPPOSITION GROUPS
HAVE MIS CHARACTERIZED TO THE
PORTION OF THE BILL THAT STOPS
THE GOVERNMENT FROM RE
TRAUMATIZING GRIEVING PARENTS
WHO LOSE A CHILD AFTER DELIVERY
THE RESULT OF SOMETHING HAPPENED
THE MESSY. THEREFORE ABOUT THIS
BILL THE BILL IS BEST TO I CAN
SEE AND PREGNANCY OUT AS RELATES
TO PERINATAL PROTECT TO EXT
DREAMILY PREGNANCY OUTCOMES. I
PRINCE. SINCE BUT AS THEY
MOURNED COMING NO PERSON SHOULD
HAVE TO ENDURE PRESS AS GRIEVED
LOSS THIS HAPPENS DURING THEIR
PREGNANCY AT THIS POINT BILL PER
. SHINS THE BOSTON YEAH WHEN
PREGNANT PEOPLE EXHIBIT SO OF
PREACH LABOR. THEY ARE
FREQUENTLY RECOMMENDED TO GO OUT
BRETT BED REST UNFORTUNATELY NOT
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THE PAID
SICK LEAVE WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS
OR SUPPORT TAKING HER. OWN
CHILDREN IN MY RECORD GO ON THE
BETTER. IF PRINCE. EXPERIENCED
PER DELIVERY RESULT IN A STILL
OF THE- PASSES A BY OF. THE
INCLUDE PERINATAL OUTCOME A
PRESS THAT SHOULD BE PART FROM
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT SURE THAT A
- CAN ARE. PURSUE GOING. SIX THE
PREGNANT DETHICK IN DELIVER. IT
IS IT. TWO TWENTY BUT NO ALL OF
PRESS FOR AN- WORKS PREGNANCY
LAW THIS WILL REMOVE OUT DID
PROVISIONS REQUIRING
INVESTIGATES PREGNANT LOSSES
WILL CLARIFY THAT THAT REPORT
PRIVATE ACT PER COMPLY. OF
PREGNANCY SOME YEP. IT PRIVATE
RIGHT TO FOR PEOPLE WHOSE RIGHT
HAVE BEEN BY A- I WANT TO OUR
SPONSORS THE STILL OF ACTION
LIKE FOR THE PROJECT. CALIFORNIA
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IF ONE
HAD LAUREN WEARING REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE NAY RAW AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF HEALTH
AND- YES. ABOUT SALINAS. DOCTOR
SERRA. THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT TESTIMONY TODAY MY
NAME IS DR SALINAS ANIMAL AND A
BOARD CERTIFIED OBGYN MATHIS
THIS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA AND
FUTURE OF ABORTION COUNSEL. HERE
TO. MY A. B. WHICH SIX TENS THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT CRIMINALIZED FOR
THE PREGNANCY OUTCOMES AS OF ANY
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE I CAN
ATTEST THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM DOES NOT BELONG IN HEALTH
CARE. THE STATE'S RAISING A
DRASTIC RIGHT THE LEGISLATION
TARGETING THOSE WHO GET
PREGNANT. WITH THE GOAL OF
CONTROLLING THEIR BODIES. YOU
CAN BRING THE REPRODUCTIVE
CHOICES. ON THE NATIONAL STAGE
JUST EARLIER THIS MONTH A WOMAN
IN TEXAS WAS ARRESTED FOR MURDER
AND PLACED IN CUSTODY ON HALF A
MILLION BOND. AFTER SHE DID WE
DISCLOSED A HOT. INFORMATION
BLOOD TO THE THAT SHE ITSELF
MANSION ABORTION. THE CHARGES
WERE ULTIMATELY DROPPED THE ONLY
AFTER A MASSIVE PUBLIC OUTRAGE
AFTER HER MEDICAL PRIVACY.
COMPLETE INVADED BY HER MOTHER
BEING SPENT INTO. TALKING IT
SAYS EXCLUSIVE. STATES IN FACT.
YEAH AND HOUSING HELLO. AS
MENTIONED TO MANY RECENTLY
CHELSEA BACKGROUND OR PRESS WERE
PROSECUTED IMPRISONED FOR
STILLBIRTHS. WE KNOW THAT THOSE
WHO FACE CRIMINALIZATION FOR THE
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BLACK INDIGENOUS OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR IMMIGRANTS LGBTQ PEOPLE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THOSE WITH LOW
INCOME. SHE BELIEVES VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE PEOPLE. BY
THEIR OWN HOSPITAL STAFF FOR THE
- THEN NEVER POST WORLD WILL
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
PEOPLE WHO. CAN GET PREGNANT
WELL FEAR SHARING POTENTIALLY
LIFESAVING INFORMATION WITH
THEIR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS DUE
TO CONCERN FOR ARREST. WE KNOW
THAT PERINATAL. FOR EVERY
PATIENT JUST AS PART IN SEEN
OTHER CORRECTIVE HEALTHCARE
NEEDS WILL DIFFER FOR A OCCASION
. LOCAL KEEPING ALWAYS POINT
WHAT IF ANYTHING UP TO SPECIFIC
LOSS IF THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
CANNOT IDENTIFY THE REASONS FOR
PERINATAL LOSS WHY WOULD WE
EXPECT JUSTICE SYSTEM AND-
PRESIDENT. EDUCATION ABORTION
TAKE ORALLY ARE IDENTICAL TO
THAT OF SPONTANEOUS PREGNANCY
LOSS AND THERE IS NO TESTS TO
DETERMINE THE DIFFERENCE. WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
EARLY PREGNANCY LOSS ARE
HONORABLE TO INTRUSIVE
INVESTIGATIONS AND WRONGFUL
PERSECUTION. WE NOT ALLOWED
BURDEN TO FALTER PATIENTS PEOPLE
WHO EXPERIENCED PREGNANCY LOSS
ARE OFTEN EXPERIENCING PAIN
DISBELIEF AND GRIEF. AND WITHIN
THIS EMOTIONAL TOLL NOW THEY'RE
FORCED TO FEED PERSECUTION
PROSECUTION AND DISTRUST THAT
HAVE TAKEN OATH TO CARE FOR
THEM. THIS IS CRUEL JUST FROM.
FOCUSED ON GETTING BETTER. EIGHT
BE THEM AND SUPPORT. THEY CAN
NOT ASSOCIATION THE COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
AND THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSOCIATION ALL OPPOSE
CRIMINALISATION OF PREGNANCY
LOSS. INVESTIGATION OR
PROSECUTION APARTMENTS THE OPS
HARMS PEOPLE'S HEALTH LIVELIHOOD
AND ABILITY TO CARE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES WE MUST MAKE CLEAR THAT
PEOPLE CAN BECOME CALIFORNIA BE
SAFE AND THEREFORE. REASONS I
AND I'VE AB TWENTY TWO THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE NEXT
WITNESS PLACE. AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DOCTOR SERRA
ROBERT HAVE A DOCTORATE IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M A
PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY ACTIVE
INCIDENT. RECEIVE CALIFORNIA
SEPT. IF HE THE IMPACTS. OF
ABORTION POLICIES AND POLICIES
RELATED TO PREGNANT PEOPLE TO
USE OF ALCOHOL AND DRUGS AND A
PUBLISHED MORE THAN NINETY PEER
REVIEWED. AND IT PUBLISHED
NINETY PEER REVIEWED ARTICLES
ABOUT THESE TOPICS. PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY SHOULD BE GUIDED
BY PUBLIC HEALTH VALUES AND
INFORMED BY THE BEST EVIDENCE.
FORMALISING PREGNANCY OUTCOMES
IS COUNTER TO BOTH PUBLIC HEALTH
VALUES AND EXISTING EVIDENCE.
FROM A VALUE PERSPECTIVE
CRIMINALIZING A PROSECUTING
PEOPLE FOR THEIR PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES CLEARLY VIOLATES CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH VALUES OF AUTONOMY
PRIVACY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE. THE
EVIDENCE IS CLEAR GOVERNMENT
INTERROGATIONS AND PROSECUTIONS
OF PEOPLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
DURING PREGNANCY OR FOR THEIR
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES HARMS RATHER
THAN HELPS HEALTH. I WANT TO
TELL YOU ABOUT RESEARCH AT THIS
TOPIC OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES
. BEGINNING IN THE MID THOUSANDS
OF OTHER PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT INTERVIEWED PREGNANT AND
POSTPARTUM WOMEN HERE'S ALCOHOL
AND DRUGS ABOUT BARRIERS TO
PRENATAL CARE. MY RESEARCH FOUND
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA LAW
PROVIDES THAT A POSITIVE
TOXICOLOGY TEST. IS INSUFFICIENT
TO ESTABLISH TODD APPEARS FROM
THE CRACKED. FEAR OF JAIL FOR
FEAR OF HAVING THEIR CHILD
REMOVED I'M- RIGHT AS LEAVES AT
PEOPLE TO PHYSICALLY AVOID AN
EMOTIONALLY DISENGAGE FROM
PRENATAL CARE. AS ONE PART IN
SAID I DIDN'T GO WELL I WAS
USING BECAUSE I WAS AFRAID THAT
IF THEY HAD KNOWN CPS WOULD HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN SOCIAL SERVICES
WOULD HAVE TO. MY BABY. ANOTHER
SAID THAT. THAT WHOLE NINE
MONTHS YOU'RE LIKE I CANNOT GO
TO THIS DOCTOR BECAUSE IF I DO
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE MY KID- PUT
ME IN JAIL FOR THE REST OF MY
NINE MONTHS JUST AB ONE I
DELIVER. FEARS ARE WARRANTED
GIVEN HOW OFTEN HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS SUPPORT BIRTHING
PEOPLE. USE ALCOHOL AND DRUGS TO
GOVERNMENT AUTHORITIES. HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS REPORT ABOUT 1%
OF ALL NEWBORNS TO CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES THIS
REPORTING IS DEEPLY INEQUITABLE.
MY RESEARCH SHOWS LIKE OTHER
WAYS IN WHICH PREGNANCY IS
CRIMINALIZED BLACK WOMEN ARE
FORTY FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY
THAN WHITE WOMEN TO BE REPORTED
TO IN A IS. THE TO THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE DURING THE PRIDE.
SO THE SCALP THIRTY SIX OF BEERS
AT THE STATE LEVEL PREGNANCY
SPECIFIC ALCALA DRUG POLICIES.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT STIGMATIZE
AND THREATEN PUNISHMENT. WE
FOUND THAT THESE POLICIES
CONTRIBUTE THOUSANDS OF BABIES
BORN LOW BIRTH WEIGHT OR PRETERM
EACH YEAR HOUSING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EACH YEAR. IF IT WERE
SIMPLY AND STIGMATIZING POLICIES
HARM RATHER THAN HELP THE HEALTH
OF PREGNANT PEOPLE AND A BABY.
PUBLIC HEALTH VALUES THAT
LIMITING THE THREAT OF STATE
RETALIATION FOR BEHAVIOR DURING
PREGNANCY IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. BASED ON EXISTING IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION. YES MY ESPECIALLY
JACK HIBBS COVER TRAVEL CHANNEL
HILLS AND THANKFULLY REPRESENTED
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE THIS
MORNING THAT ROUTE ON THE
CAPITOL STEPS. AND MY PASSION IS
MORE ONE EXPERIENCE I'M A
SURVIVOR OF AN ABORTION DECEMBER
TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. GLAD TO BE HERE BUT IN
LIGHT OF ALL THAT'S WHAT I TO
DRAW YOUR TO MAKE APPEAL TO OF.
YOU ARE NOT DO. ANY WHAT WAS.
THANK TO RESORT NOBODY LIFE FOR
TALKING TO. THE OF BLOOD THAT IF
IT'S PAST THAT THE PERINATAL
MEANING THAT YOU CAN BE DEFINED
BUT THE END IS VERY TONIGHT IS
THAT ALL READ. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN A- LAZY. BECAUSE NOBODY
CAN INVESTIGATE IF YOU READ THAT
NOBODY CAN DETERMINE HOW THIS
CHILD DIED IT WAS MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO THAT A WOMAN COULD BE
THE BEST OR- YOU AFTER PRAYER.
AND DURING THAT TIME THE CHILD
IS. DEAD WHY WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHY IT'S NOT THE PROSECUTOR TO
BRING ANYTHING AGAINST ANYONE
THE- UP. WHAT MY ARGUMENT IS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT WE ARE
GOING DOWN A ROAD THAT IS NOT
ONLY ONE THAT COULD BE CRIMINAL
PERSONALLY I WITH MY HIGH VIEW
OF LIFE ITSELF. THAT THE- IN
THIS SUPPORT. HELLO LEGALIZES
THE TERM OF A BORN CHILD A CHILD
THAT IS NOW BEYOND THAT'S THE
AGE OF DEBATE GOOD LIFE OR IS IT
A BLOG OR WHATEVER. THIS IS A
LIVE BREATHING CHIU. AND WE
THESE THINGS FOR US AS A CO BUT
WE'RE DOWN A PATH THAT IS
DANGEROUS AND THAT IS AN AFFRONT
ANY TODAY'S AT THE CAP STEPS
SOMETHING ALL OF YOU I YOU TO
NOTE OF AND I UNDERSTAND. S. B.
HE IN THIS ALMOST. I UNDERSTAND
IT'S TIME FOR HIM TO RETIRED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS PRO IT
AWAY NO. BECAUSE THIS IS A HILL
FOR MORE PEOPLE TO DIE ON THE
NOT LEAVE YOU WITH THIS THE
BIBLE SAYS IN PROVERBS THIRTY
ONE DEFENDER. OF NOVARTIS AND
THOSE ARE DESTINED TO BE CRUSHED
THAT'S A THREE THOUSAND YEAR OLD
OVER SOUNDS. WRITTEN MR DAY AND
I ASKED YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
RATHER THAN BRING SOMETHING OF.
WHAT PANO CONT BUT- IT'S NOT A
CONSCIENCE I'M CA ABOUT IT'S
THAT CHILD THAT SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT TO LIVE AND ALL OF YOU ARE%
GOING TO HAVE THAT ON YOU AND
ACTIVISTS WE- YOU. ALL TO LIVE.
TO LIVE TO FEND I'M HAPPY
HAPPIEST IN HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO
BE A AND TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU
TODAY URGE YOU TO PLEASE S. B.
THE CITIZENS CO. TO OPPOSE AB
TWO THREE. THANK YOU THIS WOULD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
VANCE AND HUANG I'M AN OBGYN
PHYSICIAN I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR THIRTY
ONE YEARS WHEN I FIRST READ
ABOUT THIS BILL AYE INDEED-
THOUGHT THAT IS ABOUT- PREVENT
SECURE BEEN PREGNANT AND WHO
SUFFER IN A.
A CLEAR AND GRUESOME INTENT CAN
BE- GLEANED FROM THIS IT'S NOT
THE INTENTION THAT WERE ARGUING
WITH. IT IS IT'S SAID IN A BILL
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC AND THE
PHRASE. NATAL DEATH DUE TO A I
CAN SEE RELATED BECAUSE SHOULD
NOT BE INVESTIGATED. IS
PROBLEMATIC FIRST OF ALL AS
STATED CLEARLY IN THE BILL AND I
THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT MOST
PARANASAL DEATHS. ARE HAVE
REALLY NO IDEOLOGY YES THERE CAN
I'M EXPLANATION FOR IT BUT THE
MOST THE MAJORITY OF THESE
PAINFUL DEATHS THEREFORE-
UNDERTONE AND HOW CAN YOU
CLASSIFY IT AS SUCH. THE SECOND
PROBLEM IS THAT MOST. OBVIOUS
PREGNANCY RELATED ISSUE IS THAT
THERE IS A BABY SO IF I'M NOT A
LEGAL SCHOLAR BUT IF IT SAYS
IT'S A PERINATAL DEATH DUE TO A
PREGNANCY RELATED BECAUSE- LET'S
STATE. A OUR GENTLEMAN AND GETS
- HIS PARTNER PREGNANT HE'S
UNHAPPY THAT SHE IS PREGNANT AND
THE CLOSETS- HURT TO LOSE A
PREGNANCY THROUGH AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE THERE'S A PLACENTAL
ABRUPTION. TO CLAIM ON THE NET
HEY YOU GUYS CAN'T PROSECUTE ME
THIS WAS A- PREGNANCY RELATED
COSTS THAT LED ME TO THIS ACTION
BECAUSE AFTER ALL. WHAT HAPPENED
WAS RELATED TO PREGNANCY. AND
IT'S REALLY NOT. THANK YOU I'M
SURE YOU'RE THINKING THAT THE
CONCERNS OF INFANTICIDE ARE
PARANOID RIDICULOUS HOWEVER THE
MORAL ACCEPTANCE OF KILLING
BABIES IS GAINING POPULARITY
PROMOTED MOST RECENTLY BY PASTOR
PETER. NEVER INDEED COURT IN ANY
TO BE STRICTLY LEGALLY
CONTROLLED AND RARE BUT IT
SHOULD NOT BE RULED OUT AND MORE
THE BOARD. THE AMBIGUITY OF THE
BILL IS CLEAR HOWEVER A CLOSE
INSPECTION OF THIS BILL DOES
ALLOW FOR THE LEGALIZING OF
KILLING OF INNOCENT NEWBORN
CHILDREN UP TO THE JOB TWENTY
EIGHT TO. YES VOTE AND I CALLED
AND TO. THE LEGAL UPSKILL
NEWBORN BABY AND WITH ALL MY
HEART I OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE AND URGE YOU TO VOTE NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THE TWO
OF WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM YOU'LL BE ABLE LAST COME UP
IN. YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON.
IN A POSITION TO REPERTOIRE AND
THAT IS ALL THE TESTIMONY.
NOTHING ELSE NOTHING NOTHING
OTHER THAN THAT. BURKE NUMBER
WITH WE WILL BE DOING THAT THIS
TESTIMONY WILL WILL ENCOMPASS A
TOTAL SIXTY MINUTES TOTAL. A
BLENDED YOU YOU MAY LEAVE WHAT
ACTUALLY STATEMENT WE MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS. ONCE AGAIN YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT AND
NOTHING MORE. ALLISON MARTINEZ
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF PREGNANCY
CARE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU PERFECT. STEPHEN
BREEDLOVE FROM PLASTIC COUNTY
REPRESENTING PEOPLE CONVOYS
TODAY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. KATHLEEN JONES
pDINO PREGNANCY AND FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO THREE
THANK YOU. HE SAID OUR CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS
REPRESENTING LEX SAID AND SOUND
CAN COUNTY LIBERTY COALITION
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
TARA MARTIN CO FOUNDER FREEDOM
ANGELS REPRESENTING MY MIRACLE
CHILD AND ALL CHILDREN STRONGLY
OPPOSE SYSTEM IF. V. LU AGUILAR
PLASTER COUNTY I AM A PRODUCT OF
PREGNANCY AND I AM HERE
REPRESENTING THOSE THAT CANNOT
THEMSELVES. THANK YEAH. MY NAME
IS THE PASTOR ELIZABETH RING GAL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TO
THREE- I DON'T SPEAK FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE NO VOICE. MEDINA
SEMINAL COUNTY PEOPLE'S CONVOYS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MICHELLE. DIENER I'M
HERE WITH THE PEOPLE'S CONVOY I
ALSO AM AFFILIATED WITH THE
CREATOR OF EACH OF OUR LIVES AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE STUFF.
CARE ABIGAIL TINA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. RACHEL GATES
ORANGE COUNTY I'M WITH THE
PEOPLE'S CONVOY THE FREEDOM
ANGELS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EGREGIOUS SPELL THANK YOU. I NAY
BREEDLOVE PLASTER COUNTY.
UNWANTED CHILD BECAUSE OF
DEFORMITIES EXTREMELY LOVED
EXTREMELY BLESSED TO BE ALIVE.
SURE NAME POSITION ON THE BILL
AN ORGANIZATION CANNY FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
THE BAND HAMMERLOCK AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. SHE
I'M OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MANY MINUTES FROM CASTRO
VALLEY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND KILLED A MONOLOGUE
THANK YOU. THERE ARE CONRAD FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CLICKER FROM FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SOON YOU
BATES WITH THE SAMBAR TO DINO
PREGNANCY AND FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. CINDY
HILLARY CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SHARON KAY KERRY SAMBAR DINO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY SO.
OPPOSE THIS BILL EXCUSE ME THANK
YOU. BEVERLY BECKLEY THE SALMON
IN A PREGNANCY AND FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT. ANDREA RIVERA FROM
SAMPOERNA DINO PREGNANCY FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M
PAMELA MY DATA FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI I'M LISA
DESSE BRO OF INFORMED PARENTS OF
CONTRA COSTA AND CALVARY CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS ONLINE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. I'MRHONDA GARRIDO FROM
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL GIVE.
KYLE HACKENBERG IN FULLERTON
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IF. HELLO MY NAME IS
JONNA HACKENBERG I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN. A FORMER BABY I'M A
CHILD OF GOD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SO THE ARRIVAL I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT LEXI AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IS PURE EVIL.
THANK YOU. WHEN IS PLAGUE SOULS
I'M FROM YUCAIPA CALIFORNIA AND
I REPRESENT THE VOICES THAT
CAN'T BE HEARD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. YES I'M FROM
THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
THAT'S CORRECT GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KENNETH PRADAL I'M A
BELIEVER MY LOTUS SAVIOR JESUS
CHRIST I AM A FATHER A MOTHER A
PATRIOT. NAY NONE. I'M SORRY IS
REALLY HEAVY ON MY HEART Q. AND-
YOUR POSITION REPRESENTS A LEXUS
AND I OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU YOUR JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION AND ANY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS HI MY NAME'S
DANIELLA. LOSCO DAUGHTER OF THE
KING. A MOTHER. AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE BURTON
I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'M A
MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. YOU
HI MY NAME IS JOY THE LILACS I'M
A MOTHER FOR THE GRACE OF GOD.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO
TWO THREE. IF I'M JIM SHOEMAKER
I'M A CANDIDATE FOR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT NINE IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND ON THE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN
ASSEMBLY. CONSENT WORKING COUNTY
AND WE STRONGLY. THIS BILL IS
NOBODY THANK LIAM JESUS CHRIST
YOU DON'T SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
NAME IS KRISTEN TURNER I'M A
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PRO
LIFE SAN FRANCISCO I'M AN
ATHEIST AND A LEFTIST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT AB TWO. TWO
THREE. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
LEAH CALLIN OWSKI ON THE
REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR
STUDENTS FOR A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
NEVADA AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO
TURMAN SENATE COMMITTEE ON MY
NAME IS ROBERT BYRD I AM AN
ORGANIZER WITH PROLETARIAN CISCO
AND I URGE YOU TO PUT THE BRAKES
ON THIS POORLY WRITTEN BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
RON BRISE C. OF CALVARY CHAPEL
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JUDY BIRDS THEY
SEE I'M A MEMBER OF CALVARY
CHAPEL OF SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR THE USE AND
CARINATA Q. MY NAME IS CLEAR
GROWTH ALTHOUGH AND A FOLLOWER
OF JESUS CHRIST AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SB TWO TWO TWO. Q. HELLO
I'M OSCAR SORIANO FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
DAVID READY FROM THE BAY AREA
AND I STRONGLY DISAGREE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. HI I AM CINDY SANDBURG
COACH I'M A GRANDMOTHER A
MOTHER. A GRANDMOTHER I HAVE
TWENTY NINE KIDS GRANDKIDS AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE KILLING AND MURDER SHOP A
PLACE YOU YOU'RE WELCOME. HELLO
I'M DOLLY LAB PERSON I'M
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE FOR
DISTRICT NINETEEN AND ICE ON
GLEE OPPOSE THIS. HELLO MY NAME
IS AMANDA I AM FROM CALVARY
CHAPEL SOUTH OC FROM SALT AND
LIGHT I AM A PREGNANCY OUTCOME
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. THANK YOU. INCONTRI
PLASTER COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL Q. HI MY NAME
IS MICHAEL- I GO TO- CALVARY
CHAPEL IN SAN JOSE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. I'M DONNA CULLEN FROM
SALINAS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. TWO TWO TWO
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KAREN RASPBERRY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CARE THAT
WOMEN'S RESOURCE CENTER OF NORTH
COUNTY LOS ANGELES AND FROM
PALMDALE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THAT DOES NOT PROTECT
ANY CHILDREN THANK YOU. HI I'M
DONNA TEARS I'M FORMALLY FROM
JACK'S CHURCH- BUT I LIVE IN THE
NATION NOW AND- I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI
I'M SUE ALL VERA AND I AM FROM
BENICIA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI AM KRISTY WALLACE AND I
LIVE IN SALON OKAY HE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BROADCASTING HERE TO THANK YOU.
HI I'M CLAUDIA STUDENTS FROM LOS
ALAMITOS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
THINK. JOHN MATTERS FROM
CHRISTIAN LIFE ASSEMBLY
LANCASTER ON THE PASTOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. GRANDFATHER SEVENTEEN TEN
MEN'S MINISTRY LEADER AT THE
LOCAL CHURCH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED. A TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. COULD HOUSING
OR BUSINESS OWNER IN DISTRICT
THIRTY FOR ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY FOUR I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARCELLA CLARK I'M A
PROUD AMERICAN I'M A PROUD.
SUPPORTER OF PRO LIFE. THANK YOU
I URGE YOU. TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINAMARTINEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO TWO
TWO THREE YOUR. MY NAME IS ERICA
RAINY I AM A PART OF A CALVET
CHAPEL CHINO HILLS ARE
COMPARABLE HAMPER. CAL HEALTH
CARE AND I STRUCK. OPPOSE THIS
BILL YEAH. HELLO MY NAME IS
KELLY HANES FROM L. A. COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IF.
HELLO MY NAME IS GINNY RIPLEY I
DROVE UP FROM RIVERSIDE IN ORDER
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS BILL
GAGNANT CRITICS TOOK SIXTY IN
CORONA I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL IF. GOOD AFTERNOON AYE
MINISTER MERLINO MASCOT FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
MEMBER FROM VOICE OF THE
VOICELESS AND I OPPOSE BILL TWO
TO THREE. THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
PRETTY RETURN RETIRED I'M FROM
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY. KILL THE
BILL BACK TO BE HERE I THANK YOU
YOU JUST YOU. HELLO I'M JENNIFER
MILBORNE I WORK FOR ABORTION
SURVIVORS NETWORK I SURVIVED MY
BIRTH MOM SOME PORTION ATTEMPT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOUR. GLORIA FLOREZ TWELVE YOU
COUNTY WERE LIFE FELLOWSHIP
ABOUT HER GRANDMOTHER AND POST
AB. TWO TO THREE. MY NAME IS
MARYLAND BLANTON I AM A
GRANDMOTHER. AND A GREAT
GRANDMOTHER I'M FROM AMADOR
COUNTY DRY TAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. TWO TWO TWO THREE
IF. HELLO MY NAME IS HEATHER
PARRY FROM CHINO CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. IF HELLO MY NAME IS SERRA
CAME REPRESENTING TV NEXT ON A
FOUNDER AND A CO PRESIDENT TV
NEXT REPRESENTING OVER THREE
THOUSANDS OF KOREAN AMERICAN
CHURCHES STRONGLY OPPOSING AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS EMERALD
MONZA I TEND LIFESONG CHURCH IN
STOCK CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AB. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
TO TWENTY THREE THANK YOU BRO
CAPITAL. HELLO MY NAME STAYS
HUMAN FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
IS STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE IF. MY NAME'S
MARLENA REFRAIN I'M FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
DIANE DUTTON AND I'M FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AT THE MOMENT
CALIFORNIANS OPPOSING AB TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JANELLE GLOMMA
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS SHEILA CATHOLIC CHECK
AND I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY I
HAVE THREE SONS. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. KELLY GEISLER FROM CAMBRIA
CALIFORNIA SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AGAINST YOUR BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS TERRA
TENCENT A BLACK WOMAN IN
AMERICA- WHO RESIDES IN ALBIA
CALIFORNIA OPPOSING AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. IF HI THIS IS HARSH
RESTAURANT OF HIM L. A. COUNTY
I'M A CHILD OF GOD AND I PRAY I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE OPPOSE AB TWO
TO TWENTY THREE. HEY KATHY
MCBRIDE PASS ACCOUNT THERE ARE
THREE. STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE PLEASE DON'T KNOW
. HI ALICIA HERNANDEZ PLASTER
COUNTY I AM A NURSE OF THIRTY
YEARS VACCINE INJURED CHILD.
PRESENTED JESUS CHRIST AND I
OPPOSE BILL TWO TWO TWO THREE
GIVE. HELLO MY NAME'S KEITH
HANNAH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO LLOYD HANNAH
PROUD MOM OF KEITH TANNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE PLEASE VOTE NO. I AM
SADDAM ACQUIRING FROM SEAL BEACH
I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE AND I GO TO CHURCH-
COUNTY CHAPTER. OKAY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY GRAVES AND I
AM REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
QINGDAO FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ
SOMEONE UP TO YOUR OFFICE BUT
YOU WEREN'T THERE PLEASE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. HI MY NAME'S CINDY
CINDY NO FIRM I'M FROM FILLED
STRETCH POMONA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND MY TENURE
FOR MISCARRIAGE USUALLY FUND.
THANK DIVERSIONS THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS BARBARA CONWAY FROM.
I STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
JAMIE HOW AND I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE I WORK IN A PERI NATAL
CLINIC AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU. I'M
TRYING TO MAKE MAN I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT Q. THANK. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARGARET GRASSLEY FROM
NEWBERRY SPRINGS SARAH SAMBAR
DINO COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THE AB TWO TO
THREE AND BEG YOU TO OPPOSE IT
IS. HI MY NAME IS GABE BIRCH
FROM THE MOJAVE DESERT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS DANIEL KLEIN YOU
PLASTER COUNTY RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
HAVE NEW GRANDSON IF. MY NAME IS
GREG ABBOTT OCEAN THE FOUNDER OF
NOW ALSO TURN COVERAGE
OPPORTUNITY HILLS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. HI MY NAME
IS GABBY REYES AKP AIRLESS MAMA
AND I ATTEND CALVARY CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS AND I REALLY REALLY
STRONGLY OPPOSES EVIL BILL THANK
YOU YOUR- HI MANY. BILLS BACK IN
AYE OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME'S
JENNIFER'S CLUB KONAMI'S
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA. CALVARY
CHAPEL CHINO ILLS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS RITA BARBER I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO AND I ALSO
ATTEND CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
FOR LOPEZ FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS SUSAN GARCIA WE ATTEND
CALVARY CHAPEL- PLEASE OPPOSE
THIS BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IF. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
SINGLETON I AM FROM SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA AND I TOOK TIME OFF
FROM WORK TODAY TO FLY UP HERE
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI MY NAME
IS DANNY BACK FROM BELLFLOWER
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. I
REPRESENT THE INNOCENT THAT
CANNOT SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARGARET CHO
AND I REPRESENT THE YOUNGER
DINNER GENERATION. AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS ABIGAIL DISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IF YOU
. HELLO MY NAME IS I'M ENGLISH
GRANDFATHER FOR I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME'S LIAM WHO'S GONNA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL DUGGAN AND I'M A
FATHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL IF. HELLO ANNA
CARPENTER FROM SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO NATALIE'S TO PRAGUE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL
THANK YOU GIVE. HELLO I'M
CRISTINA DUGGAN FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IF YOU. HI MY NAME IS LENA
DUNCAN FROM SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. I AM COUNTY LANZA SARA FROM
MY MOTHER'S WOMB AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS MURDEROUS OROVILLE.
MY NAME IS PAM BATTAGLIA
REGISTERED NURSE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL SKEWS ME. HI MY
NAME IS KRISTA ORANGE COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOUR-
HI I'M MICHELE CHRISTIANSEN
STANISLAUS COUNTY RETIRED
PEDIATRIC NURSE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU. RUSS
CHRISTIANSEN FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THIS CAROL LAM FROM THE
COUNTY OF SAN MATEO I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS TO BE A LONG I'M
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY S. DON'T
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. M.
IS MISSION ALLOWS GOAL FONG
ALAMEDA COUNTY I STRONGLY PLEASE
VOTE NOTE THANK YOU. HI I AM
STEPHANIE LAMB FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY NOT TOO FAR AWAY FROM
OAKLAND BUT ASK YOU PLEASE STOP
THIS BILL HERE. IF HENRY LAMB
FROM FREMONT- PIECE NO THANK YOU
IF. I'M LANCE KANAK FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE IF. MY NAME IS
BRITNEY STEVE ARE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I'M A REGISTERED NURSE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON JASON SQUIRE
OF CHILD HERE FROM WESTMINSTER
CALIFORNIA TO OPPOSE. THIS AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
THANK YOU. EIGHTY FOUR YEAR OLD
GREAT GRANDFATHER BUILT TWENTY
FROM COSTA MESA AND I OPPOSE.
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS ERIC HIM
WHERE I'M A FIREFIGHTER AND A
PARAMEDIC AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. YOUR I WAS AT THE
OUTCOME OF THE PREGNANCY AND I
HAVE TO FORMER FETUSES ASSIGNS
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. YOUR MY NAME
IS VICTORIA CHAVEZ FROM GARDEN
GROVE CALIFORNIA AND I'M GOING
TO BE A FUTURE LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIAN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. IF CHERYL
CHAVEZ AND I AM A FORMER FETUS
AND I REPRESENT THE GARDEN GROVE
REPUBLICAN WOMEN'S FEDERATED AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IF.
MY NAME IS DUKE THOMAS I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOUR- I AM JEFF
THOMAS AND- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
I'M FROM MONEY TO BEACH THANK
YOU. JOE PEDICAB FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. HELLO MY
NAME IS SYLVIA BRUNSON I AM A
VOTER AND A THANKFUL PRODUCT OF
AN UNPLANNED PREGNANCY I'M AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. IF HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE
TAPLIN IN ON THE VOICE FOR THE
FOR VOICELESS WITH LOVE LIFE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. STRONGLY. MY
NAME IS MANDY CURRENTS I AM ALSO
A VOICE FOR THE VOICELESS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOUR.
ANGELES MARTINEZ FROM INLAND
EMPIRE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CHÁVEZ I AM A MOTHER I
REPRESENT ALLIES TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND LOVE LIFE I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. IRA LOPEZ
LICENSE CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
HIGH DESERT AND I STRONGLY-
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME'S LINDA THE LAWS FROM
BARSTOW CALIFORNIA AND I'M WITH
THE LOVE LIFE AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS LARRY
TABLETS HI DESERT COVERAGE UP
ALL HIGH DESERT LOVE LIFE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
. HELLO MY NAME IS MATTHEW LAKE
I REPRESENT LOVE LIFE
VICTORVILLE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. HI MY NAME
IS INEZ KENNEDY. N. AND THE
PATRIOT I'M A GRANDMOTHER. AND I
AM A SERVANT OF THE MOST HIGH
GOD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
TWO TWO. THREE HI MY NAME'S TONY
KENNEDY FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL TWO TO
THREE THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SARAH VICTORIA PETTUS
I REPRESENT A RIGHT TO LIFE OF
FRESNO. I AM A FIRST GENERATION
AND THE- I HAVE FOUR CHILDREN
AND TEN GRANDCHILDREN GOD BLESS
AMERICA. THANK YOU. MY NAME'S
JULIE THURSTON I REPRESENT RIGHT
TO LIFE IN THE FRESNO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. WHEN
IS FOR NAGALAND IS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS TERRY MELINDA'S AND I'M
REPRESENTING AFRICAN AMERICAN
SOCIAL WORKERS AND LATINO SOCIAL
WORKERS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MARY MAINLY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME'S DON SMESKO AND I'M
HERE WITH CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO
HILLS FROM SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. STACEY SHOPPER I'M
HERE WITH CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
LAUREN MILLER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ERNEST MILLER FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI AMRIT SAYS
SIMPSON FROM DISTRICTS SEVENTY
FIVE NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND
I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I'M COLLEEN MUNRO
FROM VISTA CALIFORNIA TERRORIZE
CHURCH MOTHER THREE GRAND MOTHER
OF EIGHT A SURVIVOR OF ATTEMPTED
ABORTION IN NINE ONE NINETEEN
SIXTY. YOUR. HELLO I'M JAY
BRADLEY FROM ESCONDIDO
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER C. E. O. OF
EVA MASTANDIEGO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU. ROB
BRADLEY FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. JOHN GIRARDI ON BEHALF OF
RIGHT TO LIFE OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA OF WHOM I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL ABOUT FOR THOUSANDS OF
SUPPORTERS FRESNO MADERA COUNTY.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS SUIT
JACKSON I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD OF TULARE KINGS RIGHT
TO LIFE. AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS JULIE HUCKABAY I AM PART
OF THIS GROUP. AND I'M FROM
KINGSBURG CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS EMORY HOW
NUMB FROM BY SALLY CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I KNEW JANET PETERS
FROM KING'S BERGENHUS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARGIE LOPEZ I'M FROM HANFORD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
PATRICIA HE BIRD I'M FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT THIRTY ONE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS SEAN
OR DINE I'M FROM FRESNO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI I'M SURE BRAD SHAW
FRESNO COUNTY RIGHT TO LIFE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
STOP IT YOU. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
PETERSON I'M FROM FRESNO AND I'M
A 100% AGAINST THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME INTENT-
WILLIAM TIME FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT BABY MADE
IN GOD'S IMAGE AND CAMP I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. VIRGINIA
VISOR FROM- CENTRAL VALLEY RIGHT
TO LIFE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS STUBBORN
ATKINS I REPRESENT LOVE LIFE
SOUTH CENTRAL LIGHTING AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN
TOOK SPENT TIME- COMPUTER-
INSTRUCTOR IN BUSINESS TEACHER
AT FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
FROM PLACENTA CALIFORNIA APART
OF LOVE LIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI%
THERE MARIA GENOVESE APLIN LIVE
LIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
DENISE PALMER CALVARY CHAPEL
CHINO HILLS LOVE LIFE UP PLAN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE GRIFFIN I'M FROM
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS MERRY
HUMANISM BY SALLY CALIFORNIA
RIGHT TO LIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. SO
WE ARE AB A FROMBY CELLULAR
CALIFORNIA WITH RIGHT TO LIFE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M A
GRANDMOTHER TEACHER AND MY NAME
IS STEVE SOKOLOWSKI I'M FROM
LAMAR CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LESLIE VANINI STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU. NANCY CAPILLARY
FRESNO COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND BASH ALONG FRESNO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME'S CHRIS CALVERT AND I'D SAY
PLEASE PLEASE. OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TECHNI CALGARY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. THE
RAID FLEISCHMAN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOANNA RON HO FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. JOSE DARON HALL I'M
HERE BECAUSE MY MOTHER CHOSE NOT
TO ABORT ME AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN. I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I JUST WANNA KNOW
WE'VE HIT THE THIRTY MINUTE MY
NAME S ERICA SKI BAR FROM SAN
BENITO COUNTY WHICH HELPS YOU
KNOW HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IF YOU'RE DECIDING
THAT WE MET THE THIRTY MINUTE
MARK ABOUT THIRTY MORE MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY AND THEN WE WILL
THE TESTIMONY. HI MY- FROM CHINO
CALIFORNIA COVERAGE OF LATINO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY NAME IS
IT'S ALREADY. I'M BROWN SIZE SIX
CALL I POSTED AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU. MY NAME'S MAJOR
FROM SEVEN CISCO STRONGLY OPPOSE
A. B. B. O. L. A. B. TO TWO TO
THREE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS TO
REST THE PASCALI FROM COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO TO. THREE THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS MAKERS HERE FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA HAS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. MY NAME IS
ADRIANA FROM SALIVA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
MERRY HOUSE FROM NEWMAN
CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
GRANDMOTHER OF EIGHT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS DEL ELSE I'M
FROM NEW IN CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS PRISCILLA ATTY
RTM FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO AND I ADAMANTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JASMINE ATTY RT I AM A
DAUGHTER AND A FUTURE MOTHER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS THERESA
CUMMINGS I'M A MOTHER I'M IN OUR
IN I'M FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY
AND I ABSOLUTELY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. HELLO I'M ANGELA
ALANIS A MOTHER A REGISTERED
NURSE FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KRISTI HARRINGTON FROM GILROY I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER. I HAVE
ANY WITH GABRIEL IMUS AND A FULL
LINE OPPOSES BILL GIVE. MARGARET
JOHNSON NEVADA COUNTY MOTHER AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. RICHELLE ARAUCA PROUD
PATRIOT FOLLOWER OF JESUS
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI
JOHNNY VANDER POL FROM POLLOCK
PINES CALIFORNIA ABOUT
PLACERVILLE PRODUCT OF A
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL PREGNANCY
AND I STRONGLY PUBLIC POSE A. B.
TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS I'M A WHAT A HIGH SCHOOL
IN AUBURN CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU. SUE READ
OFFERING CALIFORNIA A THRIVING
GRATEFUL PRODUCT OF A PREMATURE
PREGNANCY AND A VEHEMENTLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. PEGGY MCDANIEL REPRESENTING
THE LA HABRA LIFE CENTER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MICHELLE HOWARD ORANGE
CALIFORNIA CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO
HILLS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. CALIFON SAY
CHINO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. TINA
IRVINE OF WILLMAR CALIFORNIA AND
I EMPHATICALLY OPPOSED AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU. KIM
MACLEOD MARIETTA CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. BERMAN MORGAN OF
GARDEN GROVE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING FIFTEEN ADDITIONAL
VOTERS. WE ARE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. DON SWANSON FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY PROS A. B. TWO TWO TWO
THREE GIVE. HI MY NAME IS DANIEL
SWANSON I'M A TEACHER A PARENT
AND A GRANDMOTHER I TEN DESTINY
CHRISTIAN CHURCH AND LISTEN TO
YOU A LOT AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. I CAN MARTINEZ
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AGO TO
DESTINY CHRISTIAN CHURCH AND I
HIGHLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
PRAY THAT YOU GUYS MAKE THE
RIGHT CHOICE. IF HI NICKY LOPEZ
FROM LINCOLN CALIFORNIA GO TO
DESTINY CHURCH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF. HELLO MY
NAME IS NICHOLA DONNIE I'M A
MEMBER OF DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH A SPECIAL NEEDS MOM OF
TWIN MOM IN A FORMER FETUS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS TO MICAH AND
I REPRESENT ALL THE PEOPLE. WHO
CHOOSE LIFE AND I URGE YOU TO
CHOOSE LIFE AND VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
CANALI MO FROM FULL FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. PERHAPS
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
ALAIMO ON A THIRTY YEAR RESIDENT
FOLSOM CALIFORNIA AND A
LIFELONG. REGISTERED DEMOCRAT
VOTER I URGE EVERYONE TO VOTE NO
ON THE SENATE BILL TWO TWO TWO
THREE GIVE. HI MY NAME IS MRS
STOTLER I AM FROM CONCORD
CALIFORNIA I GO TO- CALVARY
CHAPEL IN CONCORD. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL GIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS YVONNE FELL
DUTY AND I LIVE IN BRENTWOOD
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY CALIFORNIA
HERE AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. YOUR. MY NAME
IS BENJAMIN DAVID MAXWELL. AND I
I'M FROM CHINO HILLS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
. DAVID COULD NOT- MY RECENT AND
BUT PROUD RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO PROUD BROTHER A BROTHER
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS- DUE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS STEPHEN
PIETISM A FULL TIME LOVE LIFE
USA MISSIONARY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS INFANTICIDE BILL.
YOU I AM MIKE MARTIN FROM
WESTMINSTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS HIDEOUS BILL. MISTER
POSITION ON THE BILL WE AYE AND
PAM MARTIN FROM ORANGE COUNTY
MOM'S A MILITARY I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
YOUR- HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE
MORALES FROM BEAUMONT CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GIVES SIGN INTO MEMORIAL AND
PLEASE VOTE NO ON. HERE NAMES
JUST AYE MORRELL AND- I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
DAVID HALE I'M A SURGICAL
TECHNOLOGIST AND OWNER OF ACE
HEALTHCARE STAFFING AGENCY IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA GIVE
ME NOW I'M FROM BROADWAY TO%
CALIFORNIA I AM A MOM A GRANDMA
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A BOND
SERVANT OF JESUS CHRIST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. YEAH
MY NAME IS JOHN TERRY I- FROM
DIAMOND BAR OF ANEMA RETIRED
PUBLIC SCHOOL- HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IF HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT LISKI- PARIS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
AM A SELFLESS KEY FROM PARIS
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS JUDY
BERNAL A REPRESENTS A THIS
INTERPOL CHURCH HERE IN
RANCHERIA CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU IF.
KERRY HAGGERTY WITH PLASTER
COUNTY I'M A MOTHER OF SEVEN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED AB B. TWO TWO
TWO THREE. HI I'M MIKE PENCE
THANK YOU FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO BE A VOICE
FOR THE VOICELESS SO PLEASE VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL. IF HI CHARLENE
FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA. PLEASE
VOTE NO ON A. B. TWO TO THREE.
HI MY NAME IS SUSAN CISNEROS AND
I AM FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND I AM HERE AS A VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS AND I STRONGLY-
REQUEST THAT YOU OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AS WELL
AS A ME THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS LIZ RITCHIE I REPRESENT NEW
CALIFORNIA STATE AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING EAGLE FORUM. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO TWO
TWO THREE. BECAUSE IT IS A MARIO. HELLO MY NAME IS LUIS ORTEGA
MY FATHER FOR- FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY REPRESENTING THE
ANTINEUTRINO FOR GOVERNOR
CAMPAIGN AND WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FLOOR HALL I AM A PASTOR IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND JESUS IS LORD IN
THIS CASE. I'M DOCTOR SUSAN
RALPH FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA FOUNDER OF THE U. S.
IN CALIFORNIA PER WASH AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. I'M DOCTOR
FRED ROUND CHILD ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRIST IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE IF. I'M LINDA
SMITH ABOARD IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA NATIVE CALIFORNIAN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO
TWO TWO THREE. WHEN SMITH CASTRO
VALLEY CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE TWO TWO THREE THREE GIVE
. HE LISA EMMERICH MANTECA
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
VOTE NO ON A. B. TWO TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU YOUR- HI TINA MY
RADIANCE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER AND FOSTER
MOTHER TO SIXTY TWO CHILDREN AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF MY NAME
IS CONNIE BRACHER I AM FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AUBURN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M WITH CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IF NANCY THORNTON
FROM AUBURN CALIFORNIA AND-
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS JULIA KRIEGER FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY. I WAS ONCE
ASKED TO ABORT MY BABY I SAID NO
HERE SERVE THE INTEREST YOUR
POSITION- THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THEY GIVE YOU TWO TWO THANK. YOU
HELLO MY NAME IS PACKED. I'M A
RETIRED TEACHER HERE WAS
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA AND
I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE IF. HELLO MY NAME IS
MARLO TUCKER AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR OF CONCERNED
WOMEN FOR AMERICA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE IF THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS ROCHELLE CONNOR I AM A
GRANDMOTHER GREAT GRANDMOTHER
AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE LIAISON
FOR CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IN
ADDING TO YOUR NO VOTE. YOUR HI
MARTY AND I REPRESENTS ST JOHN'S
ANGLICAN CHURCH PETALUMA PLEASE
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL IF. MY NAME
IS KATHY GILLMAN- WITH REDWOOD
GOSPEL MISSION OF SANTA ROSA AND
SONOMA COUNTY AND WE ASK YOU
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. IF
I'M VIRGINIA STAFFORD FROM TWALA
ME COUNTY I'M THE PRODUCT OF A
PREGNANCY AS ARE ALL OF YOU. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IF.
HI WILLIAM LOS C. FROM TWELVE
MAY COUNTY CALIFORNIA. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TEARING HER AND
HER FROM THE SCENE TRUTH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. GIVE
HI MY NAME IS SHAWN SLATER I'M
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND NEW LIFE
CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN FAIR OAKS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOUR HI MY NAME IS SIR JEALOUS
SURGEON I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL YOUR- HIGHER BURDEN OF A
LARGE FROM FOLSOM AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO. HI I'M LYNN ROBINSON
I AM A CHILD OF GOD AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THE PASTOR JACK AND
ALL THE CHILDREN OF TO BE BORN
IN THE FUTURE. IF MY NAME IS ROB
ROBINSON I'M FROM LODI. I AM A
PRODUCT. YOU I'M REMAIN SEPARATE
PRETENDING MYSELF THE PEOPLE TO
CONFORM PLEASE VOTE AGAINST. IF. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SHERRY VITALI I AM A CHILD OF
THE MOST HIGH CREATOR OF ALL
CREATION IN THE NAME OF JESUS I
STAND HERE IN OPPOSITION I
OPPOSE STRONGLY A. B. TWO TWO
TWO THREE I PRAYED GOD GIVE YOU
WAS. FORMER FIDESZ I'M WITH
FORTY DAYS FOR LIFE STUDENTS FOR
LIFE AND PREGNANCY COUNSELING
SERVICES AND PLACERVILLE. AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
. MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE MAN I
LIVE IN EL DORADO HILLS OUT OF
TORONTO COUNTY I VOLUNTEER FOR
PREGNANCY COUNSELING IN
PLACERVILLE FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS I OPPOSED TO TWO TO THREE.
YOUR MY NAME IS MARK TRAVIS I
LIVE IN PLASTER COUNTY BABY
MURDERS NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED. MY NAME IS EMILY CRAIG I LIVE
IN AUBURN I OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION STRONGLY AND I
CONDEMN THOSE WHO REPORT. WE
COULD JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL WITH FOR
THE JEWS TO KEEP IT THAT WAY
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
NANCY HUMANISM A FORMER CAE
BURKE CARE GIVER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI JULIE
ANNA RAMIREZ WITH LOCALS
TRUCKING AND CALVARY CHAPEL
SWEET HILLS AND BANNING
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL YEAH. MY NAME IS A
PROGRAM FIFTH I'M FROM BANNING
CALIFORNIA CALVET CHAPEL SWEET
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. YOU MY NAME IS SANDRA
PERKINS I'M FROM FOUR TWELVE
CHURCH MARIETTA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL. YOUR HI MY
NAME IS FRANCISCO MANTAS FROM
SOUTHWEST RIVERSIDE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE YOU. VALERIE
GOLDSTINE MODESTO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE YOUR- MICHAEL BRADY.
MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IF.
NEED A BRADY I AM A RETIRED
EDUCATOR OF A LARGE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS RENEE ROBERTSON
FROM MODESTO I'M A RETIRED NURSE
AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THIS BILL. YOUR MY NAME IS
SHERRY FOG I'M FROM THE
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ZARINA COULD TO NOT I AM A
MOTHER ON OUR END I ATTEND
CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. IF GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS AMBER LE DANCY GONZALEZ I'M
FROM ORANGE CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
FOUR BOYS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IF HELLO MY NAME IS
DIGIT IS ROSS AND I SHOW OF
REMORSE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF HI MY NAME
IS LUCY A CARDIO WAS BORN HERE A
CITIZEN- FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA. I'M A VICTIM OF
FORCED ABORTION WHEN I WAS A
MINOR I OPPOSE THIS BILL I SAY
NO TO A NEW TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. LOS FOLLOW TO. A CHILD OF
GOD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. IF MY NAME IS MICHELLE
WARREN FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY A
MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IF. MY NAME IS
LAMONTE WORN. AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IF THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DIANA
TOOK CAN PLASTER COUNTY CITIZEN
I OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. HELLO I'M ROBIN GARY FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA FROM CHINO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
DEMONIC BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS
FLOPPY ABOARD USE I'M FROM
ANAHEIM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH
IF. HI MY NAME'S CAROLINE WEEKS
FROM WHAT I CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. YOUR
HELLO MY NAME IS MANY
VASSILIADIS I AM FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I REPRESENT
VOTERS FROM DISTRICT SEVENTY
SEVEN. YEAR ELAINE VAIL CONDO
I'M A VOTER FROM ESCONDIDO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IF. MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE SUELEN AMERICAN
CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THAT YOU GUYS ARE
INTRODUCED EMAIL. IF MY NAME'S
MATT AM AMERICAN CITIZEN BORN
AND RAISED IN CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DISGUSTING
BILL GIVEN UP WITH THE ADJUTANTS
PLEASE JUST GERMANISATION
OURSELVES ALL OF IN I'M A THIRD
GENERATION NATIVE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. GOT IT. THANK YOU. BARTON
NAME IS CAN YOU HEAR ME MY NAME
IS VERONICA I'M A DISAPPOINTED
RESIDENT FROM YUBA COUNTY I
STAND AS A PRO LIFE ON YOUR OWN
A MEMBER OF DESTINY CHURCH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS INFANTICIDE
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THANK
YOU. LET ME STOP FOR A SECOND.
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL ENOUGH OF THE
ADJECTIVES. NAME AND POSITION ON
THE BILL IN ANY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENT OTHERWISE WERE CUT OFF
. NAME IS CHRISTY MOORE AND I'M
FOR PLEASANT HILL CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHERRY AND I HAVE HEARD. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERTO
PEREZ AND I OPPOSE BILL TWO TWO
TWO THREE THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
EVELYN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE LOPEZ I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU. MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE DEGREE I'M AN RN FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY I REPRESENT-
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS FROM MY
GROUP TAKE A STAND STANISLAUS.
AND WE ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS LISA GAMBLIN I'M IN OUR
END FOR ON THE EAST SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSE IT. HI MY NAME
IS TERRA GONZALEZ I AM FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS ASININE BILL. ONE
MORE TIME AND WE'RE GONNA CUT
OFF PUBLIC THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
OKAY. ONE MORE TIME. MY NAME IS
LARGEST OIL AND I'M KEVIN DOYLE.
AND MELANIE DOYLE AND MEDICAID
WE'RE FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND BECAUSE SOMEBODY LET THESE
TO LIVE WE ADOPTED THEM PLEASE
LET THEM LIVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU BURKE AGAINST THE BILL THANK
YOU. WITH IT WE HAVE TEN MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY LEFT AND AS I SAID
SHOULD WE DEVIATE FROM THE
PATTERN YOU JUST HEARD WE WILL
WE WILL LET WE WILL AND THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH DONNELLY I'M A LONG
BEACH EDUCATOR AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BELIEVE
ALL. DESERVE LIFE LIBERTY. THANK
YOUR FOR LETTING US BE HEARD MY
NAME'S LERI PEDIA. I AM FROM-
MEMBER COVERAGE UP WHICH CHINO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ALLISON HAYDEN
I'M FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY SPECIAL
ED TEACHER CANDIDATE FOR
CONGRESS. I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS SHARON
NIGHT LINGER ON A MOTHER A
GRANDMOTHER AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER AND I STRONGLY. OF
THANK YOU. I'M AYE CHAN I'M AT
THE FROM YOUR COMMITTEE CHURCH
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND A VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS WENDY ON THE
TAIWANESE AMERICAN FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND YOU WERE COMMUNITY
CHURCH I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. FROM CONNOR CHEN
I'M FROM FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL YEAH
. HI MY NAME IS RENEE GARCIA I'M
ALSO FORMER FETUS I FROM CHINO
CALIFORNIA I'M COVERAGE UP IN
CEDAR HILLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE TWO TWO TWO THREE. YOU HI
MY NAME'S ILANA GOODMAN I'M ALSO
FROM CHINO HILLS- COVERAGE
CHAPEL AND SELLS AND I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO TWO
TWO THREE. MY NAME IS NORMAN AND
REYES MY HUSBAND KEITH REYES AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE AND WE OFFER FULL COVERAGE
APPLE CHINO HILLS. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS DONNA MONCADA AND I
ASK YOU PLEASE JOIN ME IN
OPPOSING- AB TWO TWO TWO THREE
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS DAISY
CONTRAST BECAUSE OF FROM ENTERIC
CALIFORNIA MASA FROM CHINO HILLS
AND I'M A I'D OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS ARNOLD
STRUGGLING FROM RIALTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. BETTER JOHN
CHIU REPRESENTING CITY BLESSING
CHURCH OF OUR OVER TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS STRONGLY OPPOSE THE ON
CONCERT TO SNOW BABY DAUGHTER
BILL AND F. HI MY NAME IS PAT
MIGHT COME FROM SADDLEBACK
CHURCH IN ORANGE COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. HI ANTHONY FINALLY WE ARE
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES CITY
BLESSING CHURCHES AND WE THE
PEOPLE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL YOU. HI MY NAME IS
CLOSEST WILL GO REPRESENTING
ACCESS COLLEGE MINISTRIES AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI MY
NAME IS MARIANNA I'M A
REPRESENTING CITY BLESSING
CHURCH WITH THE MISSIONS WILL
BLESSING FOUNDATIONS AND WE
OPPOSE STRONGLY ON THIS. TICKET
HI MY NAME IS SOARING EAGLE I
REPRESENT JESUS CHRIST AND I
STRONGLY PROS AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU. HI I'M JEANNIE
GREGORY I'M NOT BASS REFER
CRISIS SO GOD WERE PLEADING
THROUGH MAY I IMPLORE YOU ON
CHRIST'S BEHALF PROJECT THIS
BILL. I'M JANICE PETTIT A NEAR
DEATH SURVIVOR FROM PLASTER
COUNTY THERE IS NO PAINLESS
KILLING PLEASE REJECT AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE- HI NEED TO HIDE FROM
L. A. COUNTY REPRESENTING THOSE
THAT HAVE NO VOICE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. IT HI AM AB HOW A FROM
COVINA CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS AND URGE YOU TO DO
THE SAME. HELLO I AM CHRISTINA
BELLMAN AND I'M FROM CALVARY
CHAPEL CHINO OR YOU GOT IT OKAY
CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS MY
HUSBAND AND I BOTH HE SET ME UP
THERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. IF HELLO OTHER CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOSH
RULE FROM FULLERTON ALSO GO TO
CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS AND I
AM OPPOSED. TO AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ESERVER HALEY I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MATTHAUS ARE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. COLLETTE IN
RECASTS ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THIS BILL
THANK YOU. STEVEN RICK IS FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M ASKING YOU TO
VOTED NO ON A BEAT TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. YOUR I'D
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOUR.
HAVE NECESSARY RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS NOT THE WORD
THE LAST FIVE MINUTES I
APOLOGIZE FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY WE DID
SET THIS AT SIXTY MINUTES FOR
THIS TESTIMONY THE LAST FIVE
MINUTES OF PLEASE GO AHEAD KELLY
SALE FROM SUTTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. YOU
WE ARE MOVING TO SORT OF ALMOST
A CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS.
AND THE STEP WAS TO THE BILL I
BET BEEN TO THOSE BRING TO THIS.
YEAR MIKAELA SO THOUGHT CALVARY
CHAPEL CHINO HILLS THE AMOUNT OF
BANGALORE KERN BE LIVING THROUGH
THOSE TWENTY THIRD. YOUR TO READ
THE KNOX FROM L. A. COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS SHARON LAND SIDE AND I'M
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JOHN HAMILTON I
MEAN KEVIN MCCARTY SEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- I'M AN
ADOPTEE AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS BILL. IF JESSICA
WAGNER STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE IT. BRANDING CAMPBELL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
CONNECTION REPRESENTING BAPTIST
CHURCHES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND PASTOR OF THE FAITH BAPTIST
CHURCH IN WHEATLAND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. I AM
CHRISTINE CAMPBELL FROM YUBA
COUNTY I'M A MOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. NAME
IS GRACE GREGORY STUDENT FOR ME
THE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL YOU. MY GRANDMA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. LLOYD
CAMPBELL PLASTER COUNTY A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JENNIFER GREGORY
AND I'M FROM YUBA COUNTY AND MY
MOM AND A GRANDMA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. STEVE GREGORY
FROM YUBA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT SHALL NOT KILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF ACLU ACTION CALIFORNIA
AND THEY'RE ALL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IF WHEN HOW LORING
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE BY
CONTROLLING HIS ACTION PROJECT
OKAY THE CALIFORNIA THE AND
ABENOMICS BULLISH IMPLANT PLATES. BIG NAMES WILL APPEAR FROM
SENECA I OPPOSE THIS BILL IF. MY
NAME IS DANIELLE I'M FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND MY MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. GOOD DAY MY NAME IS CINDY
SHAVER FROM PLASTER COUNTY I'M A
GRANDMOTHER OF SEVEN ICE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. YOU.
HELLO I'M BRENDA SANDFORD AND
I'M FROM NEVADA COUNTY. AND I
OPPOSE. A. B. TWO TWO TWO THREE
A WE'VE BEEN HERE THE EARLY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED Q. A LAST TWO
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. HI MY NAME
IS APRIL MY SLEEVE FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WITH LOVE LIFE
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO OPPOSE B.
TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
HELLO ADRIENNE LAB FROM WILSON
AND I OPPOSE EIGHTY B. TWO TWO.
TWO THREE THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS LEANDRO LAP I'M WITH
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS JUST ONE LAP AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS KELLY DOBSON I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS JOSH WHEEL WELLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MATTHEW HAMMOND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANOTHER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT IF. WHAT AM I GONNA SAYS
THAT MANUAL WITH IF ON HOW
LOWERING FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORT. IF
DOT HUNTER ON BEHALF OF TEACH
TURNING IN EARLY ABORTION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE IN
STOCK THE PORT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF A FEEL YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SHANNON TOP OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BETHANY
GOLDEN NURSE MIDWIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KIMBERLY
ROBINSON WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO
LENA CHAVEZ ON THE ABORTION
TRAINING COORDINATOR FOR TEACH
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
WILL CLOSE OUR PUBLIC MISTER
MONEY. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. THIS CARILLO SECOND
BY. A YEAR CURRY THIS WALDRON
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. HI I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE A COMMENT WE
HEARD A LOT OF LINK THE-
TESTIMONY. AND- YOU KNOW THE
ISSUE A LOT OF THE ISSUE COMES
AROUND THE PHRASE DUE TO A
PREGNANCY RELATED BECAUSE- AND-
FIVE IT'S AN AMBIGUOUS IN THE
BILL IS VAGUE IT'S KIND OF OVER
BROAD. AND THERE MAY BE ISSUES
IT COMES. WILL. FIVE M. WE ALL
KNOW I WORK FOR YEARS IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SPACE DEALING WITH
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION IN FACT
WHICHIS REAL- YOU KNOW WHAT
EXACTLY IS A PREGNANCY RELATED
BECAUSE WOULD CERTAINLY INCLUDE
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION AND A
MYRIAD OF OTHER PREGNANCY
RELATED ISSUES. BUT THE WAY THAT
IT'S SO BROAD IT COULD SWALLOW
UP A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER STUFF
WHICH COULD BE A BOTCHED
ABORTION WERE BABY IS BORN
ALIVE. WHAT HAPPENS THEN THERE'S
NO INVESTIGATION. BECAUSE
CURRENTLY- THE LAW. IS PRETTY
CLEAR IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
SECTION. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FOUR
THREE FIVE. SHARES OF A CHILD IS
BORN ALIVE IN THE COURSE WHEN
ABORTION THE CHILD MUST RECEIVE
THE CARE OFFERED A CHILD BORN IN
A LIVE BIRTH. SO THERE'S NO PHAM
LONGER REALLY ANY REGULATIONS OR
OVERSIGHT OF THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY. THIS PROVISION
REGARDING BORN ALIVE ABORTION
HAS NOT BEEN ENFORCED. BUT AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE IS PROCEEDING.
RIGHT NOW AS WE WERE HEARING BUT
IT WOULD STRIKE OUT. HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR THREE FIVE. WHICH
WOULD DIRECTLY AFFECT A CHILD
BEING BORN ALIVE IN THE COURSE
OF AN ABORTION- NOTE ALSO FOR
OUR YOU KNOW IT WHAT I'M SEEING
IS THE SWEEPING LANGUAGE. WILL
OPEN A WHOLE DIFFERENT MYRIAD OF
ISSUES REMOVING CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR PERSONS
WHO MAY CAUSE THE DEATH OF
INFANTS DAYS OR WEEKS AFTER
BIRTH AND BASICALLY ORDERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO AVERT THEIR EYES
. A RISK PROSECUTION SIMPLY BY
DOING THEIR JOB AND HONORING
HUMAN LIFE. SO BORN ALIVE
CHILDREN ARE WITHOUT QUESTION
PERSONS PROTECTED BY THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. N. AS OFTEN OCCURS
WITH CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
EXCESSES AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST THIS WILL CERTAINLY BE
STRUCK DOWN AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
. THE BY THE US SUPREME COURT SO
WE'VE DONE THIS BEFORE WE'VE
SEEN THESE KIND OF BILLS BEFORE
SO I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M. ANYONE ELSE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C.
NINE WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO WE HAVE A SECOND I MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE MOST WEEKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I'M WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSING TO RESPOND TO MISS
WALDRON. AND I PRETTY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS UP
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MISINFORMATION ABOUT
THIS BILL WHICH HAS BEEN FACT
CHECKED BY. WRITERS THE
SACRAMENTO BEE EIGHT PM PLAYED A
FACT SPECIFICALLY ON EXACTLY
WHAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO AND
THEY HAVE DETERMINED THAT. MUCH
LIKE WHAT I READ IN THE BILL
THAT- THE WAY THAT IS FRAME THIS
IS INCORRECT ACTUALLY THE BILL
SPECIFIC TO PREGNANCY AND
PREGNANCY RELATED OUTCOMES. AND
DOES NOT DECRIMINALIZE. BUT A
QUOTE THE MURDER BABIES IN THE
WEEKS AFTER BIRTH. AS IT RELATES
TO THE PERINATAL PERIOD
MENTIONED IN THE BILL LANGUAGE
THE INTENT IS TO PROTECT A
PREGNANT PERSON'S EXPERIENCE.
WHO EXPERIENCES THE TRAUMA OF
LOSING A BABY AFTER DELIVERY. AS
A RESULT OF THE PREGNANCY
RELATED ISSUE. THIS BILL WOULD
NOT PREVENT POLICE FROM
INVESTIGATING FETAL DEATHS THAT
OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF A CRIME
COMMITTED AGAINST. OR FROM.
GETTING INTO. THE AS A RESULT OF
AN ACT OR MISSION THAT TOOK
PLACE AFTER DELIVERY. AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WOULD NOT
PREVENT A THIRTIES FROM BEING
ABLE TO INVESTIGATE THE FACTS OF
A NEWBORN CHILD TO DEATH.
INCLUDING WHETHER THE CHILD WAS
BORN LIVING AND WHEN AND HOW THE
CHILD DIED. THE BILL WOULD ONLY
PREVENT FOR THEIR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE PREGNANCY
THE PREGNANT PERSON. IN THE
EVENT THAT THE DEATH WAS
DETERMINED BY THE PENINSULA
RELATED COSTS. SO I JUST WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT AND I'M
ALSO WANNA A LOT MY IF SUCH
INDULGENCE. MY THIS IS ALL.
ANYTHING ELSE THEY LIKE TO WITH
REGARD TO THIS SPECIFIC MATTER
BECAUSE I DO THINK THIS IS WHAT
HAS COME UP NUMEROUS TIMES. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF INACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SO A. B. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WAS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT PARENTS WHO EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA OF LOSING A CHILD AFTER
DELIVERY AS A RESULT OF
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED DURING
THEIR PREGNANCY- SO MEDICAL
EXAMPLE OF THIS COULD BE-
PRETERM PREMATURE RUPTURE OF
MEMBRANES WHEN THE WATER AROUND
DEPARTMENTS HE BREAKS- PRIOR TO
DELIVERY- PRIOR TO WE WANTED TO-
SO THIS COULD RESULT STILLBIRTH
OR CAN RESULT- IN A PERINATAL
LOSS AFTER A DELIVERY FROM
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS INFECTION
OR THE LUNGS BEING IMMATURE.
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT- YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE. THE PASSION
ON THIS ISSUE. I'M ON ON BOTH
SIDES AND UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
FEEL VERY- THE NEED TO COME HERE
AND ENGAGE IN THE CONVERSATION
AND I ADMIRE THAT- THAT
DIALOGUE. I WILL SAY I COME TO
THIS. AS A MOTHER I HAVE A FIVE
YEAR OLD AND A ONE YEAR OLD
LITTLE GIRL. AND THE WORLD IN
WHICH THEY ARE GROWING UP. AND
THE DEBATE THAT HAVING RIGHT ON
ABORTION COUNTRY. ONE THAT.
BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY. WE
HAVE WOMEN WHO ARE BEING
PROSECUTED FOR HAVING
MISCARRIAGES AND THAT IS NOT
OKAY AND THAT CANNOT HAPPEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT. AND I'M SOMEONE WHO'S
DONE LEGISLATION TO IT. WHERE DO
I CARE. AND WOMEN CAN QUALIFY
FOR IVF TREATMENT SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY. PLAN A FAMILY WHEN
THEY WANT TO PLAN A FAMILY. BUT
IN THE ON THIS ISSUE WE HAVE TO
STAND STRONG AND SAY THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN NOT BE
CRIMINALIZED FLOODING STILLBIRTH
FOR HAVING A MISCARRIAGE FOR
HAVING AN ABORTION AND I'M%
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD A MISCARRIAGE
I'VE SPOKEN ABOUT IT PUBLICLY
I'VE HAD AN ABORTION. THIS IS A
DEEPLY PERSONAL ISSUE. AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE HAVE TO
SEND A MESSAGE TO THE REST OF
THIS COUNTRY. THAT YOU COULD NOT
BE PENALIZED FOR PREGNANCY
RELATED LOSSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS WICKS.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON NO AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE. ARAMBULA
BIGELOW BIGELOW NO CARILLO RIO
AYE FLORA FLORA NOW MAIENSCHEIN
. MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVAS
I RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO KALRA. BY
THE THREE RIVERS FIVE THREE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WANT TO AN EX BILL
MISTER BRIAN YOU'RE UP.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON J. ENVIRON AND EMOTION
YOU DIDN'T SAY A WORD DID. THE
GAP OF THE HIGH RISE THEY DID
PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE
A BILL THAT MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO OUR STATE'S
DEFINITION OF STUDENT BLANKET
INSURANCE COVERAGE. FOR SOMEONE
THINK AND ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- AS CHAIR YOU IN YOUR
COMMITTEE DO AN UNBELIEVABLE JOB
AND MY TEAM'S GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
COLLABORATING ON THIS BILL. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK HEALTH ACCESS
FOR THEY'RE WILLING TO MULLIN IS
TO WORK WITH US. YOU TAKE A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS WE CONTINUE
TO WORK. IN COLLABORATION AND
SOLIDARITY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OFTEN PURCHASE
STUDENT BLANK INSURANCE POLICIES
TO COVER HEALTH BENEFITS TO
THEIR OWN ROLE. IT'S THEIR
OVERT. TWO AND A HALF MILLION
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
OF THOSE THE CALIFORNIA PART OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY
A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND THEIR DEPENDENTS
RELY ON THEIR COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY FOR THEIR HEALTH
BENEFITS. DIDN'T BLANK INSURANCE
COVERAGE IS AN EASY A RELIABLE
OPTION FOR STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED OR
INELIGIBLE TO BE ON THEIR
PARENTS PLANS. OFTENTIMES DIDN'T
BLANK INSURANCE IS CHEAPER
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE. THAN
THE ALTERNATIVE THAT IS STILL
COMPLYING WITH THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND STILL PROVIDE
SOCIAL HEALTH BENEFITS FOR
STUDENTS. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE CODE STUDENT BLANK
INSURANCE COVERAGE INCLUDES
HOSPITAL MEDICAL SURGICAL DRUG.
IN NURSING IS SPENT. EXPENSES
RESULTING FROM ACCIDENT OR
SICKNESS. THE CALIFORNIA
INTEREST CALLED ALSO
CHARACTERIZES SUCH BLANKET
POLICIES OF THE TYPE OF
DISABILITY INSURANCE. RATHER
THAN AS INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT MANY STUDENTS AND
THEIR DEPENDENTS RELY ON IT AS
SUCH. THIS IS INCONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL LAW WHICH LABEL STUDENT
BLANK INSURANCE COVERAGES
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE. CALIFORNIA HAS HIGHER
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND HEALTH
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS. THAT ARE
AT AN EVEN HIGHER STANDARD THAN
THEY CA. YET OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR DEPENDENTS ARE NOT
GUARANTEED THESE PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE- STUDENT BLANKET
INSURANCE COVERAGE IS CURRENTLY
NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR STATE'S
HEALTH AND- IT'S- INTERNET
DEPEND. RELY ON INSURANCE
THROUGH THEIR COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
ARE NOT ENTITLED. TO BENEFITS
SUCH AS LIMITED COST SHARING FOR
OUTPATIENT PRESCRIPTION DRUGS OR
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE WILL FIX THIS BY
REDEFINING STUDENT BLANKET
INSURANCE COVERAGE OF THE TYPE
OF INDIVIDUAL HEALTH INSURANCE.
THIS WOULD BRING THESE. POLICIES
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE MANDATES RELATED TO
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH INSURANCE BY
DOING CHAU WE ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING ADEQUATE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE. THAT
IS UP TO THE PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH AND NECESSARY
STANDARDS YOU WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY. IS KATIE FISHER AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON KATIE FISHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN FOR
OFFERING AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE. DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
IS SPONSORING EIGHTEEN AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE WHICH
WOULD ALIGN THE DEFINITION OF
STUDENT LIKE A POLICIES WITH
FEDERAL LAW. WHICH CONSIDERS
DIDN'T BLINK POLICIES TO BE
THAT'S SUBJECT TO MORE REGULATOR
OVERSIGHT AND INCREASED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AVAILABLE UNDER
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
I'M GOING TO BE VERY BRIEF AND
BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BUT IN DIFFERENT YOUR
TIME I'M GOING TO BE VERY BRIEF-
THESE CHANGES ARE IMPERATIVE
ESPECIALLY DURING AND AFTER THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS MAY NEED AND WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO SEEK THEIR CARE
BY ACCESSING TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND- RICARDO LARA
ASTER I ABOUT. YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IS THERE
ANY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT EASY FOR YOU
TODAY. I APPRECIATE THAT MR
BRYANT. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
AND EITHER FOR OR AGAINST THIS
BILL. SO YOU KNOW WHEN WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- I THINK
WE STILL MIGHT HAVE AN OPERATOR
THAT THERE. OPERATOR WE HAVE I'M
SORRY I CAN'T DO WE HAVE. WE
HAVE OPPOSITION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO THE BILL.
OKAY PLEASE COMPORT I'M SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DIANA
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION WE REMAIN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE BUT ARE
ENGAGING AND VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE AND SPONSORS. IN
APPRECIATE COMMON GROUND AND
WANTING ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING STUDENTS HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE COVERAGE WE'VE LONG
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ALL ARE
AWARE OF HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
COVERAGE OPTIONS AND WE SEEK
AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE NOTICE OF
COVER COVERAGE OPTIONS.
AVAILABLE IN COVERED HELP NOW
AND BUT I CAL TO BE POLLUTED
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HEALTH INSURANCE. WE ALSO HAVE
CONSISTENTLY BEEN OPPOSED TO
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS THAT
ARE SEEKING AN AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE LANGUAGE THAT LINKS
TERMINATION OF COVERAGE TO
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS.
INSTEAD WE SUGGEST LANGUAGE TO
CLEARLY STATE THAT COVERAGE MAY
BE TERMINATED IF THE INSURED IS
NO LONGER A STUDENT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE AND SPONSORS
TO RESOLVE THESE TWO REMAINING
ISSUES AND ARE CONFIDENT WE'LL
GET TO A GOOD PLACE IN THE BUFF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. GO TO THE PHONE
LINES TO OUR A META MODERATOR
YOU ARE YOU OUT THERE SOMEWHERE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. HE'S HAD
A LONG DAY HE'S ALONG TO HIM. WE
HAVE. OPERATOR. IF THIS WAS IN
MY WOULD SAY YOU'RE ON MUTE.
SEEING THAT WE'RE. WE HAVEN'T
HAD ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OR
EVERY WEEK WHAT A WAY. HI MY
NAME IS LORN HANDING AND I AM A
DISABLED STUDENT AT UC RIVERSIDE
UP REPRESENTING THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RIGHT TO TRY TO
FIGURE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY HERE. PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. WHEN A
CENTER FOR PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
SO- AND. TO RESPECT THAT THEY
MADE THE CALL AND GIVE THE
OPTION OF PROCESS TO FIVE. SEEM
TO BE A PROBLEM WITH MICROPHONES
TODAY. WE HAVE ANOTHER MINUTE IF
WE CANNOT GET CANNOT GET- THIS
CONNECTED KANDIC WE CAN ALWAYS
WILL ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH OUR PORTAL. TO THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE.
THEY WILL GET IT M. FORTY
APOLOGIZE THE FOUR PEOPLE IN THE
IN THE QUEUE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON- WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THIS
OUT FOR FUTURE- WILL BRING BACK
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. THE
NINE WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOAT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER FLORES
SECOND MY MISS WALDRON. ODD DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH I CLOSED MISTER BRYANT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I THANK
YOU FOR ACCEPTED OUR AMENDMENTS
WE APPRECIATE THAT IT'S ALWAYS A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU. AS
SOON AS WE HAVE A SECTOR BACK WE
WILL CALL THE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW. MARIA RIO AYE
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
. MCCARTY I NAZARIAN RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
KALRA. SIX ZERO IF SIX VOTES THE
TREND IS GOOD WE ARE WE'RE
BUSINESS MEMBERS BUT EVERYBODY
WAS HERE VOTED FOR IT SO WE'LL
LEAVE THE LOG OFF. THANK YOU MR
THANK YOU. THIS CARILLO.
YOU HAVE A B. THE BILL AB TWENTY
TWO OH FIVE. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
ZERO FIVE THE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ABORTION
PREMIUMS UNDER CURRENT LAW
HEALTH INSURERS AND PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT A ONE DOLLAR
PER ENROLLEE PER MONTH PREMIUMS
. MRS REALLY NO REQUIREMENT THAT
HEALTH INSURERS AND PLANS REPORT
HOW MUCH IS COLLECTED OR HOW THE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED AB TWENTY
TWO ZERO FIVE REQUIRES INSURERS
TO SUBMIT AN ANNUAL REPORT
CONTAINING INFORMATION ON HOW
MUCH MONEY IS CURRENTLY IN THESE
ACCOUNTS AND HOW MUCH IS BEING
USED EACH YEAR TO PAY CLAIMS
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY THE FUNDS
GLOBAL ARE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR ABORTION SERVICES THE
FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
PROHIBITS COVERAGE SOLD THROUGH
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE'S WHERE
THE PREMIUMS ARE FEDERALLY
SUBSIDIZED. FROM BRING CLAIMS
FOR MOST ABORTIONS OR ABORTION
SERVICES A SEPARATE PREMIUM
PAYMENT OF ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER
PER MONTH MUST BE COLLECTED AND
HELD IN A SEGREGATED ACCOUNT BY
EACH HEALTH INSURER AND PLAN AND
ALL CLAIMS FOR ABORTION SERVICES
MUST BE PAID OUT OUT OF THAT
SEGREGATED ACCOUNT BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOR ALL ENROLLEES
AND HEALTH COVERAGE ON ON THE ON
THE TELEPHONE BUT X. THE STATE.
IS THE- PER MONTH ON THE OF ALL
THE ENROLLEES IN THESE PLANS
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS OF
MAINTAINING BE SEGREGATED
ACCOUNTS TE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES HEALTH INSURERS ALONE
HAVE COLLECTED SEVERAL MILLIONS
IN THESE ACCOUNTS THE ONE DOLLAR
PER MEMBER PER MONTH PREMIUM
LIKELY EXCEEDS THE COST OF
PROVIDING ABORTION SERVICES
WHICH CAN ONLY BE USED AT THE
SERVICES ON THE SERVICES. THIS
YEAR THE US SUPREME COURT IS
REVIEW DIRECT CHALLENGE TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO ABORTION
ESTABLISHED IN ROE V. WADE
SHOULD THE COURT OVERTURN ROE.
OVER THIRTY SIX MILLION WOMEN
AND PREGNANT PEOPLE WILL LOSE
ACCESS TO ABORTION CARE
ACCORDING TO A REPORT RELEASED
BY THE GOT MUCH INSTITUTE THE
NUMBER OF ADDED PATRONS FOUGHT
OR NEAR ABORTION BETTER IN OUR
STATE IN CALIFORNIA. FROM SIX.
TO ONE POINT FOUR ME. OF NEARLY
3000% CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE
TO SERVE ABORTION PATIENTS BUT
AS RESOURCES BECOME STRETCHED IT
IS IMPORTANT TO DETERMINE
POTENTIAL DIGITAL FUNDING
SOURCES TO SUPPORT PATIENTS
SEEKING CARE IN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS AMID ATTACKS TO WILL BE
WEIGHED IN A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WE MUST ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS READY TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE NO MATTER HOW FAR. AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO TRAVEL A CUTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO RECEIVE
THESE SERVICES AND OUR STATE
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALENDAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. HI
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
KATIEFISHER AN ATTORNEY IN THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND ACCESS OFFICE
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. THANK YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARDMEMBERS
AND KATIE FISHER AT IN HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. LIKE
TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREA
FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL. I WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. A FOR ALL THE BUT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST STATED-
WE'RE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT. OF B.
SOME OF THE DATA THAT SHE
MENTIONS THE FACT THAT THE ONE
DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER MONTH AB
PREMIUM CURRENTLY BEING
COLLECTED WE KNOW IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN COULD
EVER POSSIBLY BE SPENT ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE AND
ABORTION SPECIFICALLY. SO THERE
IS A LARGE CHUNK OF MONEY JUST
ITTING IN SEGREGATED ACCOUNTS
THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY BEING USED
AND THE COMMISSIONER SUPPORTS
ANY CREATIVE. AND BEST USE OF
THESE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
THE WOMEN THAT SEEK CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED- WE- HAVE
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I'VE UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO EMOTION
IN THE SECOND- OTHER OTHER
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WAS OR IS OUR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL I'M SORRY. THE
FATHER OF THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA WHERE A
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ERIN EVANS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GENERAL LIVE VERY HOVIS ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. OF.
THROUGH THE DINNER UGH SAMAEL
COUNTY I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. WHEN APRIL LOVE PLASTER
COUNTY I OPPOSE THE BILL YOUR-
MICHELLE DIENER ASSEMBLED YOU
KNOW COUNTY ARE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. NO ONE
WILL TRY TO GO TO THE FRONT
LINES AGAIN. FOR THE RECORD OUR
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. OPERATOR
SEPARATE OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WELCOME BACK PERFECT
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IFYOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
AB. TWO TWO.
THE COMMENT THAT WILL BE
ACCEPTED WILL BE YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION AND ANY ORGANIZATION
YOU REPRESENT. ATTAL BEIT. ZERO
TWO I AM SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN THREE
NINE. FIND TEN SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SO THE CASTEEL CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTRAL ACCENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S MERION FIRE CLOSER BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FIFTEEN
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
I NEED TO A CLEVELAND AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONLINE ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ABOUT A
MINUTE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTEEN FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
PHILADELPHIA PASADENA AND I
OPPOSE GO. YOUR NINE ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS THERESA SHEA IN ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
FIFTEEN OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS IN GREEN
CURRY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT HI MY NAME IS
SERENA LODGE AND I REPRESENT
INTO BRADLEY RUNNING FOR US
SENATE IN A TRONG ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL OKAY THE
TDP THINGS YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NINE SEVEN EIGHTY PER GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GOING TO
BE GRANTED I PROBABLY AND AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE WE ARE ACTUALLY
JUST RETIREMENT AB TWO TWO ZERO
FIVE SO NO MORE TESTIMONY ON TWO
TO THREE PLEASE. YOU'RE RIGHT
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IS THAT ME CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY MONNING OPENS
FROM L. A. COUNTY AT AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL AND MARK I HOPE YOU
ENJOY YOUR DATE ON THE OFFICE.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN
SIX EIGHT. HI MY AND SEVEN SEVEN
SIX EIGHT. GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS TIMOTHY BUYER AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO- PLEASE
GO AHEAD SHE- HI THIS MY ALEJO
OPENED- SEMINOLE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE IT HELLO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AYE IN SEVENTEEN OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN ZERO
NINE. THIS IS ANGELINA AND
CONTRA COSTA AND I OPPOSE IT
YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
THANKYOU VERY MUCH I DO WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM HERE SO PLEASE YOUR
NAME POSITION AND ORGANIZATIONS
YOU REPRESENT ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON. ON YOUR MOBILE
GALLAGHER. XIN PROJECT AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ EMOTION BEING TO PASS
TO PREPARATIONS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. NOW THE
BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THANK YOU HAVE THANK YOU. A MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW. FOR REAL AYE AYE LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
REQUEST RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. ALL RIGHT. SEVEN YES YOUR SEVEN VOTES
HERE ONE SHY WILL BE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU THINK SO MUCH
MISS KOREA. MISTER GIBSON-
SERVICE CONCERT IN SEQUENCE
GARCIA. VERY PLEASE COME FORWARD
. MY APOLOGIES. ON TOP OF THE
PODIUM IS APPARENTLY TALLER.
THANK YOU THANK ARE GONNA. THANK
YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THAT PROPOSE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK AT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL. AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX WHICH
AIMS TO COMBAT REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUAL HEALTH DISPARITIES FACING
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THESE DISPARITIES THE
BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP. SIX SEVEN THROUGH
CLASSES THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EFFECTS ON HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
THE STATE AND ESTABLISHES A
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AND FREEDOM FUND. WITH THE GOAL
OF DISMANTLING HISTORIC AND
SPENDING SYSTEMIC REPRODUCTIVE
AND SEXUAL HEALTH INEQUITIES.
THE FUND CREATED IT WOULD ALSO
BE USED TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS TRUSTED TO
PROVIDE MEDICALLY ACCURATE
SEXUAL. HEALTH EDUCATION. IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY SUN AND ACTUALLY
CUT MY COMMENTS HERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I WOULD
AND LET MY WITNESSES INSTEAD
INFILL AND A LOT OF THE GAPS FOR
THIS BILL. I WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE A LOT AND I GOT A CS AND
MENA WITH CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. AND
ENYEAMA A. B. K. UP FROM BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS TESTIFIED
SUPPORT. AND THEN YOU SAID YOU
WERE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES I THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TWO
WITNESSES THREE MINUTES EACH GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
PLAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LIEUTENANT ASSISTED MANUAL WITH
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. TESTIFYING
READING A TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF
UNFUNDED RECENT ARTICLE THIRTY
PREVENTION PROGRAM MANAGERS AT
LUMINA LAND'S. THE MINERAL LANDS
IS A SINGLE SEXUAL ASSAULT AN
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
RESOURCE CENTER FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN LUIS OBISPO. ALSO BIRD TO
A SLOW START COUNTY IS SPREAD
ALONG THE COASTLINE AND INTO A
LARGE AND THEN REGION WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. JEAN RANGING FROM
POPULATED URBAN AREAS TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS TO RURAL TOWNS THAT
ARE HOME TO BARELY ONE THOUSAND.
WE IMPLEMENT A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS TO REACH OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BEFORE VIOLENCE HAPPENS
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS AIMS TO
DELIVER COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION REPRODUCTIVE
AND SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION. IS
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND THAT
PROVIDE INSIGHTS WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS TO FORM
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS UNDERSTAND
CONSENT APPRENTICE BOUNDARIES.
WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING RISK
FACTORS PROVIDE PREVENT RETREAT. YOU THAT. WAS THE FIRST STEP.
THERE'S A LOT OF UP TO CREEK FOR
CHINA COMPLAIN. THE TOPICS ARE
QUITE VARIED AND- IN THIS TOPIC
CAN BE ON. TO TEACH WHEN YOU
WERE NEW TO THE- COLLEGES ARE
AT. DEVELOPED AND ACCESSIBLE AND
UP TO DATE CHECK CREEK. THAT IS
RELATABLE TO YOUTH. ENGAGING AND
IS DESIGNED TO INCLUDE LOCAL
RESOURCES. RELYING ON COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IS
BENEFICIAL FOR UNDERSTAFFED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HOWEVER ARE
AGENCIES LIMITED. IN THE NUMBER
OF EDUCATORS WHICH HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR MORE FUNDING.
DEDICATED TO SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION. OUR COUNTIES NEEDS
ARE DIVERSE AND WITH MANY
ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE PRIMARILY
SPANISH SPEAKING STUDENTS IN OUR
SCHOOLS. ORGANIZATION FOR
IMPEACHING THEM CONTACTING THE
TRANSLATION SERVICES. ARE
CALLING INTERPRETER SERVICES IS
USUALLY NOT TIMELY AND REQUIRES
PLANNING TIME. BUT WE OFTEN DO
NOT HAVE IT WOULD BE
REVOLUTIONARY TO HAVE THE- TURN
OFF THE BRITISH ADDITIONAL SIR
VINCE IS RURAL TOWN PRESENT ITS
OWN UNIQUE CHALLENGES HOW CAN
YOU GET SEXUAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN A TOWN WHERE EVERYONE KNOWS
EACH OTHER THESE TOWNS IN OUR
NORTH COUNTY DO NOT HAVE FREE
AND CONFIDENTIAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CLINICS AND IT IS
POSSIBLE FOR INSERTING CONDOMS
OR OTHER RPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES LIKE BIRTH CONTROL OR
ABORTIONS. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SIX WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEVELOP AN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SUSTAINABLE
SUCCESS DELIVERY AND EXPLORE
CREATIVE OPTIONS SUCH AS PUBLIC
CLINICS ARE TABLING EVENTS AT
FARMERS MARKETS AND FESTIVALS
THE SHARE INFORMATION. ALSO THEY
MAY HAVE THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
HAVE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS A
FAIR CHANCE AT FAMILY PLANNING
AND THE ABILITY TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WILLIAM UP ON YOUR MÀ AND I'M A
POLICY ANALYST WITH WALKING
FORMS ACTION PROJECT WHERE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION. COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING THE OVERALL HEALTH
STATUS AND WELL BEING OF BLACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS WE HAVE OFFICES
IN LA AND STOCKTON. I'M HERE
TRICKS. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SIX THE CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND FREEDOM FUND THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ADVANCE EQUITY IN
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BY
EMPLOYING BOTH SYSTEMS LEVEL AND
COMMUNITY BASED INTERVENTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE PERSISTENT
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES THAT ARE COMMUNITIES
FACE ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO AFFIRM AND
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
REPRODUCTIVE. JONATHAN OTHER
COLOR. YOUNG PEOPLE AND GENDER
EXPANSIVE PEOPLE BEAR THE BURDEN
OF HIGH REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL
HEALTH INEQUITIES IN OUR STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO STI FOR
INSTANCE. FOURTH IN THE COUNTRY
FOR. ONE MILLION EIGHTEEN FOR
GONORRHEA YOU FLAG FOLKS ANOTHER
LGBTQ PLUS FOLKS BEAR THE
DISPROPORTIONATE BURKE. TI'S IN
STATE CURRENTLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
YOUNG WOMEN ARE 5100% MORE
LIKELY TO CONTRACT GONORRHEA
CHLAMYDIA THEM THERE THEN OUR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS IN TERMS OF
CONTRACEPTIVE USE STUDIES HAVE
FOUND THAT RACE RELATED
DISPARITIES EXIST IN THE CHOICE
OF BIRTH CONTROL METHODS- WITH
WOMEN OF COLOR. REALLY USING
WITH METHODS WHICH IN TURN LEADS
TO HIGHER RATES OF UNINTENDED
PREGNANCIES A COG ACTUALLY NOTES
THAT A LACK OF KNOWLEDGE AND
MISPERCEPTIONS SOME OF THE MAJOR
BARRIERS TO CONTRACEPTIVE USE
INEQUITABLE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICALLY ACCURATE
CULTURALLY CONGRUENT
INFORMATION. EMISSIONS AS A
BARRIER TO K. MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION ABOUT
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
INCLUDING AROUND ABORTION
EXACERBATES VIEWS IN EQUITIES
AND CAUGHT ON TO OUR
COMMUNITY'S. A HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
EMPLOYEES LONG TERM SO WERE.
HELLO COMMUNITY CENTER AND IN
THAT'S ELIMINATE AND BIRD
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE WORK
GROUP THAT SEEKS TO DEVELOP.
SOLUTIONS WITH PROBLEM EXAM.
FIRST PAZ'S REFERRED FRAMEWORK
EMPLOYEES IN A AMOUNT WHICH
WOULD MAKE FOR REC THAT ARE WITH
AND EXPANSIVE IN THE SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED ADDITIONALLY CBO'S
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
COMBATING MISINFORMATION
DISINFORMATION ABOUT PREVENTING
TEEN IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE EMPOWERED TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
OUR HEALTH JUST THE CBO'S ARE
ENGAGED IN FOUNDED AND FUNDED TO
ADVANCE EQUITY IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER. THE RELEVANCE. GAUGE AND
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S ABOUT
pHAVE FACTUAL OBJECTIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION THIS ALIGNS WITH
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BY
PREVIOUS CALIFORNIA LEGISLATION
AS FAR BACK AS TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE THE SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND INEQUITIES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES BEAR LEAVES NO ROOM.
UNDER FOR THE HEALTH AND-
UNITY'S NOT WITH YEARS OF
PERSISTENT INEQUITIES NOT WHEN
LATEST OBJECTIVE MEDICALLY
ACCURATE INFORMATION IF THE
INFORMATION EXISTS AND HAS BEEN
AGREED UPON COMMUNITIES SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS FOR
THEIR HEALTH THIS BILL SIMPLY
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR A
LONG TERM SYSTEMIC SOLUTION.
SUPPORT THANK YOU BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ON THAT PROVIDE
MEDICALLY ACCURATE CULTURALLY
CONGRUENT COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION UP PROVIDE AS PROUD
SPONSORS OF A AS HOW CLOSE
MONSTERS OF AB TWO TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX I RESPECTFULLY URGE.
THE. OKAY SO THE WORSE THINGS
HAPPEN TODAY. A LOOK OPEN OKAY
I'M SORRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE'LL GO TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. MY NAME IS DR
. MY NAME IS DR KURT COASTER. I
HAVE BEEN A BOARD CERTIFIED
CALIFORNIA LICENSE POSITIONS OF
OBGYN SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
AND WITH OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
COMPREHENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN ALL
AREAS OF OBGYN AT KAISER
PERMANENTE. AB ON TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX AMENDS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO TARGET VALID
LEGITIMATE CALIFORNIA PREGNANCY
CLINICS SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY- AND
- CLINIC IN ROSEVILLE I
SUPERVISE ALL MEDICAL ASPECTS OF
CLINICAL OPERATIONS. WE OFFER
VITAL MEDICAL SERVICES PROVIDING
CRITICAL PRENATAL CARE THAT
MEDICARE DOES NOT PROVIDE IN THE
EARLIEST STAGES OF PREGNANCY S.
CHIEF OF REPRODUCTIVE SURGERY AT
KAISER FOR TWELVE YEARS I KNOW
THAT ULTRASOUNDS A STATION OF
DATING IS THE MOST CRITICAL
ASPECTS OF PRENATAL CARE. WOMEN
DELIVER TOO EARLY TOO LATE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY NEVER
RECEIVED AN ULTRASOUND TO DATE
THEIR PREGNANCY. WOMEN FIGURING
OUT THEIR OWN DUE DATES ARE
OFTEN OFF BY. AND THIS IS
CRUCIAL THE COMPROMISES CARE.
THERE ARE NOT THAT MANY
PROVIDERS WHO WILL ACCEPT
MEDICARE PATIENTS ESPECIALLY FOR
OF VERY EARLY PRENATAL CARE
STATE PAPERWORK CAN TAKE WEEKS
TO COME THROUGH. AND MEDICARE
WILL NOT PROVIDE EARLY
ULTRASOUNDS TO DATE PREGNANCIES
UNTIL THE PAPERWORK COMES
THROUGH BUT PREGNANCY CLINICS DO
AND WE DO IT FOR FREE. FOR A
MEDIC CAL THESE FREE ULTRASOUND
. IDENTIFY MISCARRIAGES AND
ECTOPIC PREGNANCIES THAT
MEDICARE WOULD MISS WHILE THE
WOMAN IS WAITING FOR THE
PAPERWORK TO PROCESS. FOR YOU
SEE CLINICS ALLOW FOR QUICK
MEDICAL INTERVENTION BEFORE THE
ECTOPIC PREGNANCY CAN RUPTURE.
MEN'S LIVES. YET AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX TARGETS THESE
PREGNANCY CLINICS FOR
DESTRUCTION CALLING THEM FAKE.
THE BILL FAVORS- GRANT GIVING
GRANTS TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE ABORTIONS AND COMPLETELY
EXCLUDES PREGNANCY CLINICS THAT
DO NOT. THIS EXCLUSION PRACTICE
WILL ADVERSELY IMPACT WOMEN'S
HEALTH REDUCING ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE FOR THIS REASON I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. DR VANCE AND LONG I HAVE
SERVED AS THE CHIEF OF THE OBGYN
FOR THE KAISER NORTH VALLEY AREA
IN THE PAST I ALSO HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE AT THE PRE PREGNANCY
HELP CLINICS IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA THE KIND OF CLINICS THAT AB
TWO FIVE EIGHT SIX CALLS FAKE
THERE'S AN ARDUOUS PROCESS OF
BECOMING A LICENSED MEDICAL
CLINIC IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH TO THE DETAIL
DID INSPECTOR FROM THE DROP
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
HAVE APPROVED A FAKE CLINIC I
HAVE HAD THE PERSPECTIVE OF
PERSONALLY REVIEWING THE QUALITY
OF CARE. AS A MEDICAL.
ULTRASONOGRAPHY FOR AND A
REVIEWER MEDICAL RECORDS IN MY
PROFESSIONAL OPINION THEIR
STANDARD OF CARE EQUALS OR
EXCEEDS WHAT I EXPERIENCED AT
KAISER THE PROFESSIONALS WHO
PERFORM ULTRASOUNDS OF THESE
PREGNANCY CLINICS ARE LICENSE. A
RICH AND THAT IT HERE IS TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS IN ADDITION TO
PREGNANCY ULTRASOUNDS THE
SERVICES PROVIDED A PREGNANCY
HEALTH CLINICS INCLUDE TESTING
FOR SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS PRENATAL CARE WELLMAN
CHECKS PAP SMEARS AND
REPRODUCTIVE GRIEF COUNSELING
PREGNANCY HELP CLINICS ARE THE
ONLY TRUE FREE CLINICS THAT I AM
AWARE OF THERE IS NO CHARGE TO
ANY PATIENT FOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND NO GOVERNMENTAL OR
TAX DOLLARS ARE USED TO FUND THE
CLINIC OPERATING EXPENSES. I
BELIEVE THAT PREGNANCY HEALTH
CLINICS ARE A MODEL FOR THE
FUTURE OF HEALTH CARE IN THIS
COUNTRY. WE WANTED TO IDENTIFY
IF A CLINIC. ON REVIEWS IN-
GOOGLE AND YELP HE LAND
PARENTHOOD FACILITIES ARE LUCKY
TO HIT THREE WHILE THE PRANKS HE
HELP CLINICS HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA ARE AVERAGING
WELL ABOVE FOUR POINT FIVE WE
OFTEN MEET WOMEN WHO'VE LEFT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINICS AND
DISCUSSED THEY WERE PREVENTED
FROM SEEING THEIR BABIES ON
ULTRASOUND WHEN THEY ASKED IF
THEY COULD CONTINUE THEIR
PREGNANCY CARE WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THEY WERE. TURNED
AWAY THE PHRASE ALL WE DO HERE
IS ABORTIONS ECHOES ALSO HANDED
. ANOTHER FOR CLINIC IN
SACRAMENTO USED UNLICENSED
UNTRAINED STAFF TO PERFORM
OBSTETRICAL ULTRASOUND WITH
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES THE
GROSS MISCALCULATION OF JUST A
TIONAL EIGHT CENTS A BABY TO
EXTRA PRE MATURITY WITH THE
ATTENDANT RISKS OF BLINDNESS
BLEEDING INTO THE BRAIN ABNORMAL
IN DEPLOYMENT AND INTELLECTUAL
IMPAIRMENT. B. TWO FIVE EIGHT
SIX NOT ONLY PURPOSE THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ABORTION BUSINESS
MODEL IT EXCLUDES. CARE
ORGANIZATION SOLELY BASED ON
THEIR PROFESSIONAL POINT. THIS
BILL IS EVIDENCE OF
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CONTENT BASED
RESTRICTION ABRIDGING THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH PROTECTED BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT SIX DOES NOT ADVANCE EIGHT
LEGITIMATE REGULATORY GOAL IT
SEEKS TO REWARD THE ABORTION
LOBBY AND ALSO TO ELIMINATE PRO
LIFE CLINICS BECAUSE THEY WILL
NOT PERFORM ABORTIONS FOR ALL
THESE REASONS I STRONGLY THOSE
EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHT SIX AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE. NOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE WERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE- WE'RE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
. THE AIM PHYSICIAN ON THE BILL
AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. THANK THANK YOU. TO THE
DEER SACRAMENTO OPPOSED WILL
THANK YOU. I OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. IN APRIL OF PLASTIC
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED THE BAIL
THANK YOU. BUT AS THE GONZALES
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LOOKING
AS FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE WHO
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB TWO
FIVE EIGHT SIX AND INSTRUCTS THE
PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GENERAL LIVE VERY HOVIS ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ALINA CHÁVEZ ON BEHALF OF
TEACH IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT OF EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
FOR STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PRACHI PREEMINENT FAMILY
MEDICINE RESIDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BETHANY
GOLDEN R. N. NURSE MIDWIFE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BRENT
SPENCE REPRESENTS THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK FIFTY
S. OKAY WHAT THE AUTHORS OFFICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH GIVE.
PRESIDENT AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MALAYSIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU YOUR-
ANDREA RIVERA FROM SAMPOERNA
DINO. THIS BILL TO GIVE. MY NAME
IS BEVERLY BECKLEY AMATEURS DOWN
TECHNOLOGIST AT THE SAN MARINO
PREGNANCY AND FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. KERN K. KERRY FROM THE
SAMBAR DINO PREGNANCY AND FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU. GAIL
MITCHELL RN FROM THE SAMBAR DINO
PREGNANCY AND FAMILY. ONLY
OPPOSE IF. STEPHANIE GUSTIN THE
OTHER FROM SAN MARINO CALIFORNIA
CHARACTER. YEAH GIVE. KATHLEEN
JONES. SAMBAR DINO PREGNANCY
FAMILY RESOURCE BILL. AS AND I
URGE YOU TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTIES. SO YOU
BATES SAMBAR DINO PREGNANCY AND
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL GIVE. MY NAME
IS THE. AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO FIND SO
THAT A PROPER. KEEP SESSION AND
OR AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. GOING TO
WHITE EIGHTEEN AWAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SECULAR BIOLOGY
WITH ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE OUT BECAUSE ON CERTAIN.
YES THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
EIGHTEEN THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES NICOLE YOUNG PLASTER
COUNTY HIGH STRONGLY OPPOSE
ITSELF THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTEEN OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE SEVEN ZERO NINE.
CRISTINA FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RAIMES SEVENTEEN
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MARY HOAGLAND- NUMBER IN A
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IF. THANK YOU ONE FIFTEEN FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE
CALL. YES- I AM. THANK YOU THANK
YOU I'M A LOT THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TICKET
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE- STRONG
SUPPORT AND PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
THIS IS MEYER DURAN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ITS WHEN HOW LORING
FOR REPRODUCTIVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. YOU NINE
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK. STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE STOCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT. I MANY.
WELL. THE THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH. TWENTY
FIVE EIGHT. THANK YOU. ONE SIX
EIGHT FOUR. I AM. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. THE
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY MISS AGUILAR CURRY THE MOTION
WOULD BE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. IN NO COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS SIR GARCIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. SHE DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON WATER
NOW AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
. HELLO A REAL REAL AYE FLORA.
MCCARTY I THIS AREA NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ. ROTH. SEVEN VOTES ONE SHY BUT WILL
BE THE VILLAIN CALL. BESIDES
MISTER GIBSON.
OVER THE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I KNOW IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY I THANK YOU FOR ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL-
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT- A. B.
THE BILL THAT CLARIFIES WHO CAN
HELP. MAKE WHEN AN ADULT PATIENT
CANNOT MAKE THOSE DECISIONS. OF
THE FOR THE MOVING THE BILL AND
STOP. JUST MOVED TO. SO THAT
THEY CAN- HAVE BIRDS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. JOINING ME. AND ITSELF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA'S SENIOR LET
. OF INTRODUCED HIMSELF. AND WE. IN ALMOST GOOD EVENING TO ALL
OF YOU ARE- AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
. I'M A GERIATRIC PHYSICIAN FROM
SANTA CLARITA. MAN DISABLED ARE. I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
THE RECENT PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY COMMISSION.
IF PART IN A MATTER. FOR THREE
YEARS I COME TO YOU IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
GIPSON. AN EMERGENCY CASE WAS
BROUGHT BEFORE US WITH FAMILY
REQUESTING THEY MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS FOR THEIR HOSPITALIZED
LOVE ONE. THE PATIENT WAS
ADMITTED UNCONSCIOUS. ONE A
VENTILATOR HE DID NOT HAVE AN.
WHO WOULD BE. ATTORNEYS FROM THE
HOUSE. GIVEN THE RIGHT TO
DISCONNECT THE VENTILATOR WHICH
THEY ARGUED WAS CALIFORNIA LAW
INDEED. THEN AND NOW THEY ARE
CORRECT. YEAH CAN THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS. ONE AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WHAT HAD NEXT OF
KIN TO CALIFORNIA LAW PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF. AND THOSE WHO ARE
MARKED. REMOVES THE THREAT.
HOSPITAL. THE SACRED RIGHT. FROM
FAMILY. THE HOSPITAL NOT. OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL AND RETURN HOME
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. AB
TWO THREE THREE EIGHT I'M ROBIN
CLOUGH AND I WORK AT THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY SENIOR CENTER. HE
AND BEYOND. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIORLEGISLATURE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS AND A U.
W. I COME TO YOU TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE THREE
EIGHT PROPOSED BY THE- THEN.
THIS IS. TWO THREE. A PRESENT
LAW. FOR THOSE ADULTS. DIRECTIVE
A POWER OF ATTORNEY. ADMISSION
IT WOULD PROTECT PATIENTS AND
FAMILIES ALLOWING NEXT OF KIN.
FORTY SIX OF FIFTY ONE STATES
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT. STATION. THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS
FOR. THIS IS A. MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THIS LAW IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THAT IS
WHY I URGE YEAR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB TWO THREE THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU. IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
. AND POSITION ON THE. BRENT.
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIM. ANYONE ELSE.
IS A RIGHT TO SPEAK FOR MISTER
POSITION ON THE BILL IDEA. KEEPS
CUTTING IN AND OUT. RICHARD
GATES OPENS COUNTY I SUPPORT. NO
SIR. THIS WAS THE BILL JUST YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE POSITION ON THE
BILL. ONE EIGHT ZERO AT THIS
TIME.
ONE SEVEN TWO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT THAT SHORT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR CATHOLIC
HEALTHCARE WE'VE BEEN OPPOSED TO. WORKING WITH US AND WE CAN SIT
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE. THANK YOU. ONE TWO
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THROUGH THE SAID. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS CAME
AND IMMEDIATELY HAPPY THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION PRITCHETT THE WORK WITH
THE OFFICE. THANK YOU. I'M A. AN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OF EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW MY NAME
IS STEVEDORES. STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL A. B. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK. TEN FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE BEEN CUT. THROUGH TO US SO
WE ARE. OKAY.
ON THE PHONE MIND.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE JUST GOING
TO BRING IT BACK. BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE QUESTIONS ARE
COMMON.
THE CHAIR IN THE.
R. P. NEED A MAKE. BOTH. PASSES
AMENDED THANK YOU. YOUR CURRENT
ADDRESS. BUT THEY'RE IN A HIGH
RISK.
YOU TAKE JUST A SECOND HERE.
OR SOMETHING CHANGES. NOW.
MEMBERS.
INCIDENCE OF ANXIETY DEPRESSION.
ALREADY HAS THE LOWEST RATIO OF
LICENSED.
THAT. PROBLEMS.
RETENTION INSTEAD. AFTER.
THE ALREADY OPEN. IS.
COUNTY.
TWENTY FIVE.
CREDIBLE. WHEN WE LOOK AT THE.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
TRANSLATE INTO.
I KNOW THAT.
KERRY. UNFORTUNATELY THEME.
THEN DEMONSTRATED THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE. BUT ALL OF THAT DESPITE
THE-
FIFTY. DISCIPLINES.
PERFECT OKAY. WHAT.
HEY GOOD EVENING MEMBERS I.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINE.
READING.
AREAS.
WE'RE TRAINED.
PROVIDERS BETTER.
EVEN IF YOU'RE.
THEY NEED TO.
OUR GREAT.
REPRESENTATIVE.
WHEN.
FORTY THOUSAND BALL.
PLEASE.
ALL.
THANK YOU. YOU Y.
JERRY. PRACTICE I HAVE SEEN.
I'VE WORKED.
TRANSPORT.
AND.
HELLO EIGHTEEN TAKING ME. NEVER
YEAH.
YEAH. THIS IS.
BECAUSE OF THE YEAH THE FEDERAL.
OUR. AN HOUR AND HALF OF THE
PEOPLE. SO WHY. LAST YEAR.
BUT. OKAY.
GONNA BE A BEAUTIFUL NIGHT YEAH
. EVERYONE HAS MY. YES
WASHINGTON. YEAH.
BACK.
OKAY JEFF.
YEAH THANK.
WELL.
THE OPERATOR YEP OKAY YOU. ARE
SOME OUTPUT IN THE MAIN
CONFERENCE I THANK YOU MA'AM.
YOUR WHAT. THE NEXT FIFTY.
HELLO EIGHTY TEACHERS DOING A
QUICK TEST CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
I SURE CAN. I THANK YOU. WELCOME.
CHECK CHECK. WE CAN HEAR YOU ON
THE PHONE LINES. YEAH.
WE'RE WE'RE WAITING FOR THREE
MEMBERS OF THE WE CAN RECONVENE
THE MEETING SO- IF THEY'RE
LISTENING OUT THERE MR MCCARTY
MISS WALDRON MISTER NAZARIAN
PLEASE COME TO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
START. UNTIL YOU COME HERE WE'VE
GOT ELEVEN OTHER MEMBERS
ANXIOUSLY AWAITING YOUR ARRIVAL.
OKAY HI THERE M. THANK YOU OF
AND FIRST I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED- BUT WE ARE. I WILL
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO. WE ARE GOING TO
VOTE ON THE BILLS THAT WE HEARD
PRIOR TO THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THAT WE HAD SO- I
WILL LIST OUT THE BILLS THAT WE
HEARD TOOK TESTIMONY ON TOOK
TELEPHONE TESTIMONY ON. THOSE OF
THE BILLS WE WILL VOTE ON WE
WILL ALSO BE VOTING ON OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH DO NOT
REQUIRE ANY WITNESSES. BECAUSE
THEY WERE ON WHAT WE CALL
CONSENT. MMHM THE BILLS THAT
WERE NOT HEARD TODAY WILL BE
CARRIED OVER TO INTO A FUTURE
HEARING- NEXT WEEK. AND OF THE
BILLS THAT WE HEARD. BUT HAD
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ASKED FOR A MOTION TO STRIKE THE
VOTE. AND WE WILL RE HERE THOSE
BILLS ARE THREE OF THEM- NEXT
WEEK AS WELL. SO WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS TO FIRST ASK FOR A
MOTION TO STRIKE THE BOAT. I
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THAT THE MOTION IS TO STRIKE THE
ROLE ON. THETHREE BILLS THEY
WILL BE AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. AND
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
BY MS PETRIE-NORRIS THOSE SO I
WILL ASK A MATTER SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL ON STRIKING THE
VOTE FOR THOSE BILLS. WE DO THIS
IN ONE MOTION FOR EACH BILL SO
WE WILL SO I WAS JUST GIVING YOU
THE IDEA SO. THE MOTION- BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO. THE STRIKE THE VOTE ON
A B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
BY MISTER GIPSON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL CALL THE
ROLL. I WOULD I WOULD I WALDRON
. AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO REAL AYE
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN
I RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I KALRA. I. THIRTEEN ZERO THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO TO STRIKE THE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY THREE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY MISTER GIPSON. WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND TO STRIKE
THE ROLE ON AB TWENTY FIVE TROOP
TWENTY TWO BY MR GRAY THE
MOTIONS BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE
SECONDS BY MR SANTIAGO. AND I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WOOD I WOULD I WALDRON.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO REAL AYE
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN MAJOR
AND I MAYES. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN I REQUEST.
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO OKAY- I KALRA. ALL
RIGHT ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO AND
FINALLY- THE MOTION AND A
SECOND- TO. STRIKE THE ROLE ON
A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS EMOTIONS BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO RIO I FLORA.
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MCCARTY. MCCARTY I IN
HIS AREA THE VERY AND I REQUEST
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I KALRA.
ALL RIGHT THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN
ZERO SO THESE BILLS WILL WE WILL
BE RE PRESENTED AT OUR NEXT
HEARING- WHICH WILL BE. LIKELY
LIKELY NEXT TUESDAY- WE WILL BUT
I WOULD ASK PEOPLE TO CHECK THE
FILE NOTICE CHECK CHECK FOR FILE
KNOWS DO RECOGNIZE THAT IT PART
OF A PART WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
. THE BILLS IT DID NOT GET HER
TODAY WILL BE RE NOTICED AND
HEARD AND OUR NEXT HEARING.
THERE ARE SOME BILLS THAT ARE
DOUBLE REFERRED WE WILL BE- WILL
BE WORKING OUT WORKING THAT OUT-
THROUGH FILED NOTICE- AND AT
POTENTIALLY ASKING FOR- WHATEVER
ACCOMMODATIONS WE NEED TO DO TO
DO THAT. BUT UP TO YOUR BILL
THAT MAY BE ADDED BILLS DOUBLE
REFERRED TO A COMMITTEE IT MAY
BE HEARD IN THAT SECOND THAT
COMMITTEE BEFORE IT'S HEARD BY
US BUT- WE'LL WE'LL FIGURE ALL
THE LOGISTICS OF THAT OUT- LATER
ON. SO WHAT I DID WAS I WHAT I'D
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN AT THIS POINT
IS A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. US WE HAVE- MISS
CARILLO- MOTIONS- MR BIGELOW
SECONDS. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF- ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY BY DOCTOR
REGULAR. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIA
BONTA. AND NUMBER EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. CHOI ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE BY SOME M. I'M SORRY I'VE
I'VE NEVER EIGHT. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI. AND RIVER TWELVE AB TWENTY
FIVE ELEVEN BY MISS IRWIN. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX BY MR QUIRK.
AND ADD ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION. AND A SECOND. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CARILLO. RIO AYE FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. VERY AND I RIVAS RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA. OVER
I THIRTEEN SIR AS THIRTEEN ZERO
SO WE WILL NOW VOTE ON- I WE
WILL ACTUALLY- VOTE ON THE WE
HAD A QUORUM SO WE HAD WE'RE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH QUORUM FOR ALL
THESE BILLS. BERMAN ASK MADAM
SECRETARY THE OPEN THE ROLE-
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON A B.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY DR
ARAMBULA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THIS AREA THE
SYRIAN I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING KALRA. ALL
RIGHT NOT VOTING. ALL RIGHT
KARAI. AND THE TO THE VOTERS
TENDED TO. IT IS OUT THE BILLS
OUT UNTENDED UNATTENDED YOU
ABOUT ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA. I REMEMBER SIX AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE ARAMBULA
AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW I. FLORA
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE
ITEM NUMBER SIX BY MISTER BRYANT
SANTIAGO AYE KALRA. ALL RIGHT.
FOURTEEN ZERO. OKAY EVERYBODY
LISTEN ALL WE'RE GONNA NEXT ONE
DOWN EVERYBODY LISTENING OKAY
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARILLO. MS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA
. ALL RIGHT I. 11-3 THAT IS A
LOOK THAT'S ELEVEN TO THREE. I
DON'T NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA- PLEASE. IN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO FLORA FLORA NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA
ALL RIGHT I. LIVE IN A THREE
THAT'S A LEVIN TO THREE AND
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KALRA
ALL RIGHT. 11-3 THAT IS A LEVEL
THREE THAT BILLS OUT AS WELL. I
BELIEVE UNLESS I'VE FORGOTTEN
SOMETHING WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
I HAVE THAT WE CAN NOW- MISTER
SUN HERE DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION. WE DIDN'T WE DID NOT HEAR THAT
BILLION. SO WE WILL- SO I JUST
WANNA WARN YOU FOLKS NEXT
TUESDAY IS GONNA BE A VERY VERY
LONG HEARING WE HAVE ABOUT AND
PLUS BILLS WE DIDN'T HERE
TONIGHT. BUS FORTY SIX BILLS. SO
NO I'M NOT KIDDING I'M SORRY. WE
CAN'T STARTED IN THE MORNING WE
CAN'T I WILL WE'LL WE'LL FIGURE
WE'LL TRY TO FIGURE SOME OPTION
OUT WE'LL TRY TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT BUT- BUT- NEXT
TUESDAY WILL BE A VERY VERY LONG
DAY. SO PLEASE BEAR THAT IN
MIND. PLEASE DON'T GO ANYWHERE
DON'T PLAN ANY DINNERS. CANCEL
YOUR FLIGHTS PARDON. WE'LL GET
AYE WILL HAVE FOOD FOR YOU. I
WOULD HAVE FOOD FOR YOU. YOU
WILL GET ONE HAPPY MAIL KNOW
WHAT ELSE WE GET ANYTHING. ALL
RIGHT SO WITH THAT SO WE WILL WE
WILL NOW ADJOURN THE MEETING
UNTIL- AND WE WILL. COME BACK
NEXT TUESDAY AND TRY AGAIN. R.
THANK YOU.